SENATE ON HEALTH WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AT TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING FACE COMING
GUIDELINES. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES TO IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE AND TEN
TWENTY ONE BOWSTREET AND HEARING
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. PASSED ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SO THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM AND BEGAN OUR
HEARING. TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS
WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WE
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED TO OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE FOUR ONE. ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE. OR SENATE WEBSITE. OF
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CLOSE THE
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE ON MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO WHITE
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM THERE IT IS NECESSARY-
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
IN A REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS ISAAC COMMITTEE CHAIR.
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED TO COME OUT OF TIME TO
BE DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR WHICH
HERE AND HEALTH COMMITTEE IS.
TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS FOR TWO
WITNESSES FOR TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
ON EACH SIDE. AGAIN IT'S FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THE COMMON SURNAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURES. I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE ELEVEN ITEMS
TODAY'S HEARING- ALSO NOTE THAT
WE DO HAVE ONE ABSENT MEMBERS
HERE TODAY- SO THEREFORE WE'RE
GOING TO FOR- FOR- ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR- BITE
CENTER PAN MYSELF WILL BE
RESCHEDULED WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR DAY FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB TEN TWENTY
THREE I SENT HER TADO AND- THAT
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB TEN NINETEEN- THE
ABSENCES THERE IS ALSO BE
PRESENT BY CENTER EGGMAN- AND
SEE WE ARE NOT WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM YET. SO WE SHALL BECOME-
BEGAN AS A SUB COMMITTEE- AND
SO- I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- WE
DO HAVE CEREMONY HERE SO WE WILL
BEGIN- I'M SORRY TO SAY IS A
QUESTION WE HAVE ONE PERSON
ABSENT FROM COMMITTEE TODAY. YES
THAT WHAT YOU SAID. YES AND WHO
IS THAT. IS THAT CENTER GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ OKAY BUT WE HAVE CENTER
LEYVA AND CENTER EGGMAN WHO WILL
BE HERE LATER IS THAT CORRECT.
AND SENATOR GRAHAM THE OTHER
MEMBERS YES OKAY. OKAY BECAUSE
YOU SAID WE ARE MOVING. ITEM
NUMBER ONE BECAUSE ONE MEMBERS
ABSENT I SAID WE WERE SCHEDULING
ITEM NUMBER ONE YEAH BECAUSE
WHEN MEMBERS ABSENT. AND
RESCHEDULING ITEM NUMBER ONE
OKAY I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
ANDERSON RIGHT BECAUSE I HEARD
YOU SAY WHEN ONE MEMBER
ABSTAINED SAYING THAT I'M
RESCHEDULING ITEM NUMBER ONE
OKAY THANK YOU. I MAY NOT THAT
THERE'S ONE APPS MEMBER BUT
HIGHLIGHTS US THAT'S THE TWO ARE
NECESSARY. OKAY ALL RIGHT. OKAY
SO WHAT I WILL GO TO GO AND AS
COMMITTEE. AND THEN WILL BEGIN
WITH- ITEM NUMBER THREE BY. A
SETTLEMENT. WELCOME. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I WANTED TO
START BY FIRST ACCEPTING OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. THE GOAL
OF SB NINE FIVE EIGHT IS TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS WITH
COMPLEX AND LIFE THREATENING
ILLNESSES WHO NEED. SPECIAL TEA
INFUSED OR INJECTED MEDICATIONS
ADMINISTERED BY A DOCTOR OR
NURSE. SUCH AS CHEMOTHERAPY CAN
RECEIVE THE NECESSARY MEDICATION
IN A SAFE AND TIMELY MANNER. THE
PATIENTS TO RECEIVE THE
SPECIALTY MEDICATIONS ARE OFTEN
OUR MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS
SUCH AS CHILDREN WITH LIFE
THREATENING ILLNESSES. OR FRAIL
OR ELDERLY ADULTS. HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO KEEP THESE
MEDICATIONS IN STOCK SO THEY ARE
AVAILABLE WHENEVER NEEDED.
TRADITIONALLY A PATIENT SEES
THEIR DOCTOR FOR ONE OF THESE
CONDITIONS. AND BASED ON THE
SAME DAY TESTING AND MEDICATION.
IS ADMINISTERED BY THE DOCTOR.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SAME DAY TEST MAY LEAD TO THE
DOCTOR TO CHANGE THE MEDICATION
STRENGTH OR PRESCRIBED A
DIFFERENT DRUG ALL TOGETHER.
THIS PARTICULARLY APPLIES TO
CHILDREN WHO FLUCTUATE IN WEIGHT
AND ILLNESS PROGRESSION.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE POLICIES
THAT RESTRICT PATIENT ACCESS TO
THESE IMPORTANT MEDICATIONS
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING. A HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER TO USE THE
MEDICAID THE MEDICATION ON HAND
THERE ARE POLICIES THAT REQUIRE
DOCTOR TO CALL ON THE HEALTH
PLAN. THANKS TO CALL THE HEALTH
PLAN'S PREFERRED VENDOR. THE
VENDOR THEN SHIPS THE MEDICATION
TO THE WELL TO THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER LABELED. SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE PATIENT FOR THIS PATIENT
THIS PROCESS IS KNOWN AS WHITE
BAGGY WHITE BACKING CAN RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANTLY DAY DELAYED
TREATMENT WHICH MAY CUT THE
PATIENT'S HEALTH AT RISK FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE SAME DAY TEST
REQUIRES. A DIFFERENT STRENGTH
OR DIFFERENT MEDICATION THEN THE
MEDICAL PROVIDER MUST RE ORDERED
THE MEDICATION AND RESCHEDULE
THE APPOINTMENT AS A RESULT THIS
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY DELAY
TREATMENT AND IMPACT. HEALTH OF
THE PATIENT. SINCE PREPARE
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY FOR V.
DAY TREATMENT. THE ARRANGED THE
IS THE ARRANGE TIME OFF WORK
COORDINATE RIDES AND SCHEDULE
BABYSITTERS REQUIRING THE
PATIENT TO WAIT FOR THE HEALTH
PLAN TO RANGE TO HAVE THE
MEDICATION SHIPPED OR NEEDING TO
RESCHEDULE THE WHOLE APPOINTMENT
BECAUSE THE MEDICATION WAS NOT
CORRECT OR DID NOT ARRIVE ON
TIME NOT ONLY CAUSES UNDUE
STRESS BUT IT IS DETRIMENTAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE OVERALL
TREATMENT PLAN. WHILE SOME
ALLEGE COST SAVINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH WHITE BAGGING IT SHOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THERE IS NOT
TANGIBLE SAVINGS BUT RATHER A
COST SHIFT. A RECENT STUDY FOUND
THAT WHITE BACKING COST
HOSPITAL'S OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY. THIS IS
BECAUSE WHITE BACKING POLICIES
OFTEN REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO SPEND
ADDITIONAL TIME COORDINATING
COVERAGE WITH THE PATIENTS
INSURERS PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGER AND DISPENSING PHARMACY.
IN ADDITION TO CORRECTING
MEDICATION ISSUES AND DISPENSING
MEDICATIONS. FINALLY THESE
MEDICATIONS ARE SO SPECIALIZED
BE REQUIRE COMPLEX HANDLING AND
THERE HAVE BEEN EXAMPLES OF
DRUGS NOT BEING SHIPPED PROPERLY
. FOR EXAMPLE A SPECIALTY DRUG
SAT AND REFRIGERATED FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME WHICH REQUIRED
THE FACILITY TO THROW AWAY THE
DRUG THAT PATIENT DID NOT
RECEIVE THEIR CHEMOTHERAPY WHICH
DELAYED CARE AND ALLOWED THE
CANCER. AND ALLOW THE CANCER TO
PROGRESS THE GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS NOT TO PROHIBIT WHITE BAGGING
COMPLETELY. THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO PUT APPROPRIATE
GUARDRAILS AROUND THE PRACTICE
TO PREVENT DELAYED CARE.
SUBOPTIMAL CARE PATIENT DISTRESS
AND UNNECESSARY UNNECESSARY
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS. THIS BILL
HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT PROTECTING
PATIENTS I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO STRIKE THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE THAT
PROTECTS PATIENTS TODAY WE HAVE
MELISSA CHASE WITH VALLEYS
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL HEALTH CARE
AND DOCTOR AT DISNEYLAND LEAD A
CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF PEDIATRICS
AND RHEUMATOLOGY AT STANFORD IS.
S. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU CEREMONY- CONSULTANT.
BECAUSE OF. I THINK WE HAVE
CORMORANT- YES CAN PLEASE A CALL
ROLL TO STAY QUO. PAN HERE
MELINDA'S EGGMAN YOUR GONZALEZ
GROVE FURTADO LEYVA YOUR LEÓN
HERE ROTH- RUBIO PRESENCE WIENER. OKAY QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINE FIFTY
EIGHT- WE HAVE- MOSA CHASE AND
DR HIS ONLY LEE- DATE OF BIRTH
BY THE PHONE SO- SO- ACTUALLY
MODERATOR PLEASE- BRING THEM
ONTO THE PHONE LINE SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH A MELISSA CHASE YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOR
MINUTES. BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
- FIBER OPEN. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MELISSA CHASE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF PHARMACY FOR
VALLEY CHILDREN'S HEALTH CARE I
HAVE BEEN A PRACTICING
PHARMACIST FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY ON SB
NINE FIVE AIDS THE MEDICATION
AND PATIENT SAFETY ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SB NINE FIVE EIGHT
WOULD IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS ON
HEALTH PLANS REQUIREMENT THAT
HOSPITALS USED TO HOLD THE
PHARMACIES FOR CERTAIN
MEDICATIONS INCLUDING INFUSION
DRUGS THIS REQUIREMENT HAS
NEGATIVE IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR
PATIENTS AND REQUIRES THAT
VALLEY CHILDREN'S COMMIT EXTRA
RESOURCES TO ENSURE OUR PATIENTS
RECEIVE THEIR LIFESAVING
MEDICATION IN A TIMELY MANNER I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE STORIES WITH
YOU THE STORY AS OF APRIL ONE OF
OUR PATIENTS TO HIGHLIGHT HOW
DISRUPTIVE THIS PRACTICE CAN BE.
APRIL IS BEING TREATED AT VALLEY
CHILDREN'S FOR CROHN'S DISEASE
WITH AN ABSCESS THE ABOUT AFTER
AN INITIAL HOSPITAL INPATIENT
STAY APRIL DISTORTION CONTINUES
WITH MEDICATION THERAPY SIX
WEEKS AFTER DISCHARGE HER
DISEASE FLARES IN APRIL DOCTORS
DECIDE TO START ON A DRUG CALLED
REMICADE AFTER AN INITIAL DENIAL
THE HEALTH PLAN EVENTUALLY
APPROVED REMICADE BUT ONLY FOR
TWO DOSES APRIL RECEIVE THE TO
INFUSIONS IN A SAFE AND TIMELY
MANNER FROM VALLEY CHILDREN'S
EMAIL TORRANCE USING CLINIC WITH
MEDICATIONS FROM THE INPATIENT
PHARMACY. WE THEN SUBMIT A
SECOND AUTHORIZATION REQUEST TO
CONTINUE REMICADE BUT APRIL
HEALTH PLAN REQUIRES THAT THE
MEDICATION NOW BE WHITE ACT
MEANING THAT THE DRUG WILL BE
SHIPPED FROM A SPECIALTY
PHARMACY TO VALLEY CHILDREN'S
APRIL ARRIVES AT OUR CLINIC FOR
HER SCHEDULE THIRD INFUSION BUT
THE MEDICATION DOES NOT ARRIVE
IN TIME FROM THE SPECIALTY
PHARMACY WHICH IS LOCATED IN NEW
YORK STATE TO VALLEY CHILDREN'S
RESCHEDULED HER APPOINTMENT THE
LITTLE RED ORDERS REMICADE AGAIN
THIS TIME WAIT FOR THE ARRIVAL
BEFORE SCHEDULING APRIL FOURTH
INFUSION. FINALLY TWENTY FOUR
WEEKS AFTER DISCHARGE APRIL
SCUTTLED FOR HER FOURTH INFUSION
WHICH HAS NOW BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
DELAYED DELIGHT I GAINES THIS
ENTIRE TIME DAILY TO LEARN HOW
REMITTED ON OURSELVES THAT WE
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO USE IT FOR
APRIL DUE TO HEALTH PLANS WHITE
BACKING REQUIREMENTS WHITE
BACKING TO LEAVE HEARING CAN BE
HARMFUL TO PATIENTS I URGE YOU
TO DO IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
PATIENTS BY SUPPORTING SB NINE
FIVE EIGHT I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MUCH NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR- WITH SUPPORT DR.
AT IN. LEE PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS CHAIRMAN- MY IS
YOLANDA AND I'M GOING TO GO
ABOUT OF PEDIATRIC AT TAMPA.
UNIVERSITY WITH BACHELOR'S IN
PEDIATRIC WOMEN'S. I THINK
BENEFITS OUR OVER TWO TWO YEARS
I APPRECIATE THE UP SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY AND- URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
AT THE NINE FIVE EIGHT THE MEDIC
AND PATIENTS ACCESS TWENTY. ECHO
MEN OF THE CAN DO ABOUT MY
BAGGING PRESS DR J. HER. MONEY
AT THE PETER AND PEDIATRIC
SPECIAL I'VE FIRST HAND HOW BUT
HARMFUL OF ON THE WHITE PACKING
QUALITY. MANY OF MY PATIENTS
HAVE CHRONIC AUTO DISEASE
TECHNIQUE ACTUALLY MEDICATION
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY. IN A
WHITE BAG POLICY THE MEDICATIONS
ARE NEW OR CAN'T VERY- WITH THE
FIGHT POLICY THAT HAD MORE FOR
OUR PATIENTS AND FAMILIES TO
JUMP THROUGH HI FIRST MAKES MANY
. BEING DELAYED IN THERE TO GET
BECAUSE OF POLICY WHEN WE
DELAYED ARE PATIENTS RECEIVES
WORK DISEASE AND POTENTIAL THIS
. WHAT I PATIENTS HAD FOR I. AND
WITHOUT THE MEDICARE.
SPECIALTY PHARMACY OUTSIDE THE
STATE A LOT OF TIMES. FROM ONE
PLACE AND THEN BRING IT TO
ANOTHER PLACE FOR ADMINISTRATION
IT HAS INTRODUCED BARRIERS AND
DELAYS. RIGHT DO SUPPORT FOR SB
NINE FIVE EIGHT TODAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP
TO PROTECTING OUR PATIENTS AND
PUTTING THEIR CARE FIRST. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY
PERSPECTIVE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. HI THANKS VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT. NINE FIFTY EIGHT
BEGINS IN HERE AND ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. AND THERE IS A POSITION
ONLY HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTIE
WE SOMEHOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
X. WHEN THIS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO
ON BEHALF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
AFTERNOON MISTER MEMBERS I'M
FRED NO WE'RE REPRESENTING
STANFORD HEALTH CARE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. EXPERTNESS
ROOM. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AMY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
RIGHT THANK YOU. THE KNOWN ELSE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TO WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
ONLY FILL. THIS THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT NINE FIVE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE. ZERO FIVE SIX FIVE.
IT WOULD BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE
FIRST COMMENT OKAY THANK YOU.
BUYING TWO OR FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KELLY
BACKFILLING GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
MEMORIALCARE AND THE HEALTHCARE
DISTRIBUTION ALLIANCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M TO TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY HARDY WITH CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
APPLYING TO NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR
AS- VIDEO BORN WITH THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WHEREIN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M
ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. ARABLE WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU AYE ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CALLING IN
REFERENCE REPRESENTING THE
PARENTS OF CALIFORNIA YEAH WE
ARE- STRONG SUPPORT OF REMOVING
THE PETA FILES. SORRY THIS IS A
THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S DRUM BELT-
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THIS IS REBECCA AND ON THE
PART OF THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU RIGHT THANK
YOU- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- TO- SB
NINE FIFTY EIGHT- SO WE HAVE.
POSTED CAROLINE A VEIL FROM
SOMEONE ELSE FROM ONE. SECOND IT
WOULDN'T LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
SORRY IT WAS- SERGIO-
DISINCENTIVE ALGO WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR POLICY FEDERAL
PROGRAMS AND- BILL HEAD FROM THE
PHARMACY FROM A PHARMACEUTICAL
CARE MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION SO
AGAIN EACH ONE HAS TO WEAR A-
TWO MINUTES SO BRING ON- SERGIO
SANTIAGO WITH A HIP. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY I'M HERE-
AS AS YOU NOTED- MANY
RESEARCHERS SANTIAGO I'M VICE
PRESIDENT DRUG POLICY FOR A HIP-
WE ARE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
WHOSE MEMBERS PROVIDE COVERAGE
OF HEALTHCARE AND RELATED
SERVICES TO MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS EVERY DAY WE ALL
DESERVE ACCESS TO OMPREHENSIVE
QUALITY AFFORDABLE COVERAGE IN A
HIP IS COMMITTED TO ADVANCING
MARKET BASED POLICY SOLUTIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THESE GOALS. I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY WITH TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ON BEHALF
OF OUR MEMBERS TO SHARE SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE FIFTY EIGHT THE PROBLEM
HAS LONG BEEN AND STILL IS THE
PRICE OF DRUGS THERE ARE MANY
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES BEING USED
TO LOWER THESE COSTS FOR
PATIENTS IN SO CALLED WHITE AND
BROWN BAGGING. ARE SUMMONED IN
THIS TEST EMAIL ADDRESS BRIEFLY
BOTH THE SAFETY CONCERNS AND HOW
THESE APPROACHES HELP PATIENTS
AND PLAN SPONSORS SUCH AS
PRIVATE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS UNION
PLANS AND OTHERS BEFORE THESE
HIGH PRICED MEDICATIONS FOR
BACKGROUND LET'S LEVEL SET
REALLY PER QUICKLY ON WHAT WE
ARE DISCUSSING TODAY. BEFORE
WHITE AND BROWN BAGGING PROCESS
BECAME AVAILABLE THE HOSPITAL
CLINIC OR PHYSICIAN PURCHASES
THE DRUG AND BILLS THE PATIENT'S
INSURANCE THIS IS KNOWN AS
BUYING AND BILL. WITH THEIR
COMPENSATION BASED ON A
PERCENTAGE OF THE DRUGS COST
WHICH I'LL EXPLAIN FURTHER IN A
MOMENT. UNDER WHITE AND BROWN
BAGGING PRACTICES THE HOSPITAL
CLINICAL POSITION IS PAID ONLY
FOR THE SERVICES. THEY PROVIDE
NECESSARY TO ADMINISTER THE
COSTS- ADMINISTER THE DRUG. AT
IN A GROCERY TO RATE TO THE
PATIENT BECAUSE THE DRUG IS
PROVIDED TO THEM BY A SPECIALLY
PHARMACIES SEPARATELY. SO CALLED
BROWN BAG INVOLVED ESPECIALLY
PHARMACY SHIPPING THE DIRECT
ELECTRIC WHICH THE PATIENT. WITH
EMBRACE THE BACK ASIAN TO THE
PHYSICIAN FOR ADMINISTRATION.
BOTH APPROACHES DISRUPT THE LONG
ESTABLISHED BY A BILL PRACTICES
THAT WERE. AT THE HEART OF THIS
BILL. WHICH PROPONENTS OF THIS
BILL ARE AIMING TO PROTECT AT
THE EXPENSE OF PATIENTS AND PLAN
SPONSORS. IT IS IMPORTANT
UNDERSCORE THAT HEALTH INSURANCE
PROVIDERS YOU PATIENT SAFETY IS
PARAMOUNT. AND WHAT PATIENTS TO
TAKE THESE CRITICAL DRUGS AT THE
TIME THEY ARE NEEDED. WE KNOW AS
WELL AS ANYONE THE VALUE OF
MAINTAINING OF MAINTAINING
PATIENT ADHERENCE TO MEDICATION
REGIMENS REGIMENS. AND WE WORK
VERY HARD TO PREVENT ANY
DISRUPTIONS IN CARE. OPPONENTS
OF THESE PRACTICES ALLEGE SUCH
PRACTICES ARE UNSAFE. THEY ALSO
ASSERT THAT SHIPMENTS FOR
SPECIALLY PHARMACIES PROVIDERS
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO DRUG SECURITY
I'M SORRY NEVER CHANGE SUPPLY OF
SECURITY ACT. IN OTHER SEAFOOD
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS THIS IS
PATENTLY FALSE. I IN FACT
HOUSEHOLDS GROUP PRACTICES ARE
PROVIDED THEIR OWN STORE
PRODUCTS IN THE SAME FASHION AND
OFTEN DIRECTLY FROM THE SAME
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES. DUE TO
SAFETY FTA SAFETY REQUIREMENTS.
IN OR MANUFACTURE LIMITED
DISTRIBUTION ARRANGEMENTS. SO
WHEN HEALTH INSURERS IMPLANT
IMPLEMENT THESE KINDS OF
POLICIES THEY ALSO HAVE
EXCEPTION PROCESS IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS CIRCUMSTANCES INVOLVING
QUALITY SAFETY MEDICAL NECESSITY
AND OR KAREN RUSSIAN. TWO AND A
HALF MINUTES YOU'RE TAKING TIME
WITH ME OR THE WITNESS RIGHT
OKAY MY OVER. YES OKAY WELL THEN
I'LL WRAP UP AND SAY ALSO THAT
LASTLY- THE OTHER REASON THAT-
THISIS ESPECIALLY NECESSARY
BECAUSE- THESE COSTS ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE THESE DRUGS ARE
EXPENSIVE AND-THE PROVIDERS
SUCH AS HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIANS
ARE NOT SENSITIVE TO PRICING.
AND SPECIALLY PHARMACIES OFFER
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PLANS TO FOR
DRUGS I OTHERWISE COULD NOT
COVER THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO BILL HEAD-
FROM TE PHARMACEUTICAL CARE
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION HIS ON
THE PHONE UNFORTUNATELY A FIRST
WITNESS ONLY LEFT YOU ONE MINUTE
SO. THANK YOU FOR- COMMITTEE
BILL THAT WOULD BE TO MAKE
TRANSPORTATION PROPONENT THANK-
CENTER LAMAR HER EFFORTS TO TRY
TO WORK WITH US AND CRAPPIE
LANGUAGE MAKES IT MORE PALATABLE
APPROACHING THE- BOB. O'CLOCK
THE HI ISSUE I THE PREVIOUS WITH
THAT WHILE. MORE THAN FIFTY S.
FOR THIS FROM IT'S LIKE. COMPLY
WITH ALL STATE THE PHARMACY AND
STATE FEDERAL LAW- AND IS IT.
POSSIBLE THE MARINE. YOU KNOW
SAFE QUALITY DRUGS. AND THIS IS.
ABOUT SAFETY ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE BILL
IMPOSES ON SESAME PHARMACIES
SHOULD BE IMPOSED ON HOSPITAL
PHARMACIES WELL. POSITIONED
SIXTY SHOULD NOT STOP AT THE
HOSPITAL. BUT WHATEVER PATIENTS
PERCEPTIONS ARE THE REPLY TO THE
SPECIALTY PHARMACY. SUPPLY
PEOPLE READY TO. IT'LL PROPERTY
AND WOULD HAVE. COMMITTEE IF
ISN'T ABOUT PENSIONS. WHY WOULD
WE NOT ADDRESS STATES MUST LONG
MEADOW WRONG POPULATION MEDICARE
OUTPATIENT. AND I FIVE FIVE SOME
OF THE PART OF ME. WHAT WE
CANNOT A ON THE IT'S NOT WITH
THE USE SOME OF PLASTIC BUT WE
CAN TO LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH.
THE- THE BILL OFF. AND
SOVEREIGNTY THERE ARE TO GET
REGIONAL SOLUTION THANK FOR
FRANK FACES MUCH ALL RIGHT WELL
NOW MOVES TO THIS WITNESSES AN
OPERA- ESPINO FIFTY EIGHT-
PLEASE APPROACH. SEE ONE COMING
. IF YOU'RE MEMBERS RANDOM ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE.
IN LATE OPPOSE WHICH WE REGRET-
BUT WE DO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS WILLING
TO WORK TOWARDS A SOLUTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYMORE IS A
POSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN BURSTS AT HAMPTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS THAT HEARING
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION S. NINE
FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU SEE NO ONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AND BE AT
NINE FIVE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT A
WAY TO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MISTER CHAIRMAN BREAKS YOU
WALKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I WON SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY. ONE
SEVEN NINE. HELLO. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GIVEN THE NUMBER FOR Q.
AND I'M CALLING BECAUSE- AGAIN
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION OF PANTS AND
THAT THIS IS NOT TO RUN BILL-
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I
WON FIFTY ONE PUPIL ADDS. THE
MIXTURE TO MADDEN REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE I WAS ACTUALLY NOT
INCLUDED IN THE SUPPORT GROUPS
THAT ARE ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE FOR JUMPING
AND LATE I THANK YOU- ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU I'M
TO FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU KRISTIN YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT FOR A
WHILE COMMENTS. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU MOVES NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE CENTER
ADMIN. THANK YOU- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATE LONG FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. SOME OF THE TWO
THINGS THAT REALLY STOOD OUT FOR
ME FROM THE OPPOSITION IS THE
FEAR THAT. THE PATIENTS WILL
SUFFER FROM THIS AND THEN THE
OTHER THING I HEARD VERY CLEARLY
WAS PEOPLE APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS DO YOU SHARE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS ABOUT. PATIENTS
HAVING ACCESS TO MEDICATIONS AND
ARE YOU COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION SO
IT'S BECAUSE OF MY CONCERN WITH
PATIENTS ACT HAVING ACCESS TO
MEDICATION THAT I'M RUNNING THIS
BILL- AND SO I CERTAINLY SHARE
THAT CONCERN AND I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW AS IS EVIDENCED IN THE
COMMENTS TODAY. BUT ALSO IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I'M TAKING I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THIS BILL AT THE
PROPER TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIR EDMUND IS STILL. A CENTER
RUBIO. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
AND CLARITY BASED ON. BOTH SIDES
OF THE TESTIMONY IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO HOUSE-
AND I LIKE THE BOTH SIDES ARE.
REALLY FOCUSED ON PATIENT SAFETY
AND ACCESS BUT- I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS IF I MAY ASK. I
THINK IT'S OPPOSITION I KNOW
THAT THE WORSE OUR CONCERNS
EXPRESSED ABOUT. OB PATIENT
SAFETY AND DIAL. AND THE
DELIVERY AND QUALITY CONTROL I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THEY CAN GO
A LITTLE FURTHER AND- HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THOSE MECHANISMS THAT WE
USE. THANK YOU. MMHM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SO SPECIALLY
PHARMACIES ARE NO DIFFERENT A
PART OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN OF ANY
OTHER AS COMPARED TO OTHER
SUPPLY CHAIN- MEMBER IN THIS
INSTANCE THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
SAME DRUG- TRANSLATION HERE TO
ACT UP PROVISIONS AND CONGRESS
THEY ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO COVER-
TO MEET U. S. P. UNITED STATES
PHARMACOPEIA STANDARDS FOR A
QUALITY AND PROCESSING OF
PRESCRIPTIONS- THEY ALSO HAVE
MULTIPLE ACCREDITATIONS THAT
THEY MUST MAINTAIN- SO THESE ARE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED ACCORDED
ACCREDITATION BODIES. THAT
EVALUATE AND GRANT CERTIFICATION
OR ACCREDITATION FOR THESE-
SERVICES SO THE NOTION THAT
THESE KINDS OF THESE THESE
VENDORS ARE SOMEHOW LESS SAFE IS
FRANKLY UNTRUE BECAUSE IN FACT
DEPENDING ON THE DRUG OFTENTIMES
THE PROVIDERS AND THE HOSPITALS
WILL BE ACQUIRING THEIR DRUG
SUPPLY FROM THE SAME VENDOR FROM
SPECIALTY PHARMACY THIS IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE DIFFERENT FTA
REQUIREMENTS FOR CERTAIN DRUGS.
AND ALSO THE MANUFACTURERS MAY
IMPOSE CERTAIN LIMITATIONS ON
DISTRIBUTION OF THEIR PRODUCTS
SO THEY MAY CHOOSE TO LIMIT THEM
TO CERTAIN SPECIALLY PHARMACIES
BECAUSE IN FACT THEY ARE
COMFORTABLE THAT THE SPECIALLY
PHARMACY THAT IS PROVIDING THE-PRODUCT EXPENSING THE PRODUCT IS
IN THE BEST POSITION TO MAINTAIN
QUALITY STANDARDS AND
DISTRIBUTION- I CAN ALSO SPEAK
FROM EXPERIENCE HAVING VISITED A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT- FACILITIES
THAT- THESE ARE JUST THROWN IN
AN ENVELOPE OF THESE TRUCKS ARE
NOT THROWN IN AN ENVELOPE AND
SHIPPED TO A LOCATION- THEY ARE
VERY SOPHISTICATED PROCESSES
INVOLVED ESPECIALLY FOR-
SHIPMENTS THAT ARE SENT FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY LIKE I THINK
ANOTHER WITNESS HAD MENTIONED
THE YORK- WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
SPECIALLY PHARMACIES WHEN THEY
RECEIVE AN ORDER. WILL RUN A
SERIES OF SOPHISTICATED
ALGORITHMS TO DETERMINE. THE
PATH OF TRANSIT. LITERALLY THREE
OBVIOUSLY ERROR OR GROUND THEY
WILL PACK ENOUGH- INSULATION AND
OR OTHER PROTECTIVE MEASURES IN
A PACKAGE TO ENSURE NOT ONLY
WILL THE PRODUCT BE SAFE SAFE
AND STABLE BY THE TIME IT
ARRIVED AT THE LOCATION. BUT
THAT IT WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO
WITHSTAND SITTING OUT IN THE
ELEMENTS FOR. UP TO A COUPLE OF
DAYS IN SOME CASES SO AGAIN
IT'LL DEPEND ON THE DRUG BUT
UTMOST CARE IS TAKEN HERE AND-
ANOTHER THING I'LL MENTION AS
PURCHASED SAFETY. IT IS VERY
MUCH AGAINST THE INTEREST OF
ANYONE INVOLVED ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY PHARMACIES TO RISK
SPOILAGE OR WASTE OF THESE
PRODUCTS THEY ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE. AND IF THE DRUG IS
SOMEHOW COMPROMISED BY THE TIME
AND RIGHTS THE- THE CLINIC OR
THE PROVIDER. THE LOSS OF THAT
PRODUCT IS ON THE SPECIALLY
PHARMACY SO IT'S NOT A VERY
SUSTAINABLE MODEL. FOR THEM TO
OPERATE IF THEY'RE LOSING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
DRUGS. ON A FREQUENT BASIS IT
JUST IS NOT HAPPENING SO. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER MORE. THANK YOU-
AND I JUST WANT TO GO A LITTLE
FURTHER BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THE
SPECIALTY- PHARMACIES GET THE
DRUGS AND THEN FROM MY TO HEARD.
TESTIMONY SOMEONE SAID IT. AND
IT GOES TO THE PATIENT AND THEN
THE PATIENT. BRINGS IT TO THE
HOSPITAL SO. CAN YOU HELP ME
UNDERSTAND HOW DO YOU ENSURE
THAT THE PATIENT. IS EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE IT AND GET THE MEDICATION
WHEN THEY NEED TO GET IT TO THE
HOSPITAL'S. OF COURSE THANK YOU
CENTER OF YOUR QUESTION. SO THE-
THE HEALTH PLAN. WORKING WITH
THEIR- SOMETIMES AS WITH AN
INTEGRATED AS A PBM OR
INTEGRATED SPECIALLY PHARMACY.
WAR WITH THE SEPARATELY
CONTRACTED ENTITY THAT WILL DO
THAT FOR THEM- THEY- ARE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THROUGH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT DATA. FACTORS WHETHER
OR NOT CERTAIN PATIENTS ARE.
BETTER CANDIDATES FOR EASY
REFERENCE BROWN BAGGING WHICH IS
WHEN THE DRUG IS SENT TO THE
PATIENT A PATIENT PRESIDENT. IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO RISK
THE SAFETY OF THE PATIENT OR THE
DRUG. TO USE THAT METHOD. IF
THEY'RE NOT A GOOD CANDIDATE
FORCIBLE CONSIDERING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS TO. KNOW ARE
THEY PHYSICALLY CAPABLE OF
HANDLING IT IS THE DRUG
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE KEPT IN
THE REFRIGERATOR. NOT SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS SPECIAL COLD CHAIN
HANDLING- OTHER FACTORS ARE THEY
MENTALLY COGNIZANT DEPENDING ON
THEIR CLAIMS HISTORY ARE THEY-
YOU KNOW THE COGNITIVELY
IMPAIRED OTHER OTHER CAT
FACTORS. SO THIS ISN'T APPLY TO
JUST ANY PATIENT OKAY. IT'S ONLY
APPLIED IN THE CASE OF BROWN BAG
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE PAGES THAT
ARE BEST POSITIONED TO BE ABLE
TO HANDLE THE WRONG MEDICATION.
AS FOR WHITE BACKING. UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES IF THERE'S
COOPERATION WITH THE PRESCRIBER.
WHO WILL BE ACEPTING THE
SHIPMENT AND THEN DISPENSING IT
THE PICTURE WILL HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THE DRUG CAME FROM. IT
SHOULDN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE
WHETHER COMES FROM THE POSITIONS
STOCK OR IF IT COMES FROM
SHIPMENT. THAT CAME IN EARLIER
THAT DAY OR THE DAY BEFORE. SO
YOU SHOULD BE COMPLETELY
SEAMLESS. THANK YOU L. YOU KNOW
WHEN I HEAR THE DISCUSSION TODAY
I MEAN I GUESS IT'S IMPORTANT IS
A COMPLICATED ISSUE BUT ICAN
SEE WHY THERE IS A PRACTICE OF
THIRD PARTY VENDORS AND IT HAS
TO DO WITH WITH COST SAVINGS IN
AND FOR ME THE COST IS A REAL
BIG BIG CONCERN BUT- I REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS GEARED TOWARDS
REDUCING THE COST OF MEDICATIONS
FOR PATIENTS I THINK TO ME
THAT'S FROM STRUGGLING WITH
BECAUSE- AGAIN THAT'S THE REASON
THEY USE THE THIRD PARTY VENDORS
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THEY NOT
BE. FOR HOSPITALS AND MAY NOT BE
FISCALLY FEASIBLE SINCE THEY
HAVE SUCH GREAT OVERHEAD AND
QUALITY CONTROL I GUESS
IMPLEMENTATION AND THINGS THAT
THEY HAVE TO PAY OUT SO I
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT MAY NOT BE
FEASIBLE BRINGING THE COST DOWN-
EQUAL TO THAT OF SPECIALTY
PHARMACIES BUT I DO WANT
PATIENTS TO WIN AND I THINK ALL
OF US ARE HERE BECAUSE WE WANT
PATIENTS TO WIN. AND SO- I'M NOT
NECESSARILY SURE RIGHT AT THIS
MOMENT THAT EITHER SIDE IS
SATISFACTORY TO ME- ON ONE HAND
WE HAVE THE PATIENT SAFETY IN
TERMS OF LIKE STORING AND
HANDLING AND MAKING SURE THAT
PATIENTS GET THE MEDICATION.
RIPPLED WITH YOU KNOW TIMELY
ACCESS. BUT ON THE OTHER HAND WE
HAVE THESE HIGH PRICES THAT MADE
ME FAMILIES. AND FINANCIAL
DISTRESS AND IT'S A REAL CONCERN
YOU KNOW WHEN THE PRICES CAN BE.
EXTREMELY HIGH. END SOUL YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT THE-
SENATOR. HER TESTIMONY SAYING
THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH WITH THE WITH THE
OPPOSITION. I MEAN I DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A MIDDLE GROUND
SOMEWHERE I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT
MIDDLE GROUND IS. BUT I THINK
THAT THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD THIS
BILL. AGAIN BUT I REALLY WANTED
TO BE FOCUS ON HOW DO WE-
PROVIDE THAT ACCESS BUT ALSO
ENSURE THAT THE PRICING IS RIGHT
AND THAT THESE FAMILIES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE. ARE NOT LEFT
HOLDING THE BAG SO TO SPEAK- AND
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT THEY CAN GET THIS
MEDICATION AND THEY'RE NOT GONNA
BREAK THE BANK CELL. I ALSO WANT
TO THINK OUT THERE BECAUSE I
KNOW SHE TOOK THE AMENDMENTS
WHICH IS IMPORTANT. BUT AGAIN I
THINK THERE'S STILL MORE
CONVERSATIONS TO BE HAD AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE BIT
MORE COLLABORATION ON BOTH
SIDES. BUT I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL BECAUSE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT BOTH
SIDES EQUALLY ARE HEARING THAT
IT'S AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
AND I WANT THEM TO COME TO THE
TABLE. THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I
WILL MOVE THE BILL IF IT HASN'T
BEEN MOVED. TO HAS IT IS IT HAS
BEEN MOVED THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS CASEY NINE US ARMY FOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH- COMMITTEE STAFF- AND
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- WE DID
TRY TO STRIKE A MIDDLE GROUND.
MAYBE IT'S NOT THE FINAL MIDDLE
GROUND- WHERE. WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT ON ONE HAND AS
YOU PRESENTED IN YOUR OPENING-
AND WE HEARD FROM THE WITH ME
WITNESSES SUPPORT WE WANNA BE
SURE THAT PEOPLE GET ACCESS TO
MEDICATIONS AND TIMELY ARE YOU
HAVE SOMEONE. COMING TO US TO IN
FUSION CENTER OR SOME OTHER
PLACE RIGHT TO GET TREATMENT.
AND THE MEDICATION IS NOT THERE.
RIGHT- IT'S UP. TO THAT'S A
PROBLEM THAT THAT SAYS THAT THE
COST TO THE PATIENT THAT'S A
COSTLY FOR MEMBERS FOR ME THAT
THAT. THE COST OF THE PATIENT
NOT JUST FINANCIAL BUT THEIR
HEALTH RIGHT. AND SO THAT THAT'S
THE PROBLEMS TRYING TO DRESS AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
SAMETIME WE WANTED AND AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH- THE STAFF- WE WANTED. NOT
OVERLY RESTRICT THE ABILITY OF.
THE PLAN AGAIN TO ADDRESS THE
FINANCIAL COSTS TO. IF THEY CAN
PUT. THE ACCOUNT OF THE PROVIDE
THE MEDICATION IN. THE
PREPARATORY MATTER TO SAFE
MANNER THAT HE COULD AT. THAT
THAT THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE SO
THAT- SO THAT THEY DIDN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE. THEY COULD USE
ANOTHER PHARMACY AND SO WE TRY
TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH- THE
COMMITTEE. STAFF ON THIS AND I
AM SURE YOU HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH US. THAT THE
VERY STAKEHOLDERS. BUT AGAIN OF
COURSE THE SUPPORTING THE BILL-
AND- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
PEN I THINK YOU SAID THIS AT YOU
KNOW YOU SUMMARIZED IN. WE'RE
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL COST VERSUS THE COST.
OF HEALTH. AND SO THAT'S GOING
TO BE AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
FOR THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE STATE
FOR A VERY LONG TIME- BUT YOU
KNOW AT THE CORE OF THIS IS. IF
SOMEONE IS REALLY SICK IF YOU
HAD A TERRIBLE WEEK WITH
LEUKEMIA. AND YOU'VE GOT YOUR
WEIGHT HAS CHANGED IN THE LAST
WEEK. IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
MEDICATION THAT YOU'RE GETTING
FROM A THIRD PARTY VENDOR. MAY
NO LONGER BE APPLICABLES AND YOU
WON'T BE ABLE TO GET THAT
MEDICINE. AT THE HOSPITAL SO
WE'RE HAVING DISCUSSION OF WHERE
TO GET THE MEDICINE THAT. SAVES
YOUR LIFE DO YOU GET IT FROM THE
HOSPITAL HA. PHARMACY OR DO YOU
GET IT FROM A THIRD PARTY BY. IF
YOU GET IT FROM THE THIRD PARTY
MEN. IT MAY BE. BUT YOU WILL NOT
ALWAYS GET IT AT THE TIME YOU
NEED IT. AND THIS IS VERY
DIFFICULT- CERTAINLY WE ARE
WILLING TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
BUT I DON'T WANT IT TO BE LOST.
ON THAT AT THE END THIS BILL IS
ABOUT PRIORITIZING THE HEALTH.
OF THAT INDIVIDUAL AND I THINK
YOU'LL SEE THAT IF AT THIS WAS
NOT AN ISSUE YOU WOULDN'T SEE
SEVENTEEN STATES IN OUR COUNTRY.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT GUARDRAILS
ARE CURRENTLY HAVE GUARD RAILS.
AND YOU WOULDN'T SEE DOZENS OF
HOSPITALS AND CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ST WE NEED TO HAVE A
CHANGE IN PRACTICE. IF THIS IS A
MEDICINE THAT'S GOING TO SAVE
THE LIFE OF THE INDIVIDUAL. HELP
EXTEND THE LIFE ESPECIALLY
INTEREST YOUR CIRCUMSTANCES WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENTLY. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. OKAY THANK YOU- SO THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AND
POLICE WAS AT CENTER EGGMANTO.
REMOVE THE BILL- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN
HI MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ GROVE. FURTADO LEYVA I
LEYVA AYE LEÓN HI LIMON AYE
ROTH. ROTH AYE RUBIO. AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER AYE WIENER AYE. OKAY
THE BILLS CURRENTLY HAS SEVEN
BUILT SEVEN ZERO LEVEL THE BILL
OPENED FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW GOING
TO MOVE- TO- ITEM NUMBER TWO-
THAT'S SB NINE TWENTY THREE BY
CENTER WIENER. WELCOME.
WITH GREAT THANK YOU- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING INTENSIVELY- WITH US ON
THIS BILL- AND FOR COMING UP
WITH SOME HAVING SOME STRONG
AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS- IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS- COLLEAGUES
ON THE SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY
THREE- IS IMPORTANT- AND VERY
TIMELY MEASURE- TO IMPROVE OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM- FOR-
TRANSGENDER GENDER NON
CONFORMING AND INTERSEX
PATIENTS. TO ENSURE THE DAY-
RECEIVED- APPROPRIATE- AND
SUPPORTIVE SO I CARE AND THAT
THEY ARE NOT DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST OR STIGMATIZED- IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ARE CURRENTLY
THERE IS NO NATIONAL GUIDANCE ON
TRANS INCLUSIVE CARE- AND SENATE
BILL NINE TWENTY THREE WOULD
SERVE AS A FIRST IN THE NATION
MODEL- FOR TO ENSURE THE TGI
PATIENTS OF QUALITY AND
COMPASSIONATE HEALTH CARE FROM
PROVIDERS ON THE AMENDMENTS-
THAT WILL BE ACCEPTING FROM THE
COMMITTEE WHICH ARE OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS BUT I DO WANT TO.
STATE THEM PUBLICLY ON THE BILL
RIGHT NOW MANDATES- TRAINING-
INSTEAD OF THAT WILL BE
INCORPORATED INTO CMA- INTO
CONTINUING- EDUCATION AND WE'VE-
THROUGHOUT- CME- IT WILL REQUIRE
AN AMENDMENT WILL REQUIRE THAT-
DEPARTMENTS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED CARE- DODD TRACK AND
MONITOR COMPLAINTS AND PUBLICLY
REPORT FINDINGS- WITH OTHER DATA
IN THEIR ANNUAL REPORT WEBSITE
OR OTHER PUBLIC REPORTS- IT ONE
EIGHT INS IN TERMS OF ONE OF
THE- EXECUTIVES AND THE BILL IS
TO ENSURE THAT WHEN PEOPLE GO TO
THEIR HEALTH PLAN NETWORK
DIRECTORY THEY KNOW. WHO
PROVIDES GENDER AFFIRMING CARE-
WE'RE GOING TO- NOT FOR THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT- IT'LL BE-
ACCESSIBLE LINK FROM THE PLAN'S
PROVIDER DIRECTORY- ANNEXED.
ACCEPTABLE TO THE INSURANCE CALL
CENTER- TIME A LIST OF IN FOR.%
WHO PROVIDE JONES OR FOR CARE-
IN ADDITION- THE- ALTIUM IN
SERVICES- IS AND SEE WHAT
CONVENE A WORKING GROUP
INCLUDING TJ I PEOPLE- TO
DEVELOP A- QUALITY STANDARDS.
FOR PATIENT EXPERIENCE FOR TGI
PATIENT EXPERIENCE- TO MAKE SURE
THAT- PROVIDERS ARE PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE CARE TGI PEOPLE. AND
ALSO TO CREATE A CORPORATE
TRAINING STANDARDS SO THIS
WORKING GROUP. WILL MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION AND THEN THESE
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED- AND AGAIN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE FIRST.
STATE IN THE COUNTRY- TO DO SO-
BECAUSE BIG PICTURE- HERE-
pTERRIFYING. WHAT STATES LIKE
TEXAS AND IDAHO- AND OTHER
STATES ARE DOING RIGHT NOW- TO
TRANS YOUTH AND THE TRANS PEOPLE
IN GENERAL- WE HAVE STATES IN
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW AND
SPREADING LIKE WILDFIRE. BETTER
LITERALLY CLASSIFYING GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE AS CHILD ABUSE-
AND THREATENING TO TAKE
TRANSYLVANIA WAY FROM THEIR
PARENTS- AND PUT HIM IN FOSTER
CARE AND THEN PUT THE PARENTS.
IN IN PRISON- SIMPLY BECAUSE
PARENTS ARE SUPPORTING THEIR
TRANS GENDER- OUR CHILDREN. ARE
WE HAVE STATES THAT ARE BANNING
SIMPLY BANNING- HEALTHCARE FOR
TRANS- CHILDREN MAKING IT
ILLEGAL. CRIMINALIZING POSITIONS
- FOR PROVIDING- THAT CARE- WE
HAVE- STATES THAT ARE
PROHIBITING- TRANSPORT FROM
USING THE RESTROOM THAT
CORRESPONDS TO THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY OR BANNING TRANS YOUTH
FROM PLAYING SPORTS AND THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON AND ON- THE
MESSAGE THAT THAT SENDS TRANS
PEOPLE PARTICULARLY TO TRANS
YOUTH IS HORRIFIC- AND IT IS NO
WONDER THAT. RATES OF SELF HARM
OR HIGHER AMONG TRANS KIDS
THERE'S NOTHING INHERENT ERRORS
BECAUSE OF THE SOCIETY THE
MESSAGE THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
FROM SOCIETY- THIS BILL WILL
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE TO THE
CONTRARY- CALIFORNIA PRIDES
ITSELF IN SUPPORTING OUR LGBTQ
COMMUNITY- AND THIS BILL WILL
KEEP US IN THAT. DIRECTION THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR TRANSGENDER
EQUALITY REPORTS THAT ONE THIRD
OF ALL TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS
WHO SAW HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL
IN A GIVEN YEAR HAD AT LEAST ONE
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE RELATING TO
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY. WITH EVEN
HIGHER RATES FOR TRANS PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND TRANS DISABLED PEOPLE
. THESE NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES
INCLUDE AT TIMES BEING REFUSED
TREATMENT ENTIRELY BECAUSE OF
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY BEING
VERBALLY HARASSED- EVEN
ASSAULTED- ARE HAVING TO TEACH
IN THE PROVIDER ABOUT
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE CARE.
SOMETIMES IN THESE SITUATIONS
ARE OR ABUSIVE AND INTENTIONAL
IN OTHER SITUATIONS ARE
PROVIDERS WHO MEAN NO HARM OR
NOT. I HAVE NO ILL WILL BUT
SIMPLY DON'T KNOW. DON'T KNOW
HOW TO INTERACT APPROPRIATELY IN
SUPPORT OF MATTER WITH TGI
PATIENTS A TRACK. AT
TRANSPERSONAL SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
TEACH THEIR HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
HOW TO DO THAT. ON 23% OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE REPORTED THAT
FEAR OF DISCRIMINATION CAUSED
THEM TO POSTPONE OR NOT RECEIVE
NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE BUT IT
JUST WASN'T WORTH. THE TENSION
OR THE AWKWARDNESS- OR OR OR OR
JUST IT WASN'T WORTH GOING
THROUGH THAT- AND NO ONE SHOULD
EVER HAVE TO GO TO A DOCTOR'S
OFFICE ONLY TO BE MISGENDERED
HARASSED OR EVEN REFUSE
TREATMENT- AND SAYS I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THIS IS NOT ABOUT
DEMONIZING PROVIDERS SO MANY
PROVIDERS WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE PROVIDING SUPPORT IN TERMS
OF TRAINING AND LEARNING AND
KNOWING WHAT THE STANDARDS ARE-
SO THAT THEY CAN DO WHAT SO MANY
WANT TO DO WHICH IS TO TREAT
PEOPLE. ACTIVELY AND WITH
COMPASSION- BY ENSURING. THAT WE
- PROVIDE THESE RESOURCE.
PERFORMANCE SPACE STANDARD.
ALTERNATELY TRAINING- WE WILL
HAVE A BETTER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
FRANKLY NOT JUST FOR TGI PEOPLE
BUT FOR EVERYONE- SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT. STEP FORWARD IN TERMS
OF ACCESS TO THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM BY TGI- INDIVIDUALS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY- MISTER
CHAIRMAN ARE- REVEREND BENITA
RAMSEY- AND ERIN POLLARD. AND
OUR SPONSORS ARE AVAILABLE WITH
ANY CANCER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU CENTER
WIENER ON L. HEAR FROM WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE TWENTY
THREE- SO WILL BE- SO MODERATOR
COOLEY BOTH ARE SUFFERING FROM
THE PHONE MODERATE PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES. OF YOU CAN WITH THE
REVEREND DYER RAMSEY FOLLOWED BY
L. AND KAREN POLLARD YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOR
MINUTES BETWEEN THE BOTH OF YOU.
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH AARON RAMSEY
. HERE YES AFTERNOON CHEERING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RECOMMENDED NEED RAMPING WHAT
I'M ABOUT TO SHARE THE DEEPLY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT STILL
HAD LINGERING EFFECTS ON ME
TODAY I WENT TO A MEDICAL OFFICE
OUT OF MY HOME AREA DUE TO AN
EMERGENCY. THEY ADVERTISED TODAY
SIR ALL IN A CARING ENVIRONMENT. SO I TOOK MY CANCERS. OFTEN
THE RECEPTIONIST STAFF WAS
FRIENDLY AND I'VE WAITED I WOULD
SUMMIT TO THE BACK AND
EVERYTHING WITH A DENTAL BUT TO
THE DOCTOR ASKED ME TO- BUT MAKE
SURE TO CHECK MY VITALS. OPEN
MAKE SURE AND THE DOCTOR ASKED
WHAT IS THAT SB POINTED TO MY
PRACTICE AREA. UNLETTERED BY
DECEMBER BEFORE I COULD UTTER
ANOTHER WORD HE SAID I DON'T GET
THIS. THE FOR THE BOB WHAT IS
THIS CONTRACTION SUPPOSED TO DO
FOR YOU. ARE YOU TRYING TO
BECOME A MAN. I DON'T SUPPORT
NOR WILL I TREAT WITH HIS. FACE
WE NEED TO BE WHO GOD MADE YOU
TO BE AND STOP PRETENDING. PAGE
ME A WALK OUT. SO AFTER THAT I
HEARD LOUD POPPING I HEARD A
VOICE SAY WHAT IS THAT IN ROOM
TV. BY THE PEOPLE FORCES
SEXUALITY ON US WITHOUT WARNING.
I WILL NOT SERVE THAT PATIENT.
PLEASE GIVE THEM A REFERRAL TO
GET FITTED FOR A BRA IT
SANITIZED THE ROOM. AT THIS
POINT A SWEET OFF THE TABLE AND
WALKED OUT THE FLAYED AND
DISCOVERED STILL IN PAYING. NO
SAID I WILL BE IN IN A MINUTE.
BOTH SAID I HEARD YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR. WHY WOULD I TRUST YOU NOW
. WHEN I ENTERED THE LOBBY IT
LOOKS FULL AND ALL EYES WERE ON
ME. I KNEW TO BE A FIFTY THIRTY
TWO. HEY MITCH HERE CAME OVER ME
I WISH TO MY CON BEGAN RIPPING
UP MY BANK TO SHOPLIFTING ACT
FINE. FIVE YEARS LATER JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY. ALAMEDA BRAKES
GOING MY BY DRINKING I CAN NOW
HOLD MY HEAD UP HIGH RE ENTERING
A LITTLE IN MY NON BINARY SHE'LL
JUST AS I AM THIS IS WHY SB NINE
TWENTY THREE THE COURT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW
LET'S BRING ON ERIN POLLARD.
PLEASE PM. AFTERNOON KERREY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ERIN
HOLLERED A LICENSED MARRIAGE
FAMILY THERAPIST LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELOR
AND MANAGER STUDENT EQUITY
IRVINE VALLEY COLLEGE IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA AND ADDRESSING YOU
TODAY BECAUSE I SPECIALIZED IN
GENDER AFFIRMING MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IN SUPPORT AND TRANS GENDER
NON BINARY AND INTERSEX PATIENTS
FOR THE PAST FOURTEEN YEARS.
ORDINANCES COMMITTEE. THAT BY
AND LARGE APPROPRIATE CARE AND
TREATMENT FOR GENDER DIVERSE
PATIENTS IS NOT TAUGHT IN OUR
MASTER'S PROGRAMS OR IN OUR
DOCTORATE PROGRAM. IN ORDER FOR
CLINICIANS TO RECEIVE A
SPECIALIZED TRAINING THEY MUST
SEEK IT OUT THEMSELVES.
TRAININGS ARE OFTEN VERY
DIFFICULT TO FIND WHICH RESULT
IN ONLY A SMALL AMOUNT OF
PROPERLY TRAINED CLINICIANS. THE
FOURTEENTH RTT EDUCATION
CONDUCTING A TO WHERE THEY CAN
FIND COMPANY CARE APPROPRIATE TO
THEIR NEEDS. IN ORDER FOR CARE
TO BE AFFIRMING AND INCLUSIVE
THE CLINICIAN NEEDS TO NOT ONLY
UNDERSTANDS MEDICAL TRANSITION
OPTIONS BUT ALSO THE COMPLEX
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL IMPACT IS BEING
TRANSFORMED BY INTERIOR
INTERSECTION OUR SOCIETY.
WITHOUT THIS TRAINING CLINICIANS
OFTEN PROVIDE MISGUIDED
TREATMENT IN FACT IS. HARMFUL TO
OUR TV EDUCATION. HARM OFTEN IN
. THANK OF DEPRESSION. GENDERED
INFILL SITE OUR- UNFORTUNATELY
HAPPENS ALL TOO OFTEN I CRAVE
REGULARLY BRING THE STRY THAT
THEIR DENIAL OF TREATMENT
PROGRAM. AND MISINFORMATION BY
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIAN. HE CRANTOR OFTEN THEN
LAST REASONABLY FEARFUL AND%
AVOIDANCE OF ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY FRIEDMAN THE
STAFF WAS BETTER ACCESS TO
GENDER AFFIRMING TRAINING FOR
CLINICIANS. THE ABILITY FOR
CONSUMERS TO FIND THE ACCESS TO
THE CARE THEY NEED FOR THE
THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDER YOUR
SUPPORT. KALYTERA WE SAVE LIVES
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT SB NINE TWENTY THREE
WE HAVE ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED.
WELCOME NAY MORE SEASON DECISION
GOOD AFTERNOON MOLLY ROBSON WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA WERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSE TORRES
WITH HEALTH ACTS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MATTHEW GALLAGHER ON
BIAFRA CAL VOICES ALSO INSTRUCTS
WORK THANK YOU. SEEN ON OUT
SEPARATING MICROPHONE ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED- MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE TWENTY THREE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITIONALLY. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. SB. NINE TWO THREE
ONE SEVEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BY
TWO THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND- ATTY CORRESPOND WITH
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM
HELLO UNCERTAIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN TO FORTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SECRETARY OF
STATE RECORDS TRANSFER THE- ALL
OPEN COURT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I TO SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
AMANDA MCALISTER OWNER- IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. YOU'RE RIGHT TO FIFTY
NINE THREE FOUR AT. THIS IS
TOMMY MARTIN BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA CROWD PREPONDERANCE
OF BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
RIGHT TO SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE I
HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALEZ THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. YOU'RE
GOING TO SIXTY SEVEN PEOPLE HAVE
. DANNY DANIEL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LGBTQ HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THAT WORK A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. RIGHT TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
WHEN THE WAY WITH QUESTIONS AND-
ON POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORTER OF SB NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON YOU HAVE
BEEN PALETTE ON BEHALF OF
JUSTICE MAJORING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. BY TWO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER FOR THE INSURANCE
TRANSPORT SERVICE CARS UP TO
PROBABLY HONEST ON THE COURT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU RYAN THREE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE THREE ZERO FOUR.
ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL. THE CALIFORNIA AND I THINK
WORKING FROM WORK IN THE FIELD
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M TWO FIFTY THREE FIFTY
FOUR I HAVE. BUT SHE WATER
WITHOUT PLACES AND OUT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH IN STRONG
SUPPORTER. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BY TWO TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONLY HURTING
THE CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. TRYING
TO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THIS IS THE PUBLIC ANGEL AS
ACTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PROJECT
EDWARD UNDER THAT COUPON CARE
AND I TOTALLY UPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE TO
FORTY FOUR PEOPLE AT. REPORTER
ON BEHALF PARTICULARLY HEALTH
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE OH SIX BEFORE I HAVE. SH
GOOD AFTERNOON DURING A ONE PAGE
IN RESEARCH THANK IN FULL
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. YOU'RE RIGHT THREE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ANY
OTHER YAHOO WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLAN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE NINETY FOUR
PEOPLE HAVE. THE BILL ARE BUT ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH FOR NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE TWENTY
THREE IF TWO WITNESSES LISTED
FOR TESTIMONY SO I THINK THEY'RE
BOTH IN PERSON SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH A JET HAMPTON WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS FOLLOWED BY CAT CURTAINS-
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES A
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN THE
TO VIEW. THANK YOU AFTER MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRED HAMPTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS- FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO
SINCERELY THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF AND THE CLEAN THEIR
STAFF. FOR ENGAGING WITH US ON
THIS BILL WITH THAT'S VERY
POSSIBLE TO DATE AND SO WE'RE
VERY PLEASED THAT. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON SB I. TWENTY THREE-
IN PRINT. OUT WE ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL BUT AT
FIRST BLUSH THEY DO SEEM TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE OPERATIONAL
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE BILL. A SO WE WILL
BE EVALUATING THE MOMENTS AND
CIRCLING BACK WITH OUR MEMBERS
AND- LOOKING AT THAT TIME TO RE
EVALUATE YOUR POSITION BUT- WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR- AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND HOPE TO- KEEP. AN OPEN
DIALOGUE THAT MOVING FORWARD I
SHOULD IF THERE IS NEED TO. IRIS
I FIGURE THINGS OUT. THANKS VERY
- NOW BRING UP. CHECKER. HELLO
THANKS FOR HAVING ME I'M CAT AND
IDENTIFIED AS A TRANSGENDER MALE
STARTING AT AGE THIRTEEN A
MEDICALLY TRANSITION LATER AS AN
ADULT AFTER YEARS OF STRUGGLING
WITH GENDERDYSPHORIA ALONG WITH
DIAGNOSED ANOREXIA BULIMIA
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION I THOUGHT
THE PURSUING MEDICAL TRANSITION
AND LIVING AS THE OPPOSITE SEX
WOULD BRING ME HAPPINESS. I
BELIEVE WE'RE TRANS ACTIVIST
TOLD ME BUT TRANSITIONING WAS MY
BEST OPTION IN THE ONLY WAY TO
PREVENT SUICIDE. I RECEIVED A
PRESCRIPTION FOR TESTOSTERONE
FROM THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AFTER ONLY A
THIRTY MINUTE PHONE CALL WITH
THE DOCTOR. NO BLOOD WORK NORTH
THIRTY WAS REQUIRED. MY OTHER
SERIOUS PSYCHOLOGICAL ISSUES AS
WELL AS MY HESITATION DUE TO
BEING UNSURE OF THE AFFECTS
TESTOSTERONE WOULD HAVE ON MY
SINGING VOICE. WERE OF NO
CONCERN TO THE DOCTOR. I WAS A
SEMI PROFESSIONAL SINGER AT THIS
TIME. HER MOANS ABOUT NOT
THERAPY WERE COVERED BY MY
HEALTH INSURANCE. A SECOND
PLANNED PARENTHOOD DOCTOR WROTE
ME AN APPROVAL LETTER FOR A
DOUBLE MASTECTOMY ALSO WITHOUT
ANY IN PERSON MEETING OR
RECOMMENDATION THAT I ADDRESS MY
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
FIRST. AFTER FOUR MONTHS OF
INJECTING TESTOSTERONE I
SUFFERED HEATH SIDE EFFECTS
INCLUDING HEART PALPITATIONS.
STABBING PAIN IN MY RIGHT SIDE.
NAUSEA VOMITING AND OEDEMA. I
CORD OF LOCAL DISABILITY THAT
MADE IT PAINFUL TO SPEAK OR
SING. I WAS FORCED TO MAKE THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO STOP
TRANSITIONING. ALTHOUGH MY
HEALTH SYMPTOMS HAVE IMPROVED I
STILL HAVE TROUBLE PROJECTING MY
VOICE. AND CAN NO LONGER SING
LIVE. I'M ONE OF A QUICKLY
GROWING NUMBER OF THE TRANSITION
EARNERS INDIVIDUALS FOR WHOM
TRANSITION NOT ONLY FAILED TO
IMPROVE. BUT WORSEN THEIR
SITUATION GENDER DYSPHORIA IS A
SYMPTOM AND OFTEN TEMPORARY IN
CONTRAST TRANSGENDER BODY
MODIFICATION IS PERMANENT. KNOWN
TO CAUSE NEGATIVE HEALTH EFFECTS
AND THERE'S CURRENTLY NO PROOF
IT IMPROVES MENTAL HEALTH IN THE
LONG TERM. AFTER SPENDING OVER A
YEAR HEALING FOR MY TRANSITION
EXPERIENCE I HAVE COME TO ACCEPT
MY BIOLOGICAL SEX. I AM A WOMAN
AN ADULT HUMAN FEMALE AND THIS
CAN NEVER BE CHANGED. OTHERS
OTHER DE TRANSITION OURS WENT
MUCH FURTHER IN THEIR TRANSITION
I NOW REGRET HAVING BODY PARTS
REMOVED OR FEEL DEVASTATED THERE
WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO HAVE
CHILDREN. SENATE BILL NINE
TWENTY THREE WOULD DENY HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOMMEND TREATMENTS THAT ARE
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
PATIENT'S. GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
HAS NOT BEEN PROVEN TO ALLEVIATE
GENDER DYSPHORIA. CONSIDER HOW
THIS LEGISLATION WILL PREVENT
VULNERABLE GROUPS SUCH AS YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THOSE WITH COMORBID
MENTAL ILLNESSES. FROM GETTING
THE PROPER THERAPEUTIC AND
MEDICAL CARE AND THEY ACTUALLY
NEED. THANK YOU- I'M AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS AND ALSO THERE
ABOUT FIFTY TWO HUNDRED PARENTS
WHO OPPOSE THIS BILL. UNABLE TO
GET INTO THE CONFERENCE DUE TO
IT BEING FULL. THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH- ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. NAY MORE THIS POSITION
ONLY MATURE MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS WE ALSO HAD AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING
THE AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE ON THEIR
WORK THANKS THANK YOU.
EXPERTNESS. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BRAND IN MARCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE- WE APPRECIATE THAT
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS TODAY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. IN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION DECISION. SUSAN
ARNOLD I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE WE OPPOSE
THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
EXPERTNESS. YEAH YOU CAN START
WITH THE CITY'S YOURSELF YOUR
NAME AND EXTERIOR EXPRESSION OF
YOUR OPPOSITION AND- MY NAME IS
VERONICA AND I AM A RESIDENTS OF
YUBA COUNTY AND I AM OPPOSITION
OF SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. OKAY. MY NAME
IS ERIN FRIDAY I'M A MOTHER OF
IT RAPID ONSET GENDER DYSPHORIC
CHILD WHO NOW IS HAPPY IN HER
pBODY I AM ALSO THE LEAD OF THE
NOR CAL PARENTS OF RGD KIDS I AM
ALSO A MEMBER OF OUR DUTY THERE
ARE SEVENTY TO A HUNDRED PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO CALL INTO
OPPOSE THIS THEY'RE ALL PARENTS
THE MAJORITY ARE DEMOCRATS WE
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE
REPROACHING ROOMS- THE
MICROPHONE HERE ROOM TO OF
HUNDRED- ACTUALLY I WOULD GUESS
THE STAFF IS- TO SEE IF THERE'S
A WAY TO ENSURE THAT- ANYWAY BUT
HE'S ACTUALLY TRYING TO CALL IN
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM TO BE SURE
WE ADDRESS THAT- SO- MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWENTY
THREE AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ACT HE IT NUYS TO THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME.
AEROPORTO RAIMES THREE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEED YOU CAN.
BOB I'M CALLING FROM PARKER
COUNTY AND I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AT NINE TWENTY THREE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. EIGHT
ZERO NINE TWO THIRTEEN PLEASE
CALL I HAVE. BUYING TWO ONE
THREE. BY ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS TONIGHT AND REPRESENTS
THE CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY IN THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF PLASTIC SURGEONS YEAH
BUT OPPOSE POSITION ON THE BILL
AND PRINT LOOKING FORWARD TO
REVIEW THE AMENDMENTS ON TRUCKS
OR CHANGE YOUR POSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU WIDE ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MICHAEL
PRACTICE FROM THE- IT WAS OBISPO
COUNTY- PROBLEM THAT I SEE WITH
THIS BILL SO ACTUALLY JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION SO I
ASSUME YOUR OPPOSED TO SB NINE
TWENTY THREE. THAT'S CORRECT.
YES THAT'S CORRECT THERE'S
ANOTHER INFORMED CONSENT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT AND NEXT WITNESS
AND JUST YOU KNOW HERE YOU ARE
FREE TO ALSO SUBMITLETTERS TO
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL FOR THE
RECORD. IF YOU WANT TO. EXPRESS
YOURSELF MORE FULLY SELL AGAIN
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN TO
NINETY SEVEN PEOPLE HAVE. HI MY
NAME IS MARY AND I IN. MY PART
OF ANY SPECIAL INTERESTS GROUPS
MANY OTHERS ARE IN TIME- IN
STRONG OPPOSITION SB NINETY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M ONE
TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE I HAVE.
HELLO FOREIGN WITH PLASTER
COUNTY THREE CHOICE AND WE
OPPOSE HE NINE TWENTY THREE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M ONE OF THEM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
RYAN I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. COPYRIGHT ONE
EIGHTEENTH REQUIRED. OUR CAT IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE. THE LINE
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
ONE THREE EIGHT. BY ONE NINETY
ONE IS WHY HAVE. HI MY NAME IS
ABLE GARCIA I'M NOT WITH ANY
SPECIAL INTERESTS I AM JUDGING
BEFORE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THIRTY
TRANSITION IF YOU ACCIDENTALLY
SUSPECTED AS WITNESS PLEASE.
TAKE YOUR SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
OUT. BURGER RENDON CALLED AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF MEDICAL FREEDOM
GROUP IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AND A FRIEND FOR THE
MEDICAL FREEDOM THANK YOU SB
NINETY THREE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I WON SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARON
REARDON FIVE PARENT AND FRIEND
OF SEVENTY TRANSIT ARE GOING UP
THE SYSTEM TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT EIGHTY NINE PEOPLE HAVE.
THANK YOUR DELIVER I'M WITH OUR
VIDEO ESSAY AND I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY THREE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M THREE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE THREE FIVE.
HELLO YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
MORE SUCH A POSITION. MY NAME IS
MOLLY TAYLOR AND HIS SISTER AND
I'M IN SHOCK MISSION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU JEAN I DESPERATELY
WANT TO THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME'S FUNNY MESSAGE AND I'M
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I NINETY FOUR PEOPLE HAVE.
BY NINE FOUR. TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN
MONEY BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE TWO
THREE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE TWENTY
FOUR PEOPLE HAVE. FIVE THREE TWO
FOUR. HELLO THIS IS A GOOD HERE
IS RESIDENT OF FAMILY DINO
COUNTY RIGHT NOW THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GLAD. HI MY
NAME IS CAROL SHERMAN AND I'M A
REPRESENTATIVE OF FEMINIST AND
STRUGGLE AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M
SIXTY THREE PRECOR HAVE. FIVE
SIX THREE. BY THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ADRIAN RELIGIOUS UNDERCURRENTS
AND BENDIGO I'M EXTREMELY
OPPOSED TO FILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M THREE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
AM A PARENT IN MANHATTAN BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB NINETY THREE EIGHTY
SIX WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M
THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH. FIVE THREE TWO ZERO. HELLO
MY NAME IS TINA REBELLIOUS AND I
OPPOSE SB NINE TWENTY THREE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M THREE TWENTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON VANESSA
GARCIA VENTURA COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB NINE TWO THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE WILLIAMS-
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THE FIVE
FULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS PAUL MARTIN OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY WITH TWO TEENAGE
DAUGHTERS I STRONGLY OPPOSED
THAT THE NINETY THREE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WHY THREE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU CAN
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WILL DECIDE
JOHN AND I OPPOSE SB NINETY
THREE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE KEREN IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SELF
EXPRESSION AND VERY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO S. B. NINE TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
RIGHT TO SIXTEEN PLEASE GO OUT.
YEAH MOM FROM FAR FROM MEDICAID
COUNTY I AM THE PROUD FATHER OF
A GAY MAN. YOU GOT A POINT BUT
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE HOMOPHOBIC
. THANK YOU THE NEXT ITNESS.
THANK YOU I WON ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. D'ANTONIO BUT OPPOSE ON
BEHALF OF WOMEN ADULT HUMAN
FEMALES FINALLY JANNEY A GO
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT TO FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL US. NINE TWO FIVE
FIVE. HELLO YOU HEAR ME YES
SINGLE ASISTIR POSITION HERE. IN
VERY I'M FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. SENATE BILL
NINE TWO THREE ARE YOU A MEMBER
THANK YOU HAVE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. EIGHT ZERO ONE TO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
UNDER ON THAT LIST SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE. SEVERAL
PEOPLE AT. HELLO MY NAME IS A
PLAY FAMILY AND I'M A PARENT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I'M TO SEVENTEEN
PLEASE CALL HAVE. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE AND I LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I WON TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE THE WOMAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE NINETY THREE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M TO SEVENTY EIGHT PEOPLE
HAS. ARE YOU MY NAME IS JENNIFER
CALLING FINAL. THE THING OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I DANCE GOD AND
YOU JUST AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THAT VILE BILLS THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK. THANK YOU RYAN WHITE A PRE
GO AHEAD. THE BILLION FEEL OF
ANGELES. AND MY MOTHER AND OF.
YEAH STRONG OPPOSE TO AT NINE
TWENTY THREE THANK. THANKS
WITNESS HERE FLYING TO TWO
PLEASE CALL HAS. AS SOON ALAMEDA
CAN HAS OPPOSE. SB. NINE TWO
THREE AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANKS WITNESS. THANK YOU I WON
SIXTY ONE HAVE. ON SARAH
LAUGHTER CAN GRAND AND I AM
OPPOSED. TO NINE TWENTY. THANK
YOU THAT'S WHAT. THANK YOU THREE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS NINA MOM A WOMAN AND
I THE- SB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THANK YOU SIX WITNESS. THANK YOU
I'M THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
HAVE. THE MONEY IS GOING TO BE
ONE FROM SPOKE TO NINE FOUR
FIFTY NINE THREE THANK YOU NEXT
ONE. THANK ACCORDING TO PLEASE
CALL AHEAD. CAN THE NUMBER ONE
IN SOME HAPPENS ISSUE OF CAL BY
AND HEALTH INSURANCE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ENOUGH UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION BUT FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THAT AND THE NEXT FOR
THANK THAT'S WHAT. THANK YOU WHY
IS THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO MY NAME SANDRA MARQUEZ
IN AGREEMENT WITH THE TRAIN-
WHO'S LOOKING OFF TO THE JUST
EARLY. AND I AM OFFICE TO THIS I
THEN COSTS COUNTY YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THANKS WITH. THANK YOU
I'M THREE FORTY THREE GO AHEAD.
SHANOR MCGILL FELLOW K. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. RIGHT NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWO THREE YES
WE'VE HAVE. AND YET I OPPOSE- SB
NINE TWENTY CAROLINE RUBIO
ORANGE COUNTY THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BLYDEN ONE FIFTY EIGHT
BEFORE I. BY ONE EIGHT. RIGHT.
FORTY THREE IN THE- HOLES SB.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH. RIGHT THREE
FORTY THREE PER GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON STOMACH PLACES SMITH
FROM PREVENTIVE ON BEHALF OF
WOMEN'S RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
FINANCED OPPOSITION TO THE
MEDICAL EXPERIMENTATION
INSPIRATION- NEXT ROTATION OF
NEXT WITNESS. NAME OR POSITION
OVERLY. THANK YOU I'M THREE
FORTY FIVE PEOPLE AT ALL I MEAN
THEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
IS GDP ABOUT HOW WE CAN SEE HOW
WE ARE REPORT THE BILL PARK FROM
- VIDEO SUPPORT SESSION THANK
YOU ARE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I'M A FOUR PLEASE HAVE
. YES PLEASE WHAT YOURSELF
MEMORIZATION DOES. THIS IS MARTY
HILLS NEVER I FROM THE CITY AND
I'M OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WHY IN THREE FIFTY OF
THE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
THE YOUNGER I'M FROM AND THE
NUMBER TWO CAL AND I. OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT. THANK
YOU RYAN THREE FOR TWO FOR A- HI
MY NAME IS LI I'M A DEMOCRAT
YEAH FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY.
SB NINE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. BY THREE SIXTY
PLEASE CALL HAS. HI I'M JOE HE
GREETS KESSLER HONEY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH- I HOPE
WE ARE ABLE TO ADDRESS- AT THE
REPORTS THAT THERE MIGHT BE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET
ON SO HOPEFULLY WE WILL LOOK
INTO THAT- LET'S NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE- COMMITTEE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SAN ANDREAS-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO I WANTED
TO ASK CAPT IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
COMING UP TO THE MICROPHONE I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR YOU
THANK YOU. SO DON'T BE NERVOUS-
I KNOW IT'S PROBABLY FEELS
STRANGE STANDING BEHIND THE
PLEXIGLAS- I JUST WANTED TO HEAR
A LITTLE MORE ABOUT. THE
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU HAD- YOU
ONLY HAD YOU KNOW TWO MINUTES
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE. DECIDES
THEY WANT TO GO THROUGH THIS
TRANSITION AND IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE YOU AID YOU STARTED
OFF- THAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
GAVE YOU. TESTOSTERONE WITHOUT
WELL I WILL PUT WORDS IN MATH
PLEASE IF YOU IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND TAKE YOUR TIME. YEAH SO I
STARTED IDENTIFYING AS TRANS AT
THE AGE OF THIRTEEN AND- DUE TO
WANTING 2% TO PURSUE SINGING AS
MY CAREER- AND YOU KNOW JUST
VARIOUS OTHER REASONS I DID NOT
TRANSITION UNTIL I WAS AN ADULT
BUT- AT THAT TIME I WAS NOT IN
ANY THERAPY- I CALLED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MAINLY WITH THE AIM
OF JUST- EXPLORING MY GENDER
DYSPHORIA- I ASSUME THERE WOULD
BE. SOME TYPE OF REQUIREMENTS
LIKE A LETTER FROM A DOCTOR OR
THERAPIST WHATEVER- BUT INSTEAD
I WAS JUST IMMEDIATELY AFFIRMS
AT- AS A TRANSGENDER MAN AND- I
JUST TALK TO THE DOCTOR THERE
FOR ABOUT THIRTY MINUTES AND I
GOT MY PRESCRIPTION AND THEN
BASICALLY THE SAME THING WHICH
WAS TRUE FOR. MY TOP SURGERY
LETTER WHICH I GOT APPROVAL FOR
ABOUT A MONTH LATER ALSO FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OVER THE
PHONE. OKAY SORRY OKAY SO YOU
SAID THERE WERE NO- I GUESS-
PSYCHIATRIC- APPOINTMENTS THAT
YOU WERE REQUIRED TO HAVE THAT
SORT OF YOU KNOW- ADDRESS. HERE
THE MINDSET AND EVERYTHING THAT
GOES ALONG WITH WITH THE
DECISION THAT'S THAT'S THIS
MONUMENTAL NO THERE ARE NO-
THERE ARE NO APPOINTMENTS WITH
THE PSYCHOLOGIST OR
PSYCHIATRIST- REQUIRED AND I
JUST WANT TO ADD THAT THIS IS
THE INFORMED CONSENT MODEL WHICH
IS IT THIS IS WHAT TRANS
ACTIVISTS ARE PUSHING FOR THIS
IS WHAT THEY WANT EVERYWHERE-
THEY WANT YOU TO JUST BE ABLE
TO. GET IT ON YOUR AND GET GET
THE HORMONES AND SURGERY- ON
YOUR FIRST APPOINTMENTS. OKAY I
SEE IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE THAT
YOU WANTED TO SHARE WITH US
TODAY THAT YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO
SHARE IN YOUR FIRST- GO AT THE
MICROPHONE NOW IS YOUR CHANCE. A
WELL HOURS THANK YOU I WILL
SHARE THAT ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT THINGS AS A D.
TRANSITION OR IS IT- THERE IS
ACTUALLY A LOT OF SUPPORT SET UP
ALREADY FOR TRANSITIONING.
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT FOR
DE TRANSITIONING- YOU KNOW
MYSELF I HAVEN'T GOTTEN ANY
CORRECTIVE SURGERY BUT MANY DO
TRANSITION OR IS TO REQUIRE THAT
AND- IT IS NOT COVERED BY
INSURANCE LIKE TRANS SERVICES
ARE- AND THERE'S A LACK OF
SOCIAL SUPPORT. BY TRANSACTION
THIS TEND TO IGNORE THE
TRANSITION EARNERS- SO IT'S A
VERY DIFFICULT POSITION TO BE AN
AND ALSO THAT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN MY SITUATION IS RISING
AND THIS THIS PUSH FOR
AFFIRMATIVE CARE. AND INFORMED
CONSENT MODEL IS ONLY GOING TO
CREATE. MORE SITUATIONS LIKE
MINE BECAUSE IT IT'S ELIMINATING
THE REQUIREMENTS- AND ALSO JUST
I JUST WANT TO ADD ONE MORE
THING AND THAT IS THAT IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FOR HUMANS TO
LITERALLY CHANGE SEX AND- YOU
KNOW THESE PROCEDURES THAT ARE.
ARE BEING PRESCRIBED SO EASILY-
THEY THEY DO THEY'RE DOCUMENTED
TO LEAD TO HEALTH PROBLEMS. HI
HIRE- INCREASED RISK OF HEART
ATTACK STROKE CANCER- YOU KNOW
THESE ARE KNOWN RISKS AND- SERVE
YOU. CHANGE TAX AND BY TELLING
THEM THAT THAT THEY CAN AND
LEADING THEM DOWN THIS PATH- IT
IS HARMING A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
SO. I JUST WANT TO BRING SOME
ATTENTION TO THAT SIDE OF THE
ISSUE. OKAY THANK YOU CAN I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS I KNOW
IT'S HARD TO. SHARE SOMETHING SO
PERSONAL BUT WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME- SO I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- SENATOR
WIENER. SO THE FIRST QUESTION IS
WHO WOULD PROVIDE THE EVIDENCE
BASED CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAINING. TO HEALTH CARE STAFF
IN THE THEIR CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS. TO THE CENTER THANK
YOU FOR THAT- QUESTION OF COURSE
THE BILL IS BEING AMENDED SO
IT'S NO LONGER GOING TO BE A
STANDALONE- MANDATED. MULTI HOUR
TRAINING FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER INSTEAD IT'S GOING TO
BE WOVEN INTO THE EXISTING.
CONTINUING EDUCATION- AND
THAT'LL BE DONE THROUGH THE
NORMAL PROCESS IN TERMS OF HOW
CONTINUING EDUCATION- IS CRAFTED
ON WHO WOULD BE PROVIDING THAT
TRAINING THERE COULD BE. A LOT
COULD BE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PEOPLE OR ORGANIZATIONS- YOU YOU
COULD DEFINITELY THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
TRAINING ON- ON AUG ON THESE
ISSUES AND YOUR CONTRACT WITH
THEM. I MEAN IT COULD BE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT- I CAN SEE
SPECIFICALLY WHO'S GONNA BUT SO
OKAY SO WOULD IT BE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD THAT
WOULD DETERMINE OR DECIDE WHO
PROVIDES THIS TRAINING. IT IS-
AND DOCTOR PAN PROBABLY AROUND
TERMS OF HALCION ME IS CRAFTED
ON PERHAPS OFFER PAN COULDN'T
COMMENT ON THE OUTSIDE. L. AS A
PHYSICIAN RUBIO COMMENTS. AS A
PHYSICIAN WHO HAS SOME KNOWLEDGE
OF THE MEDICAL EDUCATION PROCESS
THAT THE ME IS ACTUALLY. USUALLY
SPONSORED BY. MEDIC MEDIC ORGANS
. OR YOU ORGANIZATIONS SO
EXAMPLE ACOSTA OR HEALTH- AND
ACADEMICAL SENT. MEDICAL WITH-
BASICALLY- WOULD SPONSOR CNN
THEY WOULD SEEK OUT EXPERTS- IN
THE FIELD- TO PROVIDE- THAT
CONTENT AND TO TEACH THAT
CONTENT AND OFTENTIMES THERE'S-
THAT'S THE VERY VIGOROUS-
REVIEW. OF THE SCIENTIFIC
ACCURACY AND ALSO BY THE WAY-
ALSO A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
PROVISIONS THAT ALSO REQUIRED IN
FOR CME. NOW THIS IS I THINK-
YEP THERE'S ALSO OTHER AND
COURSE FOR THOSE OF US ON TV WE
IF KNOWN I'VE ALWAYS BRING UP
QUESTIONS ABOUT US CONTINUING
EDUCATION- OF AGAIN- SOMETIMES
SOMEBODY'S CONTINUE EDUCATION.
COURSES ARE ALSO A DEPENDING ON
THE PARTICULAR PROFESSION HEALTH
PROFESSION AND MAY ALSO BE
REVIEWED BY THE- OF. THE
LICENSING BOARD AS WELL FOR
APPROVAL. OKAY SIR THEN. THAT
ARE DEVELOP. MEDICAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL ISSUES RELATED TO
HEALTH CARE FOR TRANSGENDER
PATIENTS DOES YOUR BILL REQUIRE
THESE COMPETENCY TRAINERS TO BE
MEDICALLY TRAINED. THE BILL
REQUIRES CMA AS AMENDED THAT
SEMI TAKEN TO ACCOUNT THE NEEDS
OF TRANS GENDER NON CONFORMING
AND INTERSEX PATIENTS THAT'S
WHAT IT REQUIRES CELLS OR
WHATEVER THE CME PROCESS IS-
DOCTOR PENSIONS RIDICULOUS
HAVING GONE THROUGH IT HIMSELF
FOR MANY YEARS- THAT WOULD BE
THE PROCESS HERE AGAIN. TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN VARIOUS COMPONENTS
OF HEALTH PRACTICE- THAT
TRANSGENDER ARE CONFORMING
INTERSEX PEOPLE- ARE BEING
TREATED BY PROVIDERS WHO
ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDS WHO THEY
ARE- AND THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS.
OKAY SO- THE BILL DOESN'T
SPECIFY- WHO WOULD DO THE
TRAINING WHO WOULD BE QUALIFIED
TO DO THE TRAINING YOUR IT'S
ESSENTIALLY WITH THE AMENDMENTS
LEAVING IT UP TO. THE MEDICAL
BOARD ESSENTIALLY THAT THE
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION.
CHOI THERE'S BEEN CONTINUING
MENTAL AS MEDICAL EDUCATION FOR
MANY MANY MANY MANY MANY YEARS
ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS NO I
UNDERSTAND I JUST RETURNING TO.
WHERE THE RESPONSIBILITY LIES
AND I AM NOT A POSITION BUT I
IMAGINE SOME OF THOSE TRAININGS
ARE BY. OTHER PHYSICIANS SOME OF
THOSE TRAININGS MAY NOT BE BY
PHYSICIANS BECAUSE OF PHYSICIANS
AREN'T ALL IT YOU KNOW YOU COULD
AS A LAWYER. WHEN I DID
CONTINUING LEGAL EDUCATION
SOMETIMES THERE WERE SUBJECTS
THAT YOU THAT YOU DON'T NEED A
LAWYER WASN'T RELEVANT THERE
WERE OTHER PEOPLE IF SOMEONE'S
COMING TO TRAIN YOU FOR EXAMPLE
ABOUT YOU KNOW SAY SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ISN'T THAT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE. A LAWYER AND THE
SAME IS TRUE IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION AS A WHOLE IT DEPENDS
ON WHAT IT IS AND IF A- YOU KNOW
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS A- SAID
TRANS PERSON. IS GOING TO TALK
TO PHYSICIANS ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE OF TRANS PATIENTS AND
HOW TO BE SENSITIVE AND
SUPPORTIVE BUT DOESN'T NEED TO
BE A PHYSICIAN FOR EXAMPLE
TWENTY SAMPLE OF ONE COMPONENT.
OF TRAINING. A SUMMONS AND THIS
IS. THAT FOR. POSITIONS MIGHT
WANT HEAR FROM THE- FROM PERSON
ON THE PHONE. WITH A TERRIBLE X.
RIGHT THAT HEARING ABOUT
EXPERIENCES CAN BE HELPFUL IN
SAYING SO THAT PHYSICIANS ARE
MINDFUL. WHEN THEY TREAT TGI
PATIENTS BUT IT REALLY DEPENDS
YEAH I AND I AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPRESSION I GUESS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO GET AT IS- IT YOU KNOW
WHO IS GOING TO BE DOING THIS
TRAINING WHERE- HERE IS THERE A
NATIONAL. IS- CERTIFICATION
PROCESSES ARE SOME ACCREDITATION
PROCESS UNSETTLED GROUP SOME
PEOPLE CAN YES TWO I AND I
CENTER BECAUSE- LAUGHING BUT NO
NO I IT'S BECAUSE SOCIETY HAS
TRIED TO RACE. TGI PEOPLE
FOREVER AND IN FACT IN THE
TESTIMONY TODAY WE HEARD A THEME
ABOUT TRANS PEOPLE NOT REALLY
EXISTING AND WE LOOK AROUND THE
COUNTRY RONALD THE RESTROOM
STUFF IN THE SPORTS ETCETERA
ETCETERA THE THEME IS THAT TRANS
PEOPLE ARE ALSO SPEAKING AT AND
THEY DON'T REALLY EXIST AND ARE
TRYING TO PULL SOME SORT OF SCAM
THAT'S- THE TEAM. THAT THAT THAT
THAT HAS BEEN REFERRED TO TODAY
AND WE HEAR IT AROUND THE
COUNTRY SO BECAUSE OF THAT THERE
THERE'S NO ACCREDITATION BODY
FOR AS I SAID IN MY OPENING
REMARKS CALIFORNIA WOULD BE THE
FIRST STATE TO DO THIS. I'M PART
OF THE REASON THAT THIS BILL-
IT'S BEEN AMENDED PER WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE IS TO CREATE UNDER
DMACC EXHIBIT WITH A RESEARCH
US. A WORKING GROUP THAT WOULD
NOT WOULD INCLUDE TGI PEOPLE WHO
WOULD NOT BE LIMITED TO TGI
PEOPLE WOULD INCLUDE ON EXPERTS
IN AND PRACTICE AND- IN
EDUCATION I TO COME UP WITH BOTH
THE CURRICULUM- AS WELL AS-
STANDARDS PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS- SO THAT THAT WERE THE
FIRST IN THE NATION- TO DO THAT
AND I'M PROUD THAT WE ARE. WELL
OKAY SO I GUESS YOU KNOW FROM
WHERE I SIT IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S
A BIT OF A WORK IN PROGRESS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T REALLY
IDENTIFIED WHO IS QUALIFIED TO
DO THIS TYPE OF TRAINING OR WHO-
WILL DO IT BUT THE BILL DOES.
MAKE IT- A- TO NOT PROVIDE THIS
. SO IT I FEEL A LITTLE LEGWORK
I DON'T THINK IT'S A CRIME IT
WOULD BE REFERRED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE OF OR I DON'T
WELL I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WERE
VOTING ON WHAT'S BEFORE SAYING I
THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION EVERYTHING THAT'S
IN THE ANALYSIS SOMEONE AND
THINGS IT'S IN THE ANALYSIS IS
ON THE FACT THAT YOU YOU KNOW FM
A PROVIDER COULD GET INTO SOME
TROUBLE AND E FINE A LARGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY IF THEY DON'T
PROVIDE- THIS TRAINING SO- WELL
IF SOMETHING IS. WELL FIRST OF
ALL AGAIN. WHAT OKAY AMENDED.
BUT YES- WHAT WE DO MANDATE
THINGS LIKE TRAINING YOU HAVE
TO. DO IT AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF A RIGHT BUT WE DON'T
ENDORSE WE DON'T YET KNOW WHO'S
QUALIFIED TO EVEN DO THIS
TRAINING SO- MY FINAL. QUESTION
WOULD BE- WHAT IF THE. MEDICAL
PROVIDER HAS A DIFFERENT
EVIDENCE BASED. OPINION DAN THE
COMPETENCY TRAINERS LIKE WHAT IF
WHAT IF THEY'RE NOT MATCHING UP
WHAT I MEAN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
THE MEDICAL PROVIDER HAS TO
DEFER TO THE OPINION OF THE
COMPETENCY TRAINER EVEN THOUGH
ONE HAS GONE TO MEDICAL SCHOOL
THE OTHER LIKELY HAS NOT. SO ARE
YOU REFERRING TO RELIGIOUS
OBJECTIONS TO TREAT NO PEOPLE NO
BY THAT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE- REFERRING TO BECAUSE WE
HEAR THAT A LOT ABOUT- BY.
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHO FOR
RELIGIOUS REASONS DON'T WANT TO
TREAT LGBTQ PEOPLE. AND SURVEYS
THEREFORE THE PLAN- NO I'M NOT
AN EXEMPTION WHICH I DON'T AGREE
WITH. NO I'M STE- NO I DIDN'T
MEAN SOMEBODY WHO- I MEAN YOU
KNOW A PHYSICIAN WHO MEETS WITH
THE PATIENT AND HAS A DISCUSSION
ABOUT- ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
TRANSITIONING OR EVEN JUST IN
THE INITIAL STAGES LIKE. THE
WITNESS WHO TESTIFIED TODAY-
THAT YOU KNOW THE PHYSICIAN MAY.
LISTENED EVERYTHING AND THINK
YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE THAT THIS
PERSON IS- IS READY- TO MOVE
PERHAPS TO THE NEXT STEP. SOME
MORE- YOU KNOW DISCUSSION
PERHAPS NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE AND
SO WHAT IF THE COMPETENCY
TRAINER SAYS NO THANK THAT'S
THAT'S NOT HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS THAT'S NOT THE WAY THE
SYSTEM IS TO BE DONE I DON'T
THINK SO THE COMPANY TRADE THIS
COMPETENCY IF THERE. WAS ONE
THERE ARE TRAININGS AND STANDARD
WHEN THEIR MINDS ARE FORMULATED
IT'S NOT ABOUT LIKE THIS IS HOW
YOU PRACTICE MEDICINE IN TERMS
OF LIKE YOU THIS IS WHEN YOU DO
A PROCEDURE OR HOW YOU DO A
PROCEDURE PHYSICIANS GET TRAINED
AND PROVIDING GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE AND NOT EVERY POSITION. IS
TRAINED TO DO THAT AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS THE OTHER
PART OF THIS BILL IS REQUIRING
THAT HEALTH PLANS IN THEIR
NETWORK DIRECTORIES IDENTIFY WHO
WERE THE PHYSICIANS THAT PROVIDE
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE TO TRANS
PEOPLE- DON'T HAVE TO GAS AND
DON'T HAVE TO MAKE A THOUSAND
PHONE CALLS THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY SEE HERE THE PEOPLE WHO
AGREE TO THAT WHO HAVE BEEN
TRAINED- TO DO THAT. SO THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WHEN
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
PROVIDING HEALTH CARE SERVICES-
BUT THEY'RE DOING IT IN A WAY
THAT UNDERSTANDS A TRANS PEOPLE
EXIST A THIRD TITLE TO RESPECT
THIS IS HOW YOU INTERACT. WITH
THEM- AND SO FORTH- OKAY WELL- I
THINK THAT'S- I THINK THAT'S ALL
I HAVE RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
RICHARD. SIR EDMUND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I KNOW LAST TIME I
HAD TO DO MY CME FOR MY LICENSE-
BY CONTINUING EDUCATIONS
DISCOURTESY USE- WAS ON A BILL
THAT WE DID HERE IN THIS IN THIS
BODY HE WAS ON A SUICIDE AND SO-
HI THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE
DO RIGHT WE PASS BILLS ABOUT
WHAT WE THINK PROFESSIONALS CAN
KNOW ABOUT OF THE WE SHOULD
THINK THEY SHOULD KNOW MORE. AND
THEN WE TRUST- THEIR
PROFESSIONAL BODIES TO DEVELOP
THOSE AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD
IDEA YOU ALSO BRING TOGETHER A
GROUP TO LOOK AT IT SO CENTER
WINNER MIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING
RIGHT NOW I'M JUST GOING TO
SPEAK TO A LITTLE. SOME OF THE
WHAT WE HEARD. IS IN ORDER FOR
SOMEONE TO RECEIVE MEDICATION OR
TO BEGIN ANY KIND OF
TRANSITIONING PROCESS THEY HAVE
TO FIRST HAVE A DIAGNOSIS OF
GENDER DYSPHORIA. DOT AND AS AN
ASSISTANT YOU DON'T YOU DON'T
MAKE A DIAGNOSIS LIKE THAT
WITHOUT A FEW VISITS FOR SOMEONE
SO. TO SOMEONE WHO WENT TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND RECEIVE
MEDICATIONS ALREADY HAD TO HAVE
AN EVALUATION TO BE GIVEN A
DIAGNOSIS OF GENDER DYSPHORIA.
AS YOU UNDERSTAND IT. THIRD
THIRD ROUND NOT A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL AND I KNOW BUT I
PREFER SITE AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY. WILL BE HEARD A LOT TODAY-
I KNOW. FIVE I KNOW AND
REPRESENT A HUGE NUMBER OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE- I KNOW AN
ENORMOUS NUMBER TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE. WHO ARE. EXTREMELY
HAPPY. THAT THEY HAVE NOW HAVE
THE CORRECT GENDER GENDER
IDENTITY BACK FORMS TO WHO THEY
ARE- AND- THEY AND SO THIS WHOLE
NOTION THAT. TRANSIT FATE CAN
EVERYONE'S UNHAPPY IT IS DOES
NOT IS NOT TRUE- DAY I ALSO IN
SAN FRANCISCO WE'RE BLESSED TO
HAVE MEDICAL PROVIDERS. WHO
PROVIDE EXCELLENT CARE- AND LIKE
THAT CARE IS WHAT IT IS AND YES
THERE ARE I YOU KNOW I'M I'M-
NOT WITH PEOPLE YOU. ABOUT THIS
AND THERE ARE YES THERE ARE ALL
SORTS OF PROTOCOLS AND DIFFERENT
KINDS OF EVALUATIONS THAT PEOPLE
RECEIVE- WHEN THEY ARE
CONSIDERING- TRANSITIONING. OF
COURSE THIS BILL THIS BILL DOES
NOT DEFINE. WHAT MEDICAL CARE IS
DOES NOT- IT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ABOUT PROTOCOLS AND TRAINING AND
CULTURAL COMPETENCY. THANK YOU
AND I WOULD JUST TRY TO GET TO
SEE SOME OF WHAT WE HEARD THAT
MAY ALARM PEOPLE IS THAT PEOPLE
JUST. CALLING ON THE PHONE AND
GET PRESCRIPTIONS. SO DID SO
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE HERE'S WHAT
I KNOW AS A LICENSED PERSON
WHO'S TRAINED OTHER LICENSE
PEOPLE. IN ORDER TO GET. THE
DIAGNOSIS OF GENDER DYSPHORIA
YOU HAVE TO HAVE MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE MEETINGS FOR THE MOST
PART- BEFORE THE DIAGNOSIS IS
GIVEN AND THEN. IN ORDER FOR THE
TRANSITION TO OCCUR. THAT THAT
THAT'S WHAT IT'S BASED ON- SO-
IN AND I AGREE WE HEARD WE HEARD
. WE HEARD A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT PEOPLE
DENYING PEOPLE'S EXISTENCE
SAYING IT'S NOT REAL THING IT'S
FAKE- AND I AND I GET THERE
COULD BE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
BUT I THINK OUR JOB AS
LEGISLATORS IS TO MAKE SURE OUR
SYSTEMS ARE JUST- AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE WE'RE TRYING
TO DO- SO. THIS BILL HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH MANDATING ANYTHING
BUT THAT PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW
ABOUT- WHO THEY SEE ANNA AND I
FEEL LIKE A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. ACTUALLY
SUPPORT YOUR BILL. THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE MORE CONVERSATION
THAT IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT
SHOULDN'T BE SHOCKING TO A
PHYSICIAN WHO WALKS IN. AND SEES
SOMETHING HE MAY NOT. HE OR SHE
MAY NOT EXPECT THAT IF WE HAVE
CONTINUING EDUCATION SOMEBODY
WOULD KNOW A BETTER WAY AND EVEN
IF YOU YOU KNOW IT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE TO NOT TREAT
SOMEBODY. BUT AT LEAST TO BE
ABLE TO BACK OUT OF A ROOM IN A
DIFFERENT KIND OF WAY. THEN
HUMILIATING SOMEONE AND CAN
CAUSING FURTHER HARM- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
KNOW THESE ARE YOU KNOW THAT IT
IS A- IS A DIFFICULT PLACE TO
SIT- WHEN PEOPLE. WANT TO DENY
OTHER PEOPLE'S VERY EXISTENCE
TONIGHT BY SHARED RECENTLY I BY
BLUSTER FAMILY MEMBER. AT THE
END OF LAST YEAR THE YOUNG
PERSON WHO WANT TO TRANSITION.
ERRANT'S AGAIN HEARING A LOT OF
WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY. AND
ANNA. OF THAT AND THEN. HEARING
A LOT. OF ARE AFRAID FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND SAID NOW. THEN THAT
PERSON THEN DECIDED TO PURSUE IT
ON THEIR OWN AFTER THEY- WHEN
THEY TURNED EIGHTEEN AND THE
PARENTS AND LEAVE AND THEY DID.
AND ENDED UP. OVERDOSING TWO
DAYS LATER. SO IT IS A IT IS NOT
SOMETHING FAKE THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING MADE UP TO SEE WHO
PEOPLE ARE. AND WE NEED TO FIND.
EVERY WAY THAT WE CAN TO MAKE
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. B. AS-
INFORMED. TO BE ABLE TO HELP
PEOPLE. AS HE CAN. SO WHEN THE
APPROPRIATE TIMES I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL. POSTED BY SIR
EDMUND TELEPHONE. THANK YOU AND
YOU KNOW AS IT IS A LISTEN TO
THE CONVERSATION AND ALL THE
SIDES- PRESENT A THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT I'VE BROUGHT TO THIS
COMMITTEE- THE BILLS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE. ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
INCLUSION OF DIFFERENT TOPICS A
LOT OF YOU KNOW I'VE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME- AROUND THE ALZHEIMER'S
SPACE AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I LEARNED TO- ABOUT BRINGING IN
BEING A LEGISLATOR IN BRINGING
BILLS FORWARD THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THAT OUR MEDICAL PROVIDERS. HAVE
MORE TRAINING NOT LESS TRAINING
IS THAT WE DON'T ACTUALLY
DICTATE. WHO DOES THE TRAINING
BECAUSE THAT IS THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY THAT DECIDES WHO IS
THE RIGHT PERSON SO I'M NOT SURE
THAT WE WOULD BE IN A POSITION
TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE X.
PERSON OR THAT PERSON BE THE
TRAINERS- BUT ALSO AS SOMEONE
THAT'S WORKED WITH HUNDREDS OF
STUDENTS- THROUGHOUT MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER UP THERE ARE
SO MANY REASONS TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING REGARDLESS
OF WHAT OUR CAREER IS- AND I
THINK THAT. IT IT YOU KNOW
INCLUDING A BROADER
UNDERSTANDING I THINK IS THE
RIGHT MEDICAL DIRECTION TO GO-
NOT INCLUDING BLESS AND AS I
READ YOUR BILL THAT'S WHAT I
UNDERSTOOD AT THE BILL TO BE
DOING TO BE ASKING OUR MEDICAL
COMMUNITY TO HAVE MORE
UNDERSTANDING AND MORE AND ARE
STANDING. IS BE INCLUSIVE TO OF
EXPERIENCES A VARIETY OF
INFORMATION IT ALSO NGUYEN
SHORES- AND I THINK THAT SENATOR
EGGMAN ALLUDED TO THIS WE HAVE
TO DO YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO GET
TRAINING CONTINUOUSLY. AND THE
REASON WE DO THIS IS BECAUSE
THERE IS ALWAYS MORE WE CAN
LEARN AND IF WE ONLY DO IT YOU
KNOW ON A ONE TIME BASIS AND NOT
DO IT ONGOING- WE LIMIT HOW. WE
CAN BE A TO EITHER FOR IN MY
CASE IT WAS THE STUDENT BUT IN
THE CASE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IT'S TO THE
PATIENT RIGHT. AND SO I'M
GRATEFUL THAT THIS BILL HAS COME
FORWARD- I UNDERSTAND AND I
BELIEVE THAT MORE TRAINING AT IS
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO GO TO BE
INCLUSIVE OF THE MUCH
INFORMATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
UNDERSTOOD. TO BE A BETTER
PROVIDER- AND I ALSO KNOW HOW
HARD THESE BILLS ARE TO DEAL-
BECAUSE CERTAINLY OUR MEDICAL
COMMUNITY FEELS AT THAT. IN
ADDITION TO BEING PRACTITIONERS
THEY HAVE CONTINUOUS RIGHT
LEARNING TO DEAL ON SO MANY
ISSUES- SO I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS TO MOVE BILLS THAT
INCLUDE. YOU KNOW MORE TRIP.
THROUGH THE PROCESS- AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND WAYS. THAT
OUR MEDICAL COMMUNITY FEELS MORE
CONFIDENT TO BE YOU KNOW BE ABLE
TO BEST SERVE- THE PATIENT AND
THAT'S BY KNOWING MORE NOT
KNOWING LESS. OKAY THANK YOU.
SERAPH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OBVIOUSLY THIS ISSUE OF THE OVER
ARCHING ISSUE OF- TRANSGENDER
HEALTH CARE IS A CONTROVERSIAL
ONE THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN HERE
FOR ANY LENGTH OF TIME EVEN MORE
THAN A MINUTE CERTAINLY KNOW
THAT. BUT YOU KNOW IT SAYS SINCE
IT SEEMS TO ME THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY ABOUT. PROVIDING A
DIRECTORY. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING SERVICES. TEN PROVIDING
TO THOSE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO HOLD
THEMSELVES OUT AS PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SOME
TRAINING ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
PEOPLE. PEOPLE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
AND I SEE NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT SO I GUESS THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BUT I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FOR. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SAYING NONE- FOR
THAT- CENTER WINNER FIRST BY ONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH ME IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF I
KNOW WE'VE MADE SOME.
SIGNIFICANT MAINTENANCE TO THE
BILL- BUT I THINK IT'S IN THE
SPIRIT OF- TRYING TO COPE OF
ACTUALLY WANTING TO SET A HIGHER
STANDARD FOR THE CARE OF- TGI
PATIENTS AND- I SAY THE CARE OF
THIS NOT JUST DIRECT PATIENT
CARE BUT ALSO THE- OVERALL
HEALTH CARE. EXPERIENCE AS WELL
AND- I WOULD MAKE NOTES THAT-
IS- A AS A PHYSICIAN WHO TO TAKE
SENIOR MY SCENE REQUIRED- EVERY
EVERY TWO YEARS EVERY TIME EVERY
NEW MODEL. AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
THINGS WE HAVE TO LEARN AND KEEP
UP WITH- BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
THAT WE PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
CARE TO ALL OF OUR PATIENTS AND
INCLUDES OUR TGI PATIENTS AND-
DID YOU MISS AS I HEARD FROM
YOUR TESTIMONY AND THE TESTIMONY
OF THE WITNESSES SAID. THAT TOO
OFTEN IS NOT HAPPENING AND WE
NEED TO CHANGE THAT- I WOULD
MAKE A NOTE THAT- I KNOW THERE
ARE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
OVERSIGHT OVER WHO'S TEACHING
WELL THAT'S ACTUALLY THERE IS
OVERSIGHT OVER REALLY CERTAINLY.
OVERSEE CONTINUING EDUCATION IN
THE MEDICAL SIDE- YOU HAVE TO DO
YOU POINT OUT SENATOR- WE SHOULD
TRY TO FIND THE BEST EDUCATORS
WE CAN WRITE AND THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS ALL PHYSICIANS BUT THE-
OVERALL PROGRAM IS HAS TO BE
OVERSEEN BY THE SEAMY SPONSORS
AND THERE'S ALSO ACCREDITATION
INVOLVED. SAMETIME AND OTHER
HEALTH PROFESSIONS AT FOR IT
SOMETIMES THE BOARD IS INVOLVED
SO DAMPEN THE NURSING BOARD ONE
WEEK. OVERSEAS THEIR SEE AND
OTHERS OR OTHERS MAY HAVE
ACCREDITATION BIASES WELL SO
THAT'S WELL ESTABLISHED THAT'S
HOW WE DO SEE IT THAT'S HOW YOU
DO CONTINUING EDUCATION- THERE
ARE STANDARDS OUT THERE FOR
THAT- AND- THAT THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING TO SURE OF THAT- WE HAVE
FIVE QUALITY. CD- THIS. OTHER
PART AS WELL IT IN THE AMENDMENT
THAT I. THAT I'M HOPING THEY'LL
SIMPLY MOVE- THE PURPOSE YOU
BILL FOR IS ACTUALLY-
ESTABLISHING STANDARDS QUALITY
CARE BECAUSE ALL. IT'S NOT ABOUT
TAKING A CLASS. RIGHT AND
CERTAINLY PEOPLE WHO THAT MAY
NOT KNOW ENOUGH FOR CLASSES
IMPORTANT AND- BUT A QUALITY
STANDARD THAT ACTUALLY MEASURES
THE QUALITY CARE TO PROVIDING TO
THIS POPULATION AND FRANKLY- YOU
KNOW- IF- WHEN- AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THE WITNESSES ON BOTH SIDES
WHEN. THE RISK WHEN THE- SALT IT
IS IT IS NOT SATISFACTORY YOURS
AROUND YES- THEN THE PROVIDERS
ALSO NEED TO KNOW THAT LIKE
BECAUSE LIKE FOR EXAMPLE HOW DO
YOU DO AS EVALUATION RIGHT. FOR
GENDER DYSPHORIA IS SO WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE DOING SUBSTANDARD
EVALUATIONS RIGHT- WE WANT TO BE
SURE TO THIS IS THAT- IF THEY
GET QUALITY OF CARE AND SO
FORTH. BUT IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AGAIN I THINK AS YOU
SAID- CENTER WIENER AND THAT. IS
THAT THE- THE TEACHER POPULATION
NEEDS TO BE SEEN RIGHT NOW AND
TO BE RECOGNIZED AND THAT IT'S
REAL. AND CELLS ARE THAT THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS WELL SO
AGAIN I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WORKING WITH ME I
KNOW WE DO A LOT OF WORK BACK
AND FORTH- AND- BUT I'M GLAD
THAT THERE IS I THINK HE SAID I
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE RESULT THAT
WILL AGAIN. IT'S NOT SO MUCH
BECAUSE WE WANT CALIFORNIA TO BE
THE FIRST SAYS BE NICE OF OTHER
STATES RECTOR HEAD OF US IN THAT
REGARD- NOT BECAUSE- BUT-
BECAUSE THAT MEANS AT LEAST
DIRECTOR WHAT'S HAPPENING
SOMEWHERE ELSE AT LEAST
CALIFORNIA. POLICE IS SENDING A
NEED A HIGHER BAR AND- AND
HOPEFULLY OTHER OTHER STATES
WILL FOLLOW US IN THAT SO
CERTAINLY- AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
TAKING AMENDMENTS OF RESTORING.
THE BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. WITH YOU. VERY MUCH MUCH
MISTER. YOU KNOW LOOK AT THE
HISTORY. OF OUR CARE SYSTEM. IN
THIS COUNTRY- THERE'S SO MUCH.
OF THERE'S MUCH. THERE SOME
LIVES HAVE BEEN SAVED SO MANY
ADVANCES. BUT THERE'S ALSO BEEN
B. THE UGLY SIDE. AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR COMMUNITIES HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. TO BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GET THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF CARE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HELPED AND THOSE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE HARMED. OVER LOOK
HISTORICALLY YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE THAT. BLACK COMMUNITIES
OFTEN HAVE LACK OF CONFIDENCE IN
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. WHICH
THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT YOU
LOOK AT TO SKI. OR OTHER
SITUATIONS WHERE THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IS BADLY ABUSED- BLACK
PEOPLE. AND SO WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED DURING COLLUDED. WHEN
THERE WAS A LACK OF CONFIDENCE
HESITANCY TO GET CARE AND THE
DISPARATE IMPACTS AND HARMS.
THAT WAS THE RESULT IT. WON'T
LOOK AT. HELP HELP HEALTHCARE IS
TREATED WOMEN OVER TIME WHETHER
IT WAS INSTITUTIONALIZING. YOU
KNOW WOMEN FOR BEING QUOTE
UNQUOTE HYSTERICAL. THAT WAS.
SEVEN FOR A LONG TIME UNTIL NOT
THAT LONG AGO AND OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH WOMEN HAVE BEEN
MARGINALIZED IN THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. WE LOOK AT THE ISSUE OF
LGBTQ COMMUNITY WERE USED TO BE
YOU WERE YOUR LGBTQ. YOU COULD
BE. THE WATER SHOCK THERAPY.
INSTITUTIONALIZE SIMPLY FOR
BEING WHO YOU ARE THAT WAS TO
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND THAT
AND IT HAS CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM DOESN'T SEE
PEOPLE WHO THEY ARE AND TREAT
THEM WITH BASIC RESPECT AND
DIGNITY THAT RECOGNIZES THEM AS
FULL HUMAN BEINGS AND THAT IS
THE CASE. WITH TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE AND GENDER NON CONFORMING
PEOPLE INTERSEX PEOPLE THAT ARE
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY THEY ARE
REAL THEY'RE NOT MADE UP
CONTRARY TO SOME OF THE-
TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD. TODAY
AND SOME OF THE POLITICAL
RHETORIC WE HEAR OVER AND OVER.
HI IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND
THEY AND THEY NEED HEALTH CARE.
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO GET
HEALTH CARE IF THEY BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE TREATED
POORLY AND OR TREATED BY SOMEONE
WHO DOESN'T HAVE ANY IDEA. WHO
THEY ARE OR HOW TO INTERACT WITH
THEM. AND THAT'S BAD FOR
EVERYONE. AT FOR EVERYONE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT FORCING
ANYONE TO GET ANY KIND OF HEALTH
CARE SOME OF THE TESTIMONY TODAY
WHICH IS FRANKLY NOT ON POINT
WITH WHAT THIS BILL. IS ABOUT
THIS BILL IS MAKING SURE THAT IF
YOU ARE TRANSGENDER. IF YOU ARE
TGI THAT YOU CAN WITH CONFIDENCE
GO SEE A MEDICAL PROVIDER AND
GET APPROPRIATE CARE. THAT'S
SOMETHING SO BASIC THAT
SOMETHING SO MANY OF US. TAKE
FOR GRANTED BUT YOU'RE GONNA GO
TO A DOCTOR THE DOCTOR IS GOING
TO SORT OF BE A PRETTY MUCH
UNDERSTAND WHO YOU ARE. AND WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH APPROPRIATE
CARE BUT TGI PEOPLE CAN'T TAKE
THAT FOR GRANTED. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL AIMS TO ADDRESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. OKAY SO THE MOTIONS TO
PASSES AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
SYSTEM SECOND BY CENTER EGGMAN-
THE- SO BECAUSE OWN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S NO EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ GROVE HER TADO. LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE LEE MOON. LIMON I
ROTH ROTH IRA. WIENER WIENER AYE. THIS. ONE SIX SIX ONE. RIGHT
CURRENT ROLE IS WHO WILL THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT. RIGHT NEXT
ITEMS ACTUALLY I THINK CENTER
FRAGMENTS SO INSTEAD YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER FOUR FOR
CENTER AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY UP
TO HAVING A LOT THIS YEAR FROM
UP TO OKAY RIGHT SO SIR I
UNDERSTAND YOU'LL BE PRESENTING
THIS- ITEM NUMBER FOUR BY
CENTER- SB TEN NINETEEN BY SARAH
GONZALEZ AND OF COURSE FOLLOWING
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR TWO BILLS SO-
IF YOU WISH TO PRESENT AT YOUR
DESK THAT'S OKAY RIGHT SO LET'S
MOVE ON THE ITEM NUMBER FOR SB
TEN NINETEEN. BY SERRA IS ALSO
PRESENTED BY CENTER EGGMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISSED HERE
MEMBERS- BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD
LIKE. X. THE COMMITTEES AND A
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON
PAGE SIX OF THE ANNOUNCES THAT
WILL HELP. CLARIFY ASSESSMENT
PORTION OF THE BILL. THE
REPRESENTED A BILL SENATE BILL
TO NINETEEN WE HAVE A CENTER
CONSOLES WHICH WILL ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO AND
AWARENESS OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. FOR BLACK INDIGENOUS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR COMMUNITIES.
ROUGHLY ONE IN FIVE MINUTE CAL
ENROLLEES WILL EXPERIENCE MENTAL
HEALTH SYMPTOMS IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR. AND THE ONGOING GLOBAL
PANDEMIC BECAUSE ONLY
EXASPERATED THE EXTRAORDINARY
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTHSERVICES
ESPECIALLY. AMONG BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN THE
HARDEST HIT. BY THE PANDEMIC.
WELL THE NEED HAS ONLY GROWN
THERE ARE STILL SIGNIFICANT
RACIAL DISPARITIES PRESENT IN
THE ACTUAL UTILIZATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED
UNDER MEDICAID MANAGED CARE
PLANS. RECENT DATA. EXCUSE ME
RECENT DATA SHOWING THE ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS AND LATINO
MEDICAL AND RELEASE. EXCESS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT THE
LOWEST RATE OF ALL ETHNIC GROUPS
. SB TEN NINETEEN WILL ADDRESS
THE SHORTCOMINGS OF ACCESS AND
AWARENESS BY REQUIRING
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ENGAGE IN DIRECT
EDUCATION. OF MEDICAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS FOR ROWLEY'S ML
HEALTH SERVICE PROVIDERS.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WILL
REQUIRE REQUIRE THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO CONDUCT ANNUAL RESEARCH
AND PROVIDE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY RELEVANT
EDUCATION AND MATERIALS TO
MEMBERS AND PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS ON THEIR OWN RELEASED
RIGHTS TO TIMELY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. UNDER THEIR PLANTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
DH CS TO WORK WITH CONSUMER
ADVOCATES AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO BUILD TOOLS.
SURVEYS AND PROTOCOLS FOR
ASSESSING THE QUALITY OF CARE.
FINALLY THE BILL REQUIRES THE H.
CEST IN A REPORT ON CONSUMERS
EXPERIENCE THE LEGISLATURE AND
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ON WHY
DISPARITIES EXIST.
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENT
AND DATA THAT PROVIDES GRANULAR
INFORMATION FOR THE
SUBPOPULATIONS. MEDICAL AND
REALLY DESERVE TO KNOW ABOUT
THEIR COVERAGE THEIR RIGHTS TO
TIMELY AND RESPECTFUL CARE AND
DESERVE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY RELEVANT
INFORMATION ON HOW THEY WOULD
ACCESS HELP. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY I
HAVE CAROLINA. BELLY BY A WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND DR PAUL SINCERA FROM
UCLA. I THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
EGGMAN- MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON TO LINE- CAROLINE THE LA
FUNDS PANTS CALIFORNIA CAN
AFFECT HEALTH NETWORK FOLLOWED
BY A TALL A SINCERE. FROM UCLA
A- ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE ACTUALLY REPRESENTING
UCLA- SO AGAIN YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH THAT CAROLINE- OF LA
. AND THANK YOU SENATOR PAM I AM
HERE TODAY AS PRIME TO THE HE
HAD NINETEEN. ENSURING ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO EVEN
INDIVIDUALS NEED TO PREVENT MORE
SEVERE AND MORE COFFEE MENTAL
HEALTH THAT'S CORRECT. SB YOU
CAN NINETEEN ONE GAP HAS BEEN I
. BY AWARENESS ABOUT NON
SPECIALTY OR MILD TO MODERATE
HEALTH SHE TWENTY FOUR HEALTH
MEDIC PROGRAM COULD MITIGATE
RESTRAINT ACTION. HOW COMMUNITY
CARE PLANS ARE WITH. FOR THE FOR
CAN HELP YOU. MILD TO MODERATE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION.
ACCORDING TO TWENTY FIVE DATA
FROM PHD. BLACK MEDIC HOW CAN
A MUCH LOWER RATE. AND MY NUMBER
. I HAVE AN API HELP. USE MENTAL
HEALTH AT THE LOWEST RATE OF
ALL. ETHNIC GROUPS. ACTIVE IN.
PART COMMUNITY THE FELLOW THAT
PUBLIC AT THE A DATA IF NOTHING
ELSE. NUMBER. TWENTY ONE. IF THE
WRITER FOR THE SENATE MAY
BENEFITS IN THE PART WHERE THE.
INCREASING AWARENESS REQUIRING
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
CONDUCT ANNUAL AVERAGES
EDUCATION TO CONTROL WEEDS.
REGARDING A MENTAL HEALTH
BENEFITS AND ASK MEDICAL
CONSUMER DIRECTLY ABOUT THEIR-
HEALTHCARE. IN ORDER FOR
CALIFORNIA TO FILL PROMISED TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE CARE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS REMARKABLE GAP.
EDUCATION THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. BUT MANY WERE PROMISED
YEARS AGO YET REMAIN. YES
SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT'S A THAT SON NOW MOVE ON
TO- PATEL. THE CHAIRMAN SENATORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
HERE- MY NAME IS A FULL
FOUNDATION I'M A RESIDENT
PHYSICIAN AT UCLA ALTHOUGH I'M
NOT REPRESENTING UCLA TODAY A
CULTURAL ANTHROPOLOGIST. AND A
PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR IN L. A.
COUNTY SAFETY. PROBLEMS SB TEN
NINETEEN TACKLES ARE PROBLEMS I
SEE EVERYDAY IN THE CLINIC. IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN I STARTED
CARING FOR A SPANISH SPEAKING
FEMALE MOM. OKAY RELIED ON MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE TO MEET HER
NEEDS. DURING OUR FIRST VISIT HE
DESCRIBED THE TREMENDOUS BURDEN
OF DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY THE
CHIP CARRIED INSIDE FOR YEARS
UNTREATED. LUCKILY ONE OF MY
SUPERVISORS HAVE TAKEN FIVE
MINUTES EARLIER THAT DAY TO
SHARE ONE PAGE FIRE HE CREATED
ON HIS OWN TIME WE COVERED OUR
COUNTIES MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BENEFITS. IN A REPRESENTS A
COMPLEX. THE A VISIT IF YOU HAVE
ALREADY FOR. AND SHUT UP AND
COIN. IN THE YEARS SINCE. I
REFERRED NEARLY HUNDRED ATIONS
THIS. SHORTCODES UP IN THE
ELECTRONIC MEDICAL SYSTEM IT. IT
IS SO SIMPLE. AND YET DESPITE
BEING A SAFETY NET CONNECTION I
MIGHT NEVER HAVE KNOWN HOW TO DO
IT IF NOT FOR THAT PARTICULAR
SUPERVISORS INTO THE MANAGING
THE SITUATION FOR OUR PATIENTS
SENATORS. EVEN THOSE FROM
CULTURALLY DOMINANT BACKGROUND
OFTEN DON'T KNOW THEIR RIGHTS
UNDER MEDICARE MANAGED CARE.
HELLO ANTHOLOGISED INCLINATION I
SEE AT THE CHALLENGES ARE EVEN
MORE DIRE WITH MY NORTEL'S
FEDERAL STATUS WHETHER ALONG
RACIAL. LINGUISTIC ETHNIC GENDER
OR SEXUALITY LINE. SB TEN
NINETEEN WILL FULHAM GAP BY
ENSURING MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS THAT CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY RELEVANT PATIENT
. JUST AS IMPORTANTLY IT'LL
MANDATE UNIVERSAL PROVIDER
EDUCATION. WHICH ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO LOOK AT THE DRAW THIS IS NOT
THE EXTRA BURDEN IT MAY SEEM AT
FIRST COMPARE NOTES WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO CLEAR THAT A FEW
MINUTES OF UP FRONT EDUCATION
CAN SAVE HOURS OF WASTED TIME.
IN THE ENDLESS FRUSTRATION AND
DISAPPOINTMENT TO COME WITH NOT
MEETING OUR PATIENTS NEEDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
PLEASE CONSIDER US THE TEN
NINETEEN AS A WAY TO ENSURE
PATIENTS LIKE SOPHIA DID NOT
SUFFER NEEDLESSLY. THANK YOU AM
VERY MUCH WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANKS VERY MUCH I
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO DO SO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF. SB TEN
NINETEEN ANSWER ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OKAY. NAME ON SOCIAL
POSITION. THANK CENTER PAN JOSE
TOWARDS WITHOUT THAT BECAUSE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MOTHER UP SIMPLY
INTERNET AFFILIATES CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MATTHEW
GALLAGHER WITH COWBOYS IS ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR THE
MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES HO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
NINETEEN. NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
. ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME A LINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NUMBER FROM FOR PROFIT CHARTER
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
THREE THIRTY SIX YOUR IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS NO I POSSIBLE.
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SUPPORT S.
B. ONE ZERO ONE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
THREE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MARIA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PARENTS I THINK
HEALTH NETWORK ON FOR DEVELOPING
STRONG WORK ETHIC THANK YOU FOR
NEXT WITNESS. TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN
THE WITH A CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY
WE ARE SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
REFLECTING BOTH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. ONE THREE SEVEN ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY CAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE THREE NINETY ONE YEAR OLD.
HELLO BARKER SAID OF ALL OF THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF LAST WEEK TONIGHT.
THANK YOU EXCELLENT. ONE THREE
NINETY. HELLO MY NAME IS RAVI
FANG AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CAMBODIAN FAMILY
COMMUNITY CENTER IN SUPPORT OF
FD TEN NINETEEN THANK YOU NINETY
SIX WITNESS. ONE THREE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE WILL BE
NO ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
FEDERATIONS INVOLVED SO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. THREE EIGHTY NINE ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON NICOLE WATERMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
EXPERTNESS. TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE
YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS TONIGHT AND REPRESENTS
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SPORTS. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. FINE THREE NINETY
NINE WE STILL HAVE. BUT SHORT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE THE
CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
THREE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI YOUR AVAILABLE WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. THANK TO THE NEXT WITNESS. ONE
ONE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRIBLE WITH
FIVE IN THE WEST BOTH THE
MANAGER FOR YOUNGER PEOPLE
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
YOUR NEXT WITNESS. FIND FOUR
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON ON YOUR MOBILE AGAIN
WOULD BLOCK WONDERFUL ON THE
ACTION PROJECT CALLING IN
SUPPORT EACH YEAR THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THIS. FIND ONE
THIRTEEN YEAR OFFICE. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BILLION
AUTO LINE YOU TWENTY TWO SO I
HAD. HALEY HARDY WITH CHILDREN
NOW ADDING OUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. TWENTY ONE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS NOT ABOUT ANYTHING FROM A
THIRD OUTWEIGHS YOU CAN BE
COMPLETELY PROFESSIONAL NETWORK
OF THE A FRIEND FROM THE- I
THINK THAT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE THREE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HE PLEADED WITH THE
FUNDING FOR INSTITUTE IN STRONG
. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
ONE FIFTIES WE STILL HAVE. WHEN
A REPORTER THE HALF THE TOWN WE
CAN ON FIFTY ISLANDER AMERICAN
AFFAIRS RIGHT RIGHT. THANK YOU
THANKS WITH THIS. ONE THREE NINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES. YES
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON HAVE YOU DONE ON
BEHALF OF INFORMALITY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION. I'M IN A STRONG. HE
WANTS THEIR OWNERS ONE NIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
FLORAL PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME. MCCARTY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE ZERO ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. TWENTY FOUR OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND THEM GET- MY NAME
DURING A LONG FROM A READ IF ANY
IN SUPPORT OF BEACON. THANK YOU
THANK NEXT WEEK. BY THREE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT AFTER HOPE
EMERGED FROM THE CAL LINE TWO
THOUSAND FAMILY CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WEEK. WHY
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS A BECAUSE BOTH NATIONAL
HEALTH LAW PROGRAM IN SUPPORT I
THINK THE NEXT WITNESS. HERE WE
HAVE NO OTHER THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU NOW LET'S LET'S
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION TO THE SP
TEN NINETEEN- THERE'S NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION LISTED FOR TESTIMONY
ARE THERE ANY- BUT THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. C. NINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHICH TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN
NINETEEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
ROAD AT THIS TIME. JUST ONE
MOMENT. CURRENTLY I FEEL BETTER
YET ALL RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH
MODERATOR BRING BACK COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SEEING
NONE. OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVE I
CENTER LEYVA SIR EDMUND- THAT
ONE THANK YOU THANK SENATORS
ALSO MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD-
PROCEDURE WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK- WE WANTED.
WE AS YOU KNOW AS A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WE DO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT CHALLENGING PEOPLE
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT THAT THE
MILD TO MODERATE TO GO TO THEIR
MEDICAL PLAN AND THEN TO BE HERE
FOR HEALTH AND WHERE THAT
BOUNDARY IS AND FRANKLY I THINK
A LOT OF TIME THEIR PHYSICIAN TO
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS ON THE
CHALLENGE AS WELL. AND I THINK
THE MINUTES TRIED ALSO TO
INCORPORATE SOME OF THE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS AS WELL SO THAT
THE PATIENTS IN THE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS. CAN BETTER DELIVER
TO CARE ESPECIALLY AS WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE IN FORGET FOR HEALTH
WORKFORCE WE NEED TO MAKE BETTER
USE OF I WOULD GUESS ARE.
UNCOMMON THAT THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE BUT- AB. PEOPLE WHO.
SO MENTAL. BUT ALSO DO OTHER
THINGS AS WELL BUT ALSO. YOU
KNOW BE SURE YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT CAPACITY AS WELL TO BE
SURE TO PROVIDE THE CARE WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ALL USE YOUR REMARKS AS MY
CLOTHES AND ASKED. ABOUT OKAY
THANK YOU- SO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
DISTANCE ACTIVATES. CENTER
LEYVA. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN BY EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ GREW. FURTADO LEYVA.
LEYVA BY LEE MON. ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO. WIENER AYE. WIENER AYE.
FIVE THE CURRENTLY HAS FIVE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF THE
FOR AT MEMBERS. LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B. TEN
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT- EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I'VE YOU'VE
ALL HEARD ME TALK ABOUT MY A
BILL PACKAGE. AND THIS IS A
ANOTHER TWO OF THOSE OF THIS
FIRST ONE IS SB TEN THIRTY FIVE-
AND DEALING WITH THE
CONTINUATION OF THE WORK ON
LAURA'S LAW WE'VE ALL BEEN A
PART OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
ME AS WE'VE CONTINUED TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THAT LAW- IN
THIS LAW. S. B. TEN THIRTY FIVE
WOULD MAKE EXPLICIT THAT SELF
ADMINISTERED MEDICATIONS CAN BE
INCLUDED IN ORDER FOR A DUTY. OR
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
WHEN THEY'RE INCLUDED AS PART OF
THE TREATMENT PLAN. I'VE BEEN
WORKING THIS LEGISLATION IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO A DUTY PROGRAMS IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE DID AB SEPT NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX WHICH REQUIRED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A. O. T.
UNLESS A COUNTY SUPPOSED TO OPT
OUT OF IT. AND AT THIS TIME
WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO REPORT
OVER THIRTY COUNTIES NOW HAVE
NOW ADOPTED THE PROGRAM.
ENSURING THAT THIS EFFECTIVE AND
SAFE COMMUNITY BASED APPROACH TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE THOSE IN- LAST
YEAR SB FIVE OH SEVEN UPDATED
THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS BY
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS EXITING
INVOLUNTARY. BENEFIT FROM THE
CONTINUED SERVICES. THAT MAKE
SENSE WHEN SOMEONE EXITED
SERVICES THAT YOU WOULD SAY- NOW
THEY'RE NOT APPROPRIATE AND.
THEN HAVE THEM SPIRAL BACK. TO
INTO A CRISIS. TODAY GONNA
INCORPORATE AT THE AMENDMENT
THAT WAS SUGGESTED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR ON MEDICATIONS- WHEN
THEY LOOKED AT ALL THIS THE
COURT THE COURT CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS COURT ORDER TREATMENT
PLANS TO INCLUDE COORDINATION
AND ACCESS TO MEDICATION BUT IT
DOESN'T EXPLICITLY SAY THAT
COULD BE PART OF YOUR TREATMENT
PLAN- TO DISCREPANCY WAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT ON THE L. P. S. ACT. IN
ACCORD TO THEIR FINDINGS THE
PREVAILING FACTOR THAT
DETERMINES WHY INDIVIDUAL CYCLE
BACK INTO MORE RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS IS NON MEDICATION
NONCOMPLIANCE- IN THE PART OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES REPORTING
ON A. O. T. IMPLEMENTATION A
NOTE THAT ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
TO ENCOURAGE AND ENSURE
TREATMENT PLANS COMPLIANCE MAY
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
INCREASE NUMBER UPDATE
MEDICATION HEARINGS MEDICATION
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE AND OR
ASSESSMENT FOR POTENTIAL
HOSPITALIZATIONS. WE KNOW THAT
MEDICATION HAS BEEN PRESCRIBED
IN THESE PROGRAMS AND THAT IT
HEARINGS IS AN ESSENTIAL TOOL
THAT ALLOWS AN INDIVIDUALLY TO
STAY SAFELY IN THEIR COMMUNITY
AND AGAIN SOMETHING YOU CAN
CHECK THE PERSON COMES BACK TO
BEGINNING TO EXHIBIT SYMPTOMS
YOU CAN SAY HAVE YOU BEEN TAKING
YOUR MDICATION AS A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP PEOPLE ON TRACK AND
AGAIN NOT TO CYCLE BACK INTO
CRISIS- SO THIS AGAIN WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PART OF KEEPING
PEOPLE IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
LEVEL OF CARE- AND WITH ME
TODAY- OR PEOPLE TO TESTIFY IS
THE HONORABLE THOMAS ANDERSON
JUDGE IN NEVADA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT. AND DR ALEXIS T. AN
ASSISTANT CLINICAL PROFESSOR IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PSYCHIATRY AND
HUMAN BEHAVIOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN AND JUST TO CLARIFY YOU
MIGHT AGREE SENATE BUT- YOU'RE
TAKING YES AT TECHNICAL MEN AND
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO LET'S
NOW HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- AND I THINK THEY BOTH
ON BY PHONE- SO FIRST OR START
WITH THE HONORABLE TIME
ANDERSON. JUDGE AND THEN ABOUT A
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND THEN WILL FOLLOW
BY DOCTOR LIKES TO SEE AND- WITH
THAT UC IRVINE AND TO A- FORM.
INTO THE FUSELAGE BEGIN WITH THE
AUDIBLE TOM ANDERSON. THANK YOU
NEVADA COUNTY. HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED MOORE'S LAW HEARING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
SIMPLY SHIP THE VERY FIRST
ORDER. WHEN THE OLD LOW PETITION
THE COURT HAS ORDERED COMPLIANCE
TO TREATMENT PLANTS. OKAY IN
ORDER TAKE MEDICATIONS
PRESCRIBED IN MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS REPURPOSE DR THIS
IS IN ADDITION TO HOLDING STATUS
CONFERENCE IS GETTING A
PARTICIPANT FROM A CHURCH EVERY
TWO WEEKS OR SOONER IS NEEDED
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
PARTICIPANT. AND IT'S A SMALL TO
SUPERVISION THE CREATURES
SUCCESS OUR SUCCESS NEVADA
COUNTY THE STUDIO OR HELPING
IMPLORES LAW PROGRAM. WHICH HAS
A BODY THAT MANY PARTNERS. YOU
COMPORTS WITH SUCCESS AND OTHERS
YOU CAN THE RUNNER PER THE STATE
. THE EIGHTY MILE. ASIAN
COMPLIANCES OF THE MOST ASPECTS
WERE CORNERSTONES OF ANY
TREATMENT PLAN. WHICH CRITICAL
BUILDING THE PERSON GETS
STABILITY. MEDICATION ALONG WITH
SAFE HOUSING IMPROVE THE PUBLIC
BOXES SUCCESS AT EVERY COURT
APPEARANCE WE ADDRESS MEDICATION
COMPLIANCE HOUSING THROUGH THE
SOCIAL ACTIVITIES. PORTUGUESE
MANAGERS DELIVER MEDICATIONS
DAILY TO SOME PARTICIPANTS THE
REPORTS HELP TO ENSURE THEIR
COMPLIANCE IN THE CASE MANAGERS
CHECKING WITH THE PARTICIPANTS
MULTIPLE TIMES A WEEK TO ACCEPT
. THE SISTER CONTINUED
COMPLIANCE THROUGH THE PERSON
COMES TO COURT THE JUDGE HAS AN
AWARENESS OF WHAT ISSUES
INCLUDING MEDICATION COMPLIANCE-
OF CONCERN TO THE TREATMENT
PROVIDER TO THE PARTICIPANTS.
HAVING A PARTICIPANT IN FRONT OF
A JUDGE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO THE SUCCESS OF THE TREATMENT
PLAN. THAT PROVIDES NOT. JUST
SUPERVISION OF BOTH THE
PARTICIPANT AND PROVIDER AND
ALSO RESEARCHERS A PARTICIPANT
OF THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED JUST.
FOR STEP GIVES A MARKET TO VOICE
CONCERNS. I THINK THE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS SET. OF FOCUS NOT ON ON
THE TRUTH. WITH MEDIC. AND OTHER
INDIVIDUAL FACTORS OF INTEREST.
THE NEED TO STAY AWARE OF THE
PATIENTS PARTICIPANTS PROGRESS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ALSO
ONLINE PETITION OF ANY QUESTIONS
OF. PUBLIC PROGRAM WORKS IN
PRACTICE. IT'S SO MUCH JUDGE
ANDERSON- NOW LET'S BRING ON A
DOCTOR LIKE SISSY AND- FIFTEEN
MINUTES HI. I THANK YOU HAVE A%
PEN AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY DR ALEXIS EGAN AND
AS YOU MENTIONED I'M- A CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE. EARLY FOR.
YOUR YOUR MENTAL ILLNESS OF AP
AND HOW SETTINGS I'M SPEAKING TO
ON BEHALF OF THE COW STATE IS HI
. THE BIG THIRTY EIGHT AND
MAYORS COALITION IS STATUS AS
PSYCHIATRY THANK IN. ALLIANCE
HEALTH ALL WHO OPPOSE WITH THE
FELT THAT THE TWELVE OTHER
SUPPORTERS. AVAIL FACTOR THAT
DETERMINED WHY IN CYCLE BACK TO
DIVERSE SETTINGS IS NOT
NONADHERENCE. THE CALIFORNIA
WATERS FURTHER DETER THE TWELVE
OTHERS IN POOR ORDERED BY ALFIE
SHE TREATMENT PLANT. FIND THE
SENATE PLAN DETAILS AND MYSTERY
PRACTICES. EXPLICITLY ALLOWING
COURT ORDERED MEDICATIONS TO BE
IN CORPORATE INTO A O. T. PLAN
IF YOU'D PREFER AT PRESERVING
OUR INDIVIDUALS WITH WITH
PSYCHIATRIC ILLNESS INSTABILITY
AND DECREASING THE RISK OF
REPEATED HOSPITALIZATION OR
RAPIDLY PERSPIRATION. WE KNOW
THAT HE HAS LONG BEEN AN
EFFECTIVE THOUGH PROP POSSIBLY
UNDER UTILIZED TOOL FOR
PROVIDING APPROPRIATE INTENSIVE
TREATMENT CALIFORNIANS. OFF I
YOUR FUNDING FOR CONTACT WITH
LAW PERSON DUE TO THEIR SERVICE
ILLNESS. IT'S REALLY A THAT
THERE'S NO AND ON THE BILL TO
RECALL BACK IF ORDER PLAN.
DEVELOPED A TREATMENT PLAN
INCLUDING. FOR INTO A DIVISION
STUFF FOR FROM CITY MENTAL IS
TRUE THE EXCITING THE MONTH
FAILURE. ALONG WE KNOW
MEDICATION IS. A CURE ALL FOR
PEOPLE WITH. CONDITION AND THE
MANY FACES OUR COMMUNITY THERE
HE CAN. OF LONG TERM RECOVERY.
THANK YOU. THIRTY VERY MUCH-
WILL NOW HEAR FROM ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
THIRTY FIVE WILL BEGIN HERE ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WELCOME THANK
YOU ASSURE MEMBERS TRUST BUCKLEY
ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO DALE
STAMBERG IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEE NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING A
MIKE FROM ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
THIRTY FIVE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITIONALLY. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS. ONE EIGHT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FIRST LINE IS FOUR OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS KILEY
SHALL BE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF
AND THE BIG CITY BEARD COALITION
FOR CROWDS ON. ORDER IF THAT
ORDER EVEN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE PACKAGE INCLUDING SENATE
BILL TEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS FOR THIS.
THANKS LINE IS FORTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE TALK ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO MERRICK TODD
GLORIA IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE MISTY
JOHN MARK MARK CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIAN THE
LINE CALIFORNIA I WOULD PROBABLY
BE A CO SPONSOR AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
LINE IS Q. NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS DANGER AND HOW
TO BE WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SURE CARE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER HERE. THANKS VERY MUCH
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FOR SB EN THIRTY
FIVE- SO WE DO HAVE TESTIMONY
FROM- MAN GALLAGHER FROM CAL
VOICES- I BELIEVE ON THE PHONE
SO. IF YOU'RE HERE OKAY
EXCELLENT- TO BE FAIR YOU CAN
YOU YOU CAN'T HAVE FOUR MINUTES
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION GOT FOUR
MINUTES SO THA YOU DON'T USE
ALL OF IT YOU DON'T NEED TO BUT-
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF-
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS. MAC
GALLAGHER- PERSON FOREMOST I DO
WANNA THANK CENTER I MEAN FOR
AMENDMENTS- THE SELF
ADMINISTERED AMENDMENT TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAWS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND IT DOES
ELIMINATE. SOME OF OUR
OPPOSITION UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL
OF IT- AND THAT'S FOR SEVERAL
REASONS FIRST WE DO HAVE A FILL
. DIFFERENCE ON FORSTER COURSE
MEDICATION AN OUTPATIENT
SETTINGS. ALL RECENT INDIVIDUALS
IN AN OUTPATIENT SETTING THIS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE. CAPACITY TO
MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR BODIES. ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS OR MEDICATIONS WITH
BLACK BOX LABELS. THAT HAVE SIDE
EFFECTS. OTHER UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND SOMETIMES
INDIVIDUALS DON'T TAKE
MEDICATION SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
MISCOMMUNICATION WITH THEIR
PSYCHIATRIST THE PRESCRIBING
PHYSICIAN. OR VARIOUS OTHER
REASONS- ANOTHER CONCERN WE HAVE
WITH THIS BILL IS THE LACK OF A
CLEAR FORTUNATE MECHANISM. WHEN
THE STATE AUDITOR ISSUED ITS
REPORT AND MADE THIS
RECOMMENDATION THE AUDITORS
SUGGESTED ALSO HAVE A CLEAR
PORCELAIN MECHANISM FOR
INDIVIDUALS TAKING OR- BE
REQUIRED TO TAKE THESE
MEDICATIONS. SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS REQUIRED TO SELF
EMISSIONS MANY MEDICATION AND
CHOSE NOT TO DO SO. WITH A FACE
ADDITIONAL COURT HEARINGS WHAT
INDIVIDUAL SHOW UP TO THEIR
HOUSE AND ASK THEM IF THEY'RE
TAKING MEDICATION. WHAT EXACTLY
WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE. THE BILL
AS IT'S TODAY. WOULD SEEM TO
SUGGEST THAT SINCE IT'S PART OF
THE TREATMENT PLAN AN INDIVIDUAL
WOULD BE. OUT OF THE ACCORD WITH
THEIR TREATMENT AND THEN WOULD
BE SUBJECT POTENTIALLY TO A
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES OR VARIOUS
OTHER PROVISIONS WHERE. THEY
COULD BE COMBINED WITH THEIR
TREATMENT PLAN THEY COULD BE
GOING TO OTHER MEETINGS THAT
COULD BE CHECKING IN THE COULD
BE RECEIVING SERVICES BUT
MEDICATION MAC MIGHT JUST BE THE
ONLY ISSUE. AND SO I BRING THOSE
CONCERNS TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
CENTER EGGMAN ON THIS AND-
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE- ARE STILL
IN OFFICE. OPPOSITION THANK YOU
CARD THANK YOU. NO ONE ELSE TAKE
ON ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SAYING NONE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB TEN THIRTY
FIVE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITIONALLY. HE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST
LINE IS NINETY RIGHT. AS A POINT
OF VIEW- SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LAKE DAYLIGHT IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. EXLINE IS ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHITE ONE
THIRTY YEARS LATER IS OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME ME YES PLEASE THE
NAME MORE EFFICIENT POSITION.
YES MY NAME IS KATIE. AND I AM A
STRONG OPPOSITION IS ITSELF
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THE
POINT IS TO NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLYN
RUBIO I AM A FORMER- PATIENT. OF
MENTAL HEALTH YOU HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY GOTTEN OFF OF
MEDICATIONS AGAINST MEDICAL
ADVICE SO I WRONGLY OPPOSED TO
STOP THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. MR
HERE WE HAVE NO FURTHER IF YOU
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR BRING BACK MANY MANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER ROCK THAT
SEEN OTHER COMMENTS- CENTER EVEN
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I KNOW IT'S A- WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION- SOME
CHALLENGES BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GET OUT.
OF THE SYSTEM FOR NO PATIENT
TREATMENT- WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND YES WE
JUST HAVE SOME PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCES. AND- AND THAT'S
OKAY RIGHT THAT THAT THAT IS
OKAY. AND I THINK THE JUDGE
NORTH LAID OUT WHAT COMPLIANCE
LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT NON
COMPLIANCE LOOKS LIKE VERY
CLEARLY I DON'T I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY MEMBERS WANTED TWENTY HERE
AND GO THROUGH IT AGAIN- BUT WE
CERTAINLY CAN AND I WILL JUST
POINT OUT. IN IN IN CLOSING-
NEVADA COUNTY WAS WHERE THIS
BEGAN BOLLORE'S LAW BEGAN
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE LAURA
WILCOX WAS SHOT AND KILLED. BY
SOMEBODY WHO WAS WAS NON
COMPLIANT. AND HOW WE'VE BEEN
ADOPTED A. O. T. AND JUST SAY
YES WELL SOMEBODY. IS NOT UNDER
THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY THE THEY
HAVE BEEN DEEMED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS. SUN
COMMITTEE CRIME IN THE GO TO
JAIL WHICH IS. OUR LARGEST
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY RIGHT
NOW- THEY LOSE THAT RIGHT RIGHT
AWAY. SO WE HAVE A PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCE I THINK WE SHOULD
TREAT PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY-
AT THE LOWEST LEVEL POSSIBLE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. I THINK IF I COULD JUST AS
YOU WERE SAYING. THIS IS TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE YOU HEARD SOME
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY DOING IT
MARIN COUNTY ALREADY DOING A LOT
OF COUNTIES ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS. VERY SUCCESSFULLY THIS IS
A CLEAR FIGHT FOR THE COUNTIES
WHO HAVE BEEN. MORE HESITANT
THIS IS PART IS BEFORE THE
TREATMENT ORDER. OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SINCE
SECOND BY CENTER ROCK. CONTROL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HANDS HIM
FIND MELINDA'S EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
I GONZALEZ GROVE HER TADO LEYVA
HI LEYVA AYE LEE MON THE MOON I
ROTH AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO WIENER
OKAY THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS FIVE
LITTLE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN THE SECOND BILL
AND PRESENTED TODAY AS PART OF
THE R. EIGHT BILL PACKAGE SB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
PROVIDE ONE ADDITIONAL THIRTY
DAY PERIOD OF INTENSIVE
TREATMENT AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCEEDINGS IF A
PERSON CURRENTLY CURRENTLY
RECEIVING CARE IS LIKELY TO
RECOVER WITH IT JUST A LITTLE
MORE TREATMENT AND
STABILIZATION- WHEN REALIZE
RIGHT NOW SOMEONE GOES IN YOUR
DEEMED A DANGER PUT OFF FIFTY TO
FIFTY HOLD. THEY CAN BE
CERTIFIED FOR MORE INTENSIVE
TREATMENT GENTLY THREE DAYS IS
NOT WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO
STABILIZE SOMEBODY WHO'S IN A
HUGE PSYCHOTIC- HAVING AN
EPISODE SO THAT THEY CAN BE
TREATED. FOR AN ADDITIONAL
FOURTEEN DAYS. AFTER IF A PERSON
FOUND TO REMAIN GREATLY DISABLED
UNWILLING TO ACCEPT VOLUNTARY
TREATMENT AT THAT POINT THE
PERSON MAY BE CERTIFIED FOR
ADDITIONAL PERIOD OF NOT MORE
THAN. THIRTY DAYS OF INTENSIVE
TREATMENT. DURING THOSE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS WE HAD BEFORE.
AGAIN AS A WAY TO KEEP FROM
MOVING ON TO THE CONSERVATIVE
PROCESS. AND THIS THAN WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW IS LET'S GIVE
ANOTHER ADDITIONAL THIRTY DAYS.
AS A AS A POSSIBILITY IF IT
LOOKS LIKE SOMEBODY WILL RECOVER
ENOUGH AGAIN TO MOVE TO A LOWER
LEVEL OF CARE AND NOT INTO A
CONSERVATORSHIP. PROCEEDING TO
THE THIRTY DAY INTENSIVE
TREATMENT IS ONLY AN OPTION AND
COUNTIES THAT HAVE ADOPTED A
RESOLUTION AUTHORIZING IT. AT
THIS TIME TWENTY THREE COUNTY
HAVE IMPLEMENTED THIS OPTIONS
AGAIN AS A WAY TO SAY YOU CAN'T
DO THIS WE KNOW SOME ARE DOING
IT SOME ARE NOT. THIS IS TO MAKE
MORE STANDARDIZATION ACROSS OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM- IN WITH ME TODAY
IS- DOCTOR SAGAN AND RANDALL
HAGAR ON BEHALF OF THIS
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- AND CEDAR BOTH BY PHONE
RIGHT US SO THAT'S A- MODERATE
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE RANDALL
HAGAR FROM THE PSYCHIATRIC AND
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YOU HAVE THE TWO
MINUTES THE TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
AND THEN FOLLOWED- AGAIN BY DR
ALEXIS SEGAN- FROM UC IRVINE-
SO- RANDALL HAGAR. DR PAN THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL
BAKER I REPRESENT THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA. ONE THING- CENTER
EGGMAN FOR OBVIOUS LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THIS BILL AS WELL AS
THOSE IN THE- TOP PACKAGE OF
EIGHT BILLS THAT ARE EIGHT
THAT'LL HELP REFORM PACKAGE.
WHICH PSYCHIATRIC ALLIANCES WITH
A SPONSORED BY TWELVE. TWENTY
SEVEN IS AT THE END OF THE DAY
ABOUT PROVIDING THE RIGHT CARE
AT THE RIGHT TIME TO SEVERELY
ILL AND DISABLED INDIVIDUALS.
ALSO AWAY ABOUT CONSERVATORSHIP
IN THE SENSE THAT FROM TWENTY
SEVEN HELPS US TO AVOID
CONSUMERS SHE SHIPS. WHAT IT
TAKES TO DO SO CONSERVATORSHIP
SAGER INTRUSIVE INVENTORY-
RESTRICTIVE OF INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTY AND O WHEN WE CAN
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE
LESS RESTRICTION WE SHOULD DO SO
IN THIS TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
DOLLARS. I WILL SAY JUST IN
SUPPORT OF- THOSE POINTS THAT WE
CAN'T RUSH RECOVERY. RECOVERY
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS OFTEN PROCEEDS AT
ITS OWN PACE- SO IN THIS
INPATIENT SETTING WOULD BE SOLD
TOO MANY OF OUR PATIENTS SO THEY
ARE SICKER THAN. DECADES PAST.
ON THE SYSTEM LEFT. FOR A LONG
THERE ARE PROBLEMS. BUT BASS USE
COULD BE HEALTH ISSUES. THEY
PERCENT MORE COMPLEX- IN- TO A
GENERATION AGO. AND SO WE NEED
MORE TO READ THESE ISSUES FOR
THE PATIENTS AND FINING RIGHT
MEDICAID TO UNDER THESE
CONDITIONS CAN BE A LENGTHY
PROCESS AND ALL THAT COULD TAKE
TIME SO SB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
HELPS US. WITH A FEW PATIENTS
ARE NOT QUITE THERE YET WHICH
MEANS THEY MAKE PROGRESS THEY
LIKELY WON'T NEED A
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT THEY NEED
MORE TIME TO RECOVER. AND GET
TREATMENT SO THEY CAN BE
DISCHARGED SAFELY IF IT TURNS
OUT THAT THEY NEED TO BE
REFERRED TO A CONSERVATORSHIP SB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN PROVIDES.
THAT TO- SB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
PER SERVICE YOU PROCESS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND EARLY HOLDS
AND ON BEHALF PSYCHIATRIC
CONDITIONS. APPLY INSPIRED
SUPPORT. THANKS NOW SPRING ON
DOCTORAL C. FROM THE FIRST FIFTY
C. IRVINE. HI OKAY THANK YOU-
CHAIRMAN AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SO I'VE BEEN AS
YOU MENTIONED DR LAXITY CAN I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS. SB TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT
PROMISES TO BOTH IMPROVE
TREATMENT OUTCOMES AND DECREASED
SERVICE COSTS FOR ALL PATIENTS
WITH A SEVERE MENTALITY IF
THEY'RE CONCERNED OR NOT
CONCERNED. TO WIN AN INDIVIDUAL
HOSPITALIZED WE HAVE TO MAKE THE
DECISION REGARDING
CONSERVATORSHIP EARLY ON WITHIN
THE FIRST. TWO WEEKS PERCENT
HOSPITALIZATION. LIFE APPOINTED
THAT APPLE. IN ORDER HELP THE
PERMIT THE PUBLIC GUARDIAN
SUFFICIENT TIME FOR THE
INVESTIGATION AND THAT'S OFTEN
THE FOR TREATMENT THAT REALLY
HAD A SUFFICIENT TIME TO TAKE A
FACT. IT BILITY UTILIZED SECOND
THIRTY DAY HOLD WOULD SPARE FOR
CONSERVATORSHIP THOSE PEOPLE
WHOSE NEEDS ARE MORE
SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESSED THROUGH
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR INTENSIVE
INPATIENT THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION. AT THE SAME TIME
SB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN HAS.
OTHER IMPORTANT IMPLICATIONS FOR
THOSE WHO REALLY DO NEED
CONSERVATORSHIP AND IT GREATLY
IMPROVES THEIR ACCESS TO
NECESSARY CONSERVATIVE A
CONSERVATIVE RELATED SERVICES IN
TWO WAYS. FIRST BY LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF PATIENTS UNNECESSARILY
REFERRED FOR CONSERVATORSHIP IT
FREES UP THE SECOND HALF OF THE
FOR SERVICE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CLEARLY REQUIRE COURT EVALUATION
POTENTIAL PATIENTS THE
PLACEMENT. BECAUSE OF THE OFTEN
UNMET DEMAND FOR CONTROVERSIAL
RELATED SERVICES THE PLACEMENT-
INDIVIDUALS WHO REQUIRE THE
SERVICES ARE TOO OFTEN.
NECESSARILY DESTRUCTION HOSPITAL
CARE BEFORE THE SERVICES CAN BE
PROVIDED IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH
LPS CODE. AND AFTER DISCHARGE
THEIR EXPOSED AND VULNERABLE
IT'S. DANGER FAILURE AND
READMISSION. SECONDLY UNLESS
HIGH BURDEN PLACE RESOURCE FOR
NEW CONCERT PEOPLE MAY PEOPLE
WHO REQUIRE BECAUSE- TOO OFTEN
IN THE HIGH. AT ALL AND IT. DATE
FOR WEEKS MONTHS AND SOMEHOW
HE'S UP TO IT- OVER A YEAR WELL
WE THERE'S OPENINGS HOSPITALS-
AYE INDEED. THE SITUATION NOT
ONLY ANTI THERAPEUTIC AND A
DELAY OF TRANSFER TO LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING IT ALSO
BURNS HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS AND
HOSPITALS FOR PROVIDING
ADMITTEDLY NON MEDICALLY
NECESSARY INPATIENT SERVICES.
WHICH ARE OFTEN NOT REIMBURSABLE
THREE EITHER PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
INSURANCE SO IN ESSENCE.
DISABILITIES RAPIDLY. IMPROVED
OKAY. POLITY OF- QUALITY FOR
CONSERVATIVE AND CONSERVATIVE.
WHO EXISTING RESOURCES MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND AVOID POTENTIAL-
REIMBURSABLE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
DECEMBER IN SUPPORT I THANK YOU
. SEEN ON ELSE APPROACHING
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS A PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST CALL IS
FROM THE LINE FOR SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANKS FOR YOUR MIND
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS WHERE IT POPPED ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO MAYOR TODD
GLORIA AND THE CITY COUNCIL OF
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. SIX
POINT DROP FROM ONE FOUR
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS CRUCIAL
THE ONCE AGAIN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF
AND THE SIXTY YEAR COALITION
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. EXPLAIN FROM THREE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS AREA
APPLE WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THIS IS YOUR CARE AT THIS TIME
NO FURTHER ISSUE. THANK YOU-
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN- AND I BELIEVE ON THE
PHONE LINE WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU YOU ACTUALLY
TO BE FAIR YOU ACTUALLY CAN HAVE
UP TO FOUR MINUTES ALTHOUGH
AGAIN IF YOU DON'T NEED TO USE
ALL FOUR MINUTES THAT'S FINE TOO
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
PAN- UNFORTUNATELY DEBRA
FACILITY RIGHT CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY WE THINK THAT
STILL GOES IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. ONE OF THEIR PRIMARY
PURPOSES OF THE LPS PACKAGE TO
EXPAND INAPPROPRIATE INDEFINITE
AN INVOLUNTARY COMMITMENT. WE
THINK RESOURCES SHOULD BE
DEVOTED TO HELPING PEOPLE. GET
OUT OF IN PATIENT CARE OUT OF
LOCKSTEP CARE. AND INTO
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT.
ANALYSIS NOTES A CONCERN ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WOULD BE
ENOUGH AND- AND IN ADDITION. I
BELIEVE THAT WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE THE DATA TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSITION THAT- THIS IS GOING
TO RESULT IN GREATER SUCCESS.
AND LOWER COSTS- THERE FOR WE
SHOULD IN THE BASED CARE I'M
FORTUNATE MOST CLOSER THANK VERY
MUCH. THANKS FOR MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES AND- HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. SORT
COMMENTS BY. MATTHEW GALLAGHER-
CAL VOICES WE ECHO THE CONCERNS
OF THE RC THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SAN OTHER WITNESSES SAID HERE
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
HERE WE HAVE NOBODY HE LAID OUT
HI THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
RETURN MOVE BY SERRA SEEN NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ASSER
EGGMAN- YOU KNOW WHAT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AGAIN ONE OF THESE BILLS FOR
YOUR NAVIGATING- AND CERTAINLY-
UNDERSTAND- SO THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION BUT- I.
THINK WE'LL BE FOR LEARNED- AT
LEAST WHAT'S RECENT EVENTS-
CONSERVATORSHIP IS NOT ALWAYS
THE RIGHT ANSWER EITHER AND-
HAVING AN OPTION TO ALLOW SO ONE
MORE TIME FOR RECOVERY WITHOUT
HAVING TO END OF THE
CONSERVATORSHIP. DESPITE GOING
TO BE BENEFICIAL THE END AND-
SO- CERTAINLY- AND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
WE WOULD AGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE WOULD AGREE THAT
WE WOULD SAY COMMUNITY CARE IS
THE BEST BUT WHEN THAT DOESN'T
WORK WE NEED OTHER OPTIONS IT.
IS THIS TRUE- FIFTY YEARS AGO
FORTY AGO WITH. A LAW AND IF
WITH LOOKING HONEST. THAT'S
OKAY- THEN I GUESS YOU KNOW WE
CONTINUE ON AS AS WE HAVE BEEN I
DON'T THINK THAT'S OKAY AND I
DON'T THINK. MANY PEOPLE SITTING
UP HERE TODAY THINK WHAT WE
CURRENTLY. HAVE IS OKAY- WE HAVE
PUT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO OUR
SYSTEM THE LAST COUPLE YEARS TO.
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
PROVIDING CARE TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THOSE THINGS. BUT
WE ALSO NEED TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
RETURN PEOPLE SAFELY TO THE
COMMUNITY- AND JUST. AS AN ASIDE
I WAS DISCUSSING MOST OF MY
FORMER COLLEAGUES WHO ARE STILL
ACTIVELY WORKING IN THE FIELD
ABOUT THIS. AND MY ONE COLLEAGUE
SAID THANK GOD YOU CAN'T IMAGINE
HOW MANY CRADLE BEDS WE HAVE TO
HAVE AN R. ET SHE'S WORKS IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM. HEARD IN AND TO
ALSO WAS A CREDIBLE AND SHE'S
LIKE WELL YOU KNOW YOU DON'T
WANT TO. RESTRAIN PEOPLE ANYMORE
BUT WHEN PEOPLE COME IN A
PSYCHOTIC STATE. YOU HAVE TO
KEEP THEM SAFE AND EVERYBODY
ELSE SAVE SO CRADLE BED NOW. IS
A BET THAT SOMEONE OF THE CRADLE
MESH ALL AROUND IT. CAMPUS OVER
THE TOP- AND MESS AROUND THE-
THE DOT SHARP CORNERS. FOR
SOMEONE TO STAY IN AN EMERGENCY
ROOM WHILE PEOPLE DESPERATELY
TRIED TO FIND. THEM CARE. OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY SO WHAT WE HAVE IS
NOT WORKING MY FRIENDS. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN SO
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
AND SECONDED BY CENTER ROTH.
THAT COULD SOMEONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ GROVE HER TADO LEYVA.
LEYVA HIGHLY MON HI FI MON I
ROTH. ROTH AYE RUBIO. WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE. THIS SIX THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS SIX VOTES- THERE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ALL RIGHT- SO
JUST A GENERAL ANNOUNCEMENT TO
ALL THOSE WATCHING- FROM OUR
MEMBERS OFFICES- WE ARE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS WE HAVE- CENTER
CAPPIELLO- AND I THINK CENTER
SKINNER IS GONNA BE JOINING WITH
HER AND SURE SHE IS. AND THEN
ALSO- SO SINCE I GOT HERE THIS
YEAR AND THEN FALLING WOULD BE
CENTER COME OSCAR CENTER FACTORS
CENTER GLAZER AND ARE WE
SUPPOSED ALSO WEEK FOR CENTER
SKINNER TO ARE YOU GOING TO
START ON YOUR OF. SECOND OKAY
I'LL- IT WILL FROM. ALSO OKAY
CAN I ADD ON. A MISERABLE PLANT
YES AT SEA- ALL RIGHT WE'LL
WE'LL GO AND UP AND RUNNING S.
BEING ATTENDING. YEAH OKAY SO WE
GONNA LIFT BECAUSE ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB. TEN NINETEEN A
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS. MELINDA'S
GONZALEZ GROVE FURTADO LIMON
LIMON HI RUBIO. OKAY THAT BILLS
CURRENTLY SIX ZERO ALL RIGHT-
OKAY SO WE'LL WAIT A FEW MINUTES
FOR CENTER SKINNER GIVE HER A
CHANCE TO GET OVER HERE
-
OKAY SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE CENTRAL WE ONLY HAVE
ONE ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER FIVE- S. B.
TEN TWENTY THREE BY CENTER HER
TADO IS OUR MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY I THINK I
PERSONALLY A FIRST SORRY THIS
YEAR GOT FASTER- SO- YOU CAN
SOME PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR
CONSENT CALENDAR. PAN HI CAN I
MELENDEZ EGGMAN EGGMAN I CAN
SALAS GROVE FURTADO LEYVA LEYVA
HIGHLY MON HI. LIMON I ROTH ROTH
AYE RUBIO WIENER. WIENER HI THIS
IS CERTIFIED YET THAT JUST NINE
FIVE THAT'S THE ONLY ITEM ON
SECOND OKAY SO THAT'S CURRENTLY
SIX ZERO AND TO HOLD ROLE OPEN
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY
AND THEN THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS HERE YES. OKAY THE ONLY
ONE MOMENT HERE AND THEN WE'LL
GO AHEAD BEGIN AND END OF CENTER
SKINNER STATUS HEARING THIS WEEK
WE WILL BE BEGINNING VERY
SHORTLY.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
OF ALL EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT WELL
GOOD EXCELLENT SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AND BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO. MICHAEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO A BILL THAT WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS TO SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE SEEKING AN
ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA BARRIERS
TO ABORTION STILL EXISTS EVEN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
WHO SEEK ABORTION RELATED
REPRODUCTIVE CARE ARE IN A
VULNERABLE PLACE BURKE
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE OF THE
OBSTACLES THEY FACE SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION LODGING WAIT
SUPPORT SICK LEAVE WHICH AND
CHILD CARE FOR WOMEN OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA SEEKING AN ABORTION
THESE BARRIERS INCREASE
EXPONENTIALLY. THIS YEAR THE US
SUPREME COURT IS REVIEWING A
DIRECT CHALLENGE TO ROE V. WADE
SHOULD THE COURT OVERTURNED A
LONG STANDING LEGAL PROTECTIONS
FOR ABORTION SERVICES. ACTED
UNDER THIS MONUMENTAL DECISION
TWENTY SIX EIGHT STATES ARE
CERTAIN OR LIKELY TO GAIN TO BAN
ABORTIONS IMPACTING AS MANY AS
THIRTY SIX MILLION WOMEN. AND
PEOPLE WHO MAY BE BECOME
PREGNANT ACCORDING TO A RECENT
GOOD MOTT MARKER INSTITUTE
REPORT CALIFORNIA MAY SEE THREE
A 3000% INCREASE IN PEOPLE
DRIVING TO CALIFORNIA FOR
ABORTION CARE IF A TOTAL BAN
WOULD IT TAKE PLACE IN THE
UNITED STATES. IF THIS IS THE
CASE PATIENTS WON'T NEED ACCESS
TO TRANSPORTATION LODGING AND
CHILDCARE ABORTION PROVIDERS CAN
EXPECT TO SEE A RISE IN DEMAND
AND IN OVERALL OVERALL WORKLOAD.
SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS TO DIRECT AND PRACTICAL
SUPPORT FOR ABORTION PATIENTS
DIRECT SUPPORT SUCH AS RIGHTS TO
HEALTH CARE FACILITY IS
SOMETIMES A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SEEKING CARE. AND NOT FOR
DECADES ABORTION FUNDS LIKE
ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
INDEPENDENTLY FUNDRAISE TO
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY SUPPORT
CALLERS AND PATIENTS WITH THESE
NEEDS. SOME WASHING CLINICS ALSO
SISTER PATIENTS WITH PRACTICAL
SUPPORT NEEDS TO GET TO THEIR
APPOINTMENTS YET MANY UNMET NEED
HOWEVER IS FAR GREATER THAN THAT
RESOURCES CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
SB ELEVEN FORTY THREE FORTY TWO
WHAT CREATE A LANDING PAGE OF
CENTRALIZED INFORMATION FOR
WOMEN SEEKING CARE IN CALIFORNIA
THIS WILL BOTH COME BACK
MISINFORMATION AND PROVIDE
PATIENT ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED. TO ACCESS ALL KINDS
OF REPRODUCTIVE CARE THE SITE
WILL INCLUDE COMPREHENSIVE AND
MEDICALLY ACCURATE INFORMATION.
ABOUT ABORTION PROVIDERS
PROCEDURAL SUPPORT OPTIONS
INFORMATION ON THE TYPES OF
SERVICES AVAILABLE INSURANCE
INFORMATION ALONG WITH LANGUAGE
SUPPORT SERVICES. THE STATES OF
WASHINGTON AND NEW YORK ALREADY
HAVE CREATED LANDING PAGES TO
DIRECT INFILL INDIVIDUALS TO
LINKS FOR ABORTION CARE POST
OPERATION RESOURCES. AT FUNDS
AND MORE THE GOAL IS TO
STRENGTHEN PRACTICAL SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE BY PROVIDING ONE
POINT OF ENTRY TO CONNECT A
PATIENT WITH THE NEW ARRESTER
MOST ACCESSIBLE. PROVIDER OBTAIN
HEALTH COVERAGE OR FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR THE CARE AND OBTAIN
ASSISTANCE RULED A LOGISTICAL
NEEDS. AS A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
STATE CALIFORNIA MUST BE
PREPARED TO TREAT PATIENTS WHO
ARE SEEKING KERR IN THE STATE
NAVIGATE THEM TO THE BEST CARE
POSSIBLE. SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO IS
JUST ONE OF MANY STEPS TO STATE
CAN TAKE TO HELP ACHIEVE THIS
GOAL THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. UP WITH ME TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY IN SUPPORT-
ABBY- POUND LOCATION ADVOCATE
AND SOCHI LOPEZ AYALA. UP POLICY
ADVOCATE COORDINATOR WITH ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND- I HAVE
CENTERS SKINNER HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS AS WELL
TRANCERS COUNTER. YOU'RE GOING.
THANK YOU- MISTER CARE AND-
MEMBERS ARE VERY PLEASED TO JOIN
MY CO AUTHOR SENATOR KABIR AND
PRESENTING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL- PRIOR TO ROE VERSUS WADE
THE SUPREME COURT'S RULING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. THEIR ONE
POINT TWO MILLION ILLEGAL
ABORTIONS EVERY YEAR NOW AT THAT
TIME THE U. S. POPULATION WAS A
GREAT DEAL SMALLER. THAN IT IS
TODAY CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE IS
ONLY AROUND TWENTY MILLION
PEOPLE AT THAT TIME. AND DURING
THAT PERIOD OF ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ILLEGAL ABORTIONS EVERY
YEAR. THOSE UNSAFE ABORTIONS
CAUSED AS MANY AS FIVE THOUSAND
ANNUAL DEATHS SO YOU COULD
IMAGINE WHAT WE WOULD FACE
TODAY. THE NUMBER OF DEATHS WE
FACE TODAY IF. THAT RIGHT IS
DENIED. OSMOSIS STATES OF US.
NOW IN OUR OWN STATE CALIFORNIA
WELL WE HAVE GOOD ACCESS. WE'RE
HUGE STATE AND MANY OF US HAVE
DISTRICTS IN MY COLLEAGUES
MIGHT- CO AUTHORS DEFINITELY ONE
THE GEOGRAPHICALLY VERY LARGE.
BEYOND WHERE THE PERSON WHO
NEEDS THE SERVICES WHILE WE HAVE
GREAT ACCESS IT COULD BE VERY
FAR AWAY IT COULD BE MORE THAN A
DAY'S TRAVEL AND SO THE TYPE OF.
BY CREATING ESTABLISHING A FUND
LIKE THIS BILL WOULD DO THEY
WOULD PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR ANY
PERSON WHO NEEDS THIS HELP
WHETHER THEY ARE COMING FROM
ELSEWHERE OR WHETHER THEY ARE IN
OUR OWN STATE- WHAT SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO DOES IS SENDS A CLEAR
MESSAGE. THAT CALIFORNIA CANNON
WILL ACT TO PROTECT A PERSON'S
RIGHT TO ALL REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES INCLUDING ABORTION AND
CONNECTING THEM WITH SAFE.
AVOIDERS AND SUPPORT IF NEEDED
TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER THAT CARE
AND- WITHOUT WILL LETTER
WITNESSES. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- CENTER SKINNER AND ALSO
CENTER CAN AVAIL- THAT'S NOW
BRING ON I THINK THE BOTH BY THE
PHONE SO LOOKS A MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AT THE
FELLOW. AND HOTEL- LOPEZ I OUR-
SO THAT EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES-
SO APPY FELLOW CAN BE AN- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ABBY FELLOW AND I'M A
PATIENT STORYTELLER WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ADVOCATES MARMONT. AT
AGE TWENTY SIX BY IT SALES AND
SO BEGINS THE WEEK OF SEVERE
STRESS SHAME AND CONFUSION ABOUT
TRYING TO ACCESS AN ABORTION. I
KNEW IT ALL FANS ABOUT THE TIME
I GO TO A DOCTOR I'D NEVER MET.
SHE THAT MY PART IS ACT. FOR
NEED EMERGENCY SURGERY TO STOP
THE BLEEDING. I AM TERRIFIED SO
I AGREED TO THE PROCEDURE
IMMEDIATELY. WHEN I WAKE UP I
LEARNED THE PREGNANCY WASN'T
ACTUALLY I THOUGHT THANK BUT DUE
TO SAFETY CONCERNS THE DOCTORS
PERFORMED AT THE END. I'M TOLD
THIS MEANS THE PREGNANCY IS OVER
AND I CAN MOVE ON WITH MY LIFE.
HOWEVER MY ONE WEEK CHECKUP AND
STILL PREGNANT SO I SPEND THE
NEXT SEVERAL DAYS DOING NOTHING
EXCEPT TRYING TO GET AN
ABORTION. AT FIRST THE DOCTOR
GAVE ME A PRESCRIPTION FOR
MEDICAL ABORTION AND SENT ME TO
A PHARMACY. AND SOCIALLY AND
WHEN THE PHARMACIST SHOT THAT
THIS MEDICATION CAN ONLY BE
ADMINISTERED AT THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE. WHEN I CALLED THE DOCTOR
EXPLAINS THAT SHE CAN'T GIVE ME
THE ABORTION IN HER OFFICE AND
SHE'S EMPLOYED BY CAP THE CALL.
ALL NOW I AM PANICKING CONFUSE I
DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER DOCTORS IN
LA TO GO TO. I WISH SOMEONE
WOULD JUST GIVE ME AN
INSTRUCTION MANUAL FOR HOW
DOCTOR FOR THE PORTION. I WISH
SOMEONE WOULD EXPLAIN HOW TO
TELL MY OLDER MALE SUPERVISORS I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO WORK FOR A
WEEK AND MIGHT NEED MORE TIME
OFF. SOBBING I CALL CLINIC
DOCTOR CLINIC BUT CAN'T GET AN
ABORTION ANYWHERE FOR A FEW
WEEKS. EVEN THOUGH I OFFERED A
COMMENT ANYTIME AND DRIVE
ANYWHERE. IF I HAD TIME OR
TRANSPORTATION CONSTRAINTS I
MIGHT HAVE TO WAIT MUCH. I
IMAGINE HOME POSSIBLE SCHEDULING
AS BUFFY FOR PEOPLE CARING FOR A
CHILD OR ELDERLY RELATIVES. I
EVENTUALLY GET THE ABORTION BUT
THE EXPERIENCE CONVINCED ME THAT
MAKING CALIFORNIA STATE FOR
PEOPLE TRULY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE REQUIRED INSURING ALL
PATIENTS. WHETHER THEY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA- COMING FROM OTHER
STATES AND ACCESS TO TIMELY
ABORTION ARE SUPPORTED ABOUT
PASTA MOSTLY AND LOGISTICALLY
AND GET HELP NAVIGATING
EDUCATIONAL AND FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCES KICKING THAT OUT OF
YOUR LIFE BACK. HEALTH CARE THE
BILL GET THOSE CLOSER TO THAT
EIGHT PROFESSORS I URGE YOU TO
VOTE HI. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S BRING ON- BUT YOU TELL
LOPEZ I LS. ACCESS PROTECT.
PLEASE PM. ASSEMBLY I THOUGHT
SHE LOOKED AT L. A. I'M POLICY I
FOR NADER CAL ONLY A PORTION AND
ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE JEFF ALSO
KNOWN AS RJ ACT RJ COMPANY THE
REPORT DOCTOR MOVEMENT WE
TEACHES I PLAN AND IF THE
PARENTS IN RATE CHILDREN. THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY THANK YOU RIGHT. R. J. OFFICER THE NEW CUENTA
CON. AND. FOR ADVOCATING BARRIER
FOR THAT IT NINETEEN MORE THAN
SHE COULD THOUSAND PEOPLE CALLED
AND LOOKING FOR HELP GET THEIR
PORTION. WE'LL CALL FOR SHOULD
FIND WE REMAIN KEY. WHEN IT
COMES CONNECTING THEM WITH THEM
CARE. NO OTHER NETWORK THE
SHARED. NOT AND EXPERTISE.
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL REAP. WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO COURT PATIENTS
WERE SPEAKING CARRY CAL. I
ELEVEN FORTY YOU WILL CREATED.
PORTION SUPPORT FUND TO PROVIDE
GRANTS PARTICIPATION FLIGHT AT
THAT WILL PROVIDE LOGISTICAL
DIRECT SUPPORT THE PEOPLE ACT
THAT THE ABORTION PERFECTLY
CALIFORNIA. WHEN I TELL YOU A
PORTION FUNDS LIKE THE PARKING A
JURY CHALLENGING WORK DIFFERENT
PASSION OF CARING FOR OTHERS AND
TRY THAT. IS NOT AN EXAGGERATION
AND WE CANNOT FAST RELIEF FOR
THE PAIN POLITICAL MOMENT FOR
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE ECONOMY
YOU KNOW TAX. MORE FINANCIAL
BENEFIT THAN EVER AND MORE
PEOPLE WILL BE TRAVELING FOR A
PORTION WITH HIGH IN
CONSTRUCTION. AND I THINK YOUR
SUPPORT AT ELEVEN FORTY TWO.
BILLION HONOR CREDIT DECADES OF
WISDOM AND HERITAGE IN A PORTION
OF THE WORK. FOR THE TRUCK GIVES
YOU NEED TO SPEAK UP FOR YOU
TODAY I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
CHIU LIBERATION WITH THE PORTION
I MEAN. BETTER AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE I'M ALSO AVAILABLE.
FOR QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE
NOW MOVE ON WITNESS. AND SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY TWO OR A POSITION
BEGINNING ROOM TO HUNDRED. MOLLY
ROBSON WITH PACK BY AND PROUD
SUPPORT THANK YOU. JOE SOROS
WITH THE CAL. MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. SEE NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING A
MICROPHONE ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
REQUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. BURKE I THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. YOU'RE RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MULTI AGAIN WITH
THE CENTRAL AFTER POSTING STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU FACT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN FOR
TWENTY SIX BEFORE I HAVE. HI
SHANNON OLIVIERI HOLDEN ERICA
MIRACLE TREE CALIFORNIA LET'S
PUT INCOME. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
MORE COMMON THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION TO SB. ELEVEN
OPPOSITION IN PERSON SO BEGIN
WITH US SUSAN ARE NOW WITH THE
RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE FOLLOWED BY
MOLLY SHEEHAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE- YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES A TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
SO. YOU PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN MY NAME IS SUSAN
ARNOLD I'M A CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
AND VICE PRESIDENT OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS AT THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE AMERICA'S FIRST PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING FIFTY
TWO MEMBER PREGNANCY HEALTH
CLINICS CENTERS AND MATERNITY
HOMES IN EVERY ONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PRO LIFE VOTERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO PROPOSES TO FUND A
MYRIAD OF SERVICES TO SUPPORT
ABORTION TOURISM ALL FUNDED
THROUGH A FANCY STATE FINANCED
WEBSITE THE BILL TOTALLY IGNORES
FUNDING FOR CHILD BIRTH THE
OTHER REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE
BECAUSE S. B. ELEVEN FORTY TWO
IS SO ONE SIDED IN ITS FUNDING
MAKING NO ACCOMMODATION FOR
FUNDING CHILDBIRTH SERVICES IT
VIOLATES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THE UNEQUAL
FINANCIAL TREATMENT OF ABORTION
AND CHILD BIRTH BY THE STATE IS
CLEARLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
ACCORDING TO COMMITTEE TO DEFEND
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS VERSUS MYERS
IN THAT CASE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT RULED THAT THE PRO
LIFE LEGISLATURE VIOLATED THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONSTITUTION BY
FINANCIALLY FAVORING CHILDBIRTH
OVER ABORTION WITH A QUOTE
CONDITIONING OF PUBLIC BENEFITS
FRAMEWORK. TODAY MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS LATER PRO ABORTION
LEGISLATORS ARE ADVANCING SB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO FAVORING
ABORTION OVER CHILD BIRTH THE
BILL MANDATES FUNDING QUOTE
DIRECT LOGISTICAL AND PRACTICAL
SUPPORT BUT ONLY FOR ABORTION
PATIENTS THESE INCLUDE QUOTE
AIRFARE LODGING GROUND
TRANSPORTATION GAS MONEY MEALS
DEPENDENT CHILD CARE DUELA
SUPPORT AND TRANSLATION SERVICES
TO HELP A PERSON ACCESS AND
OBTAIN. AN ABORTION ON QUOTE THE
BILL OFFERS A STATE FUNDED
ABORTION VACATION INCLUDING
PAYMENT SUPPORT RESOURCES TO
QUOTE HELP PEOPLE WITH THE COST
OF THE ABORTION PROCEDURE ON
QUOTE. S. B. ELEVEN FORTY TWO
DOES NOT PROVIDE SUCH ASSISTANCE
OR BENEFITS TO THOSE WHO CHOOSE
TO MISSILE BIRTH WHY NOT ISN'T
BIRTH A CHOICE TO S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY TO BLATANTLY FAVORS ONE
REPRODUCED GROUP REPRODUCTIVE
CHOICE OVER ANOTHER AND IT IS
CON CONSTITUTIONAL PLEASE REJECT
SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO THANK YOU.
VIEW SO WE NOW HAVE A BUY SHE
HAD AND- SHE LEFT YOU A MINUTE
AND I THINK FORTY FIVE SECONDS
OKAY THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MOLLY
SHEEHAN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE.
THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IS THE
LARGEST PROVIDER OF PRIVATE
NONPROFIT SOCIAL SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE WORLD AND
EVERY SINGLE DAY OUR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER'S GO INTO THE HOMES OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES
FAMILIES IN POVERTY AND THESE
FAMILY STATE WE CANNOT SURVIVE
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA. POOR WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T HAVE
TIME OFF WORK WHO DON'T HAVE
SOMEONE TO WATCH THEIR KIDS WHO
ARE LIVING WITH AN ABUSIVE
PARTNER WHO DON'T HAVE
TRANSPORTATION TO PRENATAL
APPOINTMENTS WHO CAN'T PAY FOR
GAS OR HOUSING INSECURE THEY
FEEL THEY HAVE NO CHOICES. YEAH
THIS BILL WOULD OFFER THOSE SAME
SOLUTIONS TO WOMEN WHO ARE OUT
OF STATE COMING HERE FOR
ABORTIONS. LOW INCOME MOTHERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA AND OTHER
STATES DO NOT WANT TO TRAVEL TO
HAVE AN ABORTION THEY DO SO ONLY
WHEN THEY FEEL THAT THAT'S THEIR
OPTION IN A SITUATION THAT IS
IMPOSSIBLE. THE SAME WITH
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WHO SAY LOOK
WE'RE PUTTING OFF HAVING
CHILDREN FOR NOT HAVING CHILDREN
WE WANT TO HAVE WE HAVE CHILDREN
AND WE'RE NOT THRIVING. IF
YOU'RE HOMELESS AND PREGNANT
CALIFORNIA YOU DON'T RECEIVE A
PRIORITY HOUSING UNTIL YOU'RE
SEVEN MONTHS PREGNANT. THESE
MOTHERS HAVE TO PAY FOR PRENATAL
CARE DELIVERY PROTECTION ALL THE
CARE THEY RECEIVED THROUGHOUT
PREGNANCY OUT OF POCKET AND
THERE'S NO EQUITY FOR CALIFORNIA
WOMEN AND FAMILIES OFFERING
ABORTION AS THE ONLY SOLUTION
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THESE REAL
NEEDS IS TANTAMOUNT TO COERCION.
MOST LOW INCOME WOMEN SELF
IDENTIFY AS PRO LIFE ACCORDING
TO GALLUP AND THE LOW INCOME
MOTHERS WE WORK WITH EVERY DAY
DO NOT WANT MORE ABORTION THEY
WANT HELP TO BE PERRANCE.
CHANNEL AWAY FROM CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO PAY RENT
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE TO FIND
HOUSING ON THE LONG WAIT LIST
FOR DAY CARE DOES NOT ACHIEVE
THE GOAL OF REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE. FAMILIES DESERVE THE
RIGHT TO LIVE IN SAFE AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES YES AND
TO BE SUPPORTED WHEN THEY CHOOSE
TO BE PARENTS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN ISRAELIS. WHO
WANT SUPPORT TO BE PARENTS AND
LIVING HEALTH FORMULA I ARE A NO
VOTE ON SPLM FORTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WILL NOT ON ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO SO. NAME OR
POSITION A POSITION. I THINK IT
MELISSA MELENDEZ- I OPPOSE
EVERYTHING YOU DO IS FRAUD THANK
YOU. YOUR NEXT WITNESS. HI MY
NAME'S JENNIFER MILBORNE I WORK
FOR ABORTION SURVIVORS NETWORK
AND SURVIVED AN ABORTION
PROCEDURE BY MY BIOLOGICAL MOM
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. A GREG BIRD WITH A
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. BRIDGET
BLAIR I'VE HAD FOR A THREE FIRST
TRIMESTER DNC SECTION ABORTIONS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. JONATHAN KELLER
WITH CALIFORNIA FAMILY ALLIANCE
AND ALSO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN BAPTIST
CONVENTION STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE YOUR
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FORTY
TWO NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU IF YOUWISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. YEAR LIVE
AND FORTY YOU SEE FRANK ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. START WITH LINE
FOR THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. ANNE HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
COPYRIGHT ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR CAT NUMBER EIGHTEEN
COUNTY STRONG OPPOSITION SO FAR
VERY FEW LEX WITNESS. THANK YOU
LINE FOR TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JIM
AMHERST AND PLASTER COUNTY AND
STRONG ENOUGH TO DISTANCE ITSELF
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M THREE EIGHTY THREE
REQUIRE. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT
JAY BIRD I'M A LIFELONG RESIDENT
OF THE DISTRICT ELEVEN AND I'M
AN ACTIVIST AT PRO LIFE WITHOUT
APPROVED GETTING PROJECT THE
VOTE NO ON THAT FEEL LEVIN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
EIGHT ZERO TO NINETY SEVEN
PEOPLE HAVE. THE OPENING FOR
OPEN MY MOTHER A FEW CENTS
BEATING HEART YOUR SHOPPING THE
ONLY A POST A FEW CAN AFFORD. TO
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU. THREE THREE THREE FIVE. BY
THREE TO THREE. BY FOUR TWENTY
NINE THREE FOUR. MY NAME IS
BRIDGET CANDLES I FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUYING TWO THREE ONE. FIVE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB THE
TRACY WESLEY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. BY FOUR TWENTY FIFTH GO AHEAD
. YEAH MY NAME IS NOEL MILBORNE
FATHER HAS BEEN AND- CARING FOR
MOTHERS AND THE UNBORN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES MY NAME IS SUSAN LACY'S
PLASTER COUNTY RESIDENT MOTHER
OF FIVE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. THANK YOU I FOR TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MANY
VICTORIES AND OVER. MERCED
COUNTY RESIDENT AND FATHER AND
I'M IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I ONE THIRTY CORTES. BY ONE
THREE ZERO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
REVITALIZATION POSITION. EIGHTY
EIGHT LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I
FOR THIRTY FOUR REQUIRED. BRIAN
FOR THREE FOUR. SEVERAL BASS
RIGHT AFTER ONLY OPPOSED THE
BILL SB FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR AND
A FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY SIX
THANK YOU ACTUAR N. S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY TWO THANKS THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS THIS IS ABOUT MONEY
THANK YOU RYAN TWO OH SEVEN
PLEASE GLORIA. I'D LIKE TO
REMAIN RELEVANT BUT AS- SOMEONE
WHO RECEIVED IN A PORTRAIT AND
NOW AS A MOTHER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS MAIN ORGANIZATION
POSITION THANK YOU YES. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO THIRTY. PLEASE CALL
. YES HOW CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
NAY MORTICIAN POSITION LOW.
YEAH- ABORTION IS NOT
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE NO ON HAND
AT THE ELEVEN FORTY WHAT'S YOUR
NAME SIR. OKAY NEXT WITNESS AND. THANK YOU I'M FREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO AND
MAYBE FOUNDER MARK HAS SIGNED AN
AGREEMENT WITH TWO INDIVIDUALS
BOTH IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
AT ELEVEN FORTY TWO BRIAN
STRONGLY DURING THE NINETY NINE
OCCURRED THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU I EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GOING. BY EIGHT FIVE. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU THANKS FOR MUCH THEY'LL
BRING THE SET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. YEAH OKAY CENTER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- SO
SENATORS SKINNER AND COVER YOUR-
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS- THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE A WEBSITE TO
BE ESTABLISHED SO THAT IT CAN
LIST WHERE ONE CAN ACQUIRE AN
ABORTION AND IT ALSO ESTABLISHES
A FUND TO ASSIST THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING AN ABORTION RIGHT THAT'S
THE NUTS AND BOLTS OF IT. THERE
ARE TWO SEPARATE PIECES AND ONE
IS A WEBSITE AND ONE IN RIGHT ON
THE FUNDING OKAY FOR THE
FUNDING- PURSUANT TO THE
LEGISLATURE MAKING THE
PREPARATION FOR THE FUNDS- THESE
FUNDS WOULD COULD BE ACCESSED BY
. ANY WOMAN SEEKING AN ABORTION
WHETHER SHE'S A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT OR NOT IS THAT CORRECT
THE STATE FUNDS- WELL THAT IT
THERE IS IT IS WE ANTICIPATE A
FUND THE FUND WILL WOULD INCLUDE
STATE RESOURCES AND THEN THEY
WOULD INCLUDE- PHILANTHROPIC
RESOURCES INCLUDING DONATIONS
FROM INDIVIDUALS- RIGHT NOW IT
APPEARS AS IT AS IF WE NEED TO
SEGREGATE THOSE FUNDS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
CONSEQUENCES- AND IT'S OUR
ANTICIPATION THE STATE FUNDS
WOULD BE USED FOR STATE
RESIDENTS IN THE PHILANTHROPIC-
FUND WOULD BE USED FOR OUT OF
STATE- FOR. ANYBODY WHO- IS
ASKING THE FOR- SERVICES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OKAY THAT IS
NOT OUTLINED IN THE BILL THOUGH
THAT IS CORRECT ARE YOU PLANNING
ON AMENDING IT YES. WE'RE
WORKING ON ON EXACTLY HOW WE
HAVE TO SET UP THE FUNDS IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH. STATE LAW
OKAY SO AT THIS POINT YOU'RE NOT
CLEAR AS TO HOW. HE WOULD DO
THAT. NO THIS TO AT THIS TIME
IT'S CLEAR HOW WE WOULD DO THAT
IT'S A QUESTION OF EXACTLY WHERE
THE FUNDS WOULD BE AND HOW THEY
WOULD BE ALLOCATED- ACTUALLY OF
THIS WEEK OKAY THAT AND UNLESS
UNLESS SOMEONE'S ASKING ASKING
ME FOR THAT SORRY. S. S. S. IS
VERY COMMON IN MANY BILLS WHEN
YOU'RE STILL TRYING TO WORK OUT
THE DETAILS OF IMPLEMENTATION IN
BECAUSE OF OBVIOUSLY THIS WOULD
BEEN MEETING WITH. YES FUNDS
STATE AGENCIES TO. WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STRUCTURE WAS
EXACTLY RIGHT AND WE'VE NOT
LANDED ON THAT BUT WE HAD FOR
EXAMPLE MEETING TODAY ON THE
QUESTION AND SO WE WILL BE
AMENDING IT SO THAT IT OUTLINES
EXACTLY WHAT THE THAT DIFFERENCE
IN ANY OTHER DIFFERENCES WE NEED
FOR THE FUND TO BE ESTABLISHED
APPROPRIATELY SO CAN I ASK-
WHAT'S THE RUSH I MEAN IT THIS
SEEMS COMPLICATED ON HOW YOU
MIGHT COMPLICATED BECAUSE WE
ALREADY HAVE FOR EXAMPLE- IF WE
TAKES NOT A BELL STYLE NO IT'S
NOT IN THE BILL YET BECAUSE- THE
TODAY THIS THE FIRST HEARING
ENDED. THAT'S WERE PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESSYOUR WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS AND WE
STILL HAVE OTHER COMMITTEES THAT
WILL HAVE TO BE VITAL INTEREST I
IF I GET THAT IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS OFTENTIMES BILLS ARE
AMENDED ALONG THE WAY
DISSATISFIED THE CONCERNS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MORE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE IMPLEMENTATION
MECHANISMS BUT BUT GENERALLY THE
BILL IS- YOU KNOW GOT MORE. IS
MORE COOKED THAN THIS BUT-
THAT'S NEITHER HERE NOR THERE-
SO YOU TURN OF MY BILLS THAT
STILL NEED IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS. SO THE FUNDS COULD BE
USED FOR- THOSE WHO COME TO
CALIFORNIA FROM OUT OF STATE
FOR- AN ABORTION. AND. I GUESS.
RIGHT I KNOW YOU MADE MENTION
DURING YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT- IT
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME SORT OF
NATIONWIDE PRESS ON THIS BUT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THE TEXAS
ABORTION BILL IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT HAS WITH HELD- YOU KNOW
LEGALLY I MEAN THAT'S IT SO I AM
. I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE SUPREME
COURT MAY RULE ON THIS BUT THEY
HAVEN'T I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL AND COULD
POSSIBLY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO- BUT- A- I GUESS
IRRESPECTIVE OF THAT- RIGHT YOU
KNOW I. I GUESS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS PROBABLY VERY
HAPPY THAT YOU'RE BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO STAND TO BENEFIT
THE MOST- THANKS TO THE
TAXPAYERS IN ANY PHILANTHROPIC
EFFORTS- BUT I CANNOT SUPPORT A
BILL THAT. SEEKS TO SNUFF OUT
THE LIFE OF A HUMAN BEING THAT'S
A PHILOSOPHICAL- DIFFERENCE
OBVIOUSLY NUMBER I ALSO DON'T
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE
WOULD THAT THE TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD WOULD PAY FOR
THAT I JUST I JUST DON'T BELIEVE
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THOSE
THROUGH TWO THINGS COMBINED I'M
SURE THIS COMES AS A SURPRISE TO
YOU ON THAT I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL BUT I JUST. I WILL END MY
COMMENTS BY SAYING THAT- I THINK
. THIS PERHAPS THE GENESIS WAS
THE GOVERNOR'S STATEMENT THAT HE
WANTED CALIFORNIA TO BECOME THE
ABORTION SANCTUARY WHICH I CAN
THINK OF MANY MANY THINGS THAT
WE SHOULD BE KNOWN FOR THAT IS
NOT ONE OF THEM- BUT I YOU KNOW
MY GUESS IS IT'S COMING FROM
THAT AND THIS IS A WAY TO HELP
IMPLEMENT HIS VISION- BUT IT IS
NOT APPROPRIATE TO ASK- OTHER
PEOPLE TO PAY FOR- SOMEONE
ELSE'S ABORTIONS SO- I WILL NOT
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR MELENDEZ-
CENTER WINNER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I THINK THE TAXPAYERS
SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE SUPPORTING-
PEOPLE'S ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE INCLUDING ABORTION- AND I
AND I WAS OTHER STATES- MOVED
TO- EFFECTIVELY BAN ABORTION I
THINK OKLAHOMA IS THE LATEST
ONE- AS WE SEE THE TRAIN WRECK
THAT. IS THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT- I THINK I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL AND LIFESAVING FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE CAN COME AND SEE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IF
THEY'RE BANNED AND CRIMINALIZED-
DOING SO IN THEIR OWN- IN THEIR
OWN STATE I'M PEOPLE DO ANY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE ARE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING
ABLE TO FLY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND GET A HOTEL ROOM AND PAY FOR
CARE. NOT EVERYONE CAN DO THAT
ABOUT THEIR PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE PEOPLE STRUGGLE TO HAVE
ACCESS SO I THINK THIS IS
INCREDIBLY. IMPORTANT I THINK
IT'S TERRIFYING WHAT'S HAPPENING
AROUND THE COUNTRY IS ABSOLUTELY
TERRIFYING THAT THEIR WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY AND THEY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE ARE LOW INCOME WOMEN
PEOPLE WHO AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
WHO ARE AND WHO ARE GOING TO BE.
EFFECTIVELY FORCED BY THE STATE
THEY LIVE IN- TO CARRY A
PREGNANCY TO TERM THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON THERE AND DO NOT
WANT TO CARRY TO TERM OR NOT. SO
I'M IT IS LITERALLY. THEM
COMMANDEER THEIR BODY AND
TELLING THEM YOU MUST CARRY TO
TERM. AND THAT IS NOT TO ME
THAT'S NOT. AMERICAN THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS COUNTRY IS ABOUT- THIS
IS COUNTRY IS ABOUT. FREEDOM AND
IT IS ABOUT- PEOPLE MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES- AND
SO- I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL- I NOTICED THAT THE- CO
AUTHOR LISTS ARE- ALL ONE GENDER
IF YOU ARE ACCEPTING- MALE CO
AUTHORS I WOULD LOVE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR IF NOT I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND- AND- HUNDREDS. WE
WOULD WELCOME YOU- YES. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
TWENTY MEMBERS FACING NONE-
BUCKLEY IS EIGHT I THINK CENTER
LEADER PROBABLY CAPTURED A LOT
OF IN HIS REMARKS FOR AT LEAST
FOR MYSELF AND PERHAPS RATHER'S
AS WELL O- AND YOU'VE MADE OF I
THINK YOU'VE PRETTY WELL
PRESENTED THE ISSUES TWELVE SO-
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE IN SUPPORT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WILL
DROP TO THE CLOSING OF AB
SENATOR WIENER AS MY CLOTHES AND
I RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU. WAS THERE A
MO YEAH SO MOVED. HER EXPENSIVE
FIGHT. A CENTER EGGMAN MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY-
CONSULTANT PLESE CALL THE ROLL
HAND BY HAND HI MELINDA'S HELLO
AND IS NO EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI
GONZALEZ GROVE HER TADO LEYVA.
LEYVA EILEEN MOANED. ROTH ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE RIGHT THAT'S
CURRENTLY SIX ONE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY I SEE
THAT WE HAVE SENATOR GLAZERS
HERE- SO I THINK- TO THAT ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. SIR GLAZER. THANK
YOU FOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS. AND
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
ON THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL
THE GOOD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- I'VE
AUTHORED SB FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE AMERICAN
RED CROSS. THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE A REGISTERED NURSE TO
BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT OR
AVAILABLE VIA TELEHEALTH FOR
BLOOD DONATIONS. NATIONWIDE
BLOOD CENTERS ARE FACING A BLOOD
CRISIS. THE WORST BLOOD SHORTAGE
IN OVER. A DECADE. DOCTORS HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO MAKE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS ABOUT WHO RECEIVES
BLOOD TRANSFUSIONS. AND WHO WILL
NEED TO WAIT UNTIL MORE PRODUCTS
BECOME AVAILABLE. THIS PAST
JANUARY YES JUST A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THIRTY
YEARS. HARBOR UCLA MEDICAL
CENTER A PUBLIC HOSPITAL IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. CLOSE ITS
TRAUMA CENTER FOR TWO HOURS
BECAUSE IT RAN OUT OF BLOOD FOR
PATIENTS. IN ADDITION THOUSANDS
OF BLOOD DONATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE LOST EACH YEAR AS A
RESULT OF BLOOD DRIVES CANCELED
AT THE LAST MINUTE. TO DO OUR
AND STAFFING CHALLENGES.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE.
THAT MANDATES THAT A REGISTERED
NURSE BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT AT
ALL SITES WHENEVER BLOOD IS
DONATED. TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE
DURING THE PANDEMIC BLOOD BANKS
WERE ALLOWED TO DEVIATE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES REGULATIONS THAT
REQUIRE REGISTERED NURSE TO BE
AVAILABLE ON SITE. BUT A
REGISTERED NURSE WAS NOT
AVAILABLE TO BE ON SITE COVERAGE
OF THAT BLOOD DRIVE OPERATION
WAS ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH THE
UTILIZATION. OF A REGISTERED
NURSE VIS A VIS TELEHEALTH.
BASED ON DATA FROM THE AMERICAN
RED CROSS. THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE BLOOD DRIVE
OPERATIONS WHICH COLLECTED
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND PLUS RED
CELLS AND SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
PLUS. BOB PLATELETS UTILIZING
OUR INTEL HEALTH SUPPORT. THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE NOT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING IF THEY ARE AND HAD TO
BE AVAILABLE ONSITE. DATA ALSO
SHOWS THE DONOR SAFETY WAS NOT
IMPACTED DURING ANY OF THESE
BLOOD DRIVES. THIS BILL WOULD
ENSURE THAT BLOOD IS COLLECTED
SAFELY AND UNDER SUPERVISION OF
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR. OR THE
PERSON IN CHARGE FOR THE
TELEHEALTH NURSE IT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR INCREASED ACCESS TO
RURAL COMMUNITIES. IT WILL
PROVIDE FOR INCREASED AMOUNTS OF
BLOOD DURING CRITICAL PERIODS.
AND IT WOULD REDUCE COSTS TO
BLOOD BANKS. TELEHEALTH IS BEING
USED FREQUENTLY IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS AND HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
BE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT THIS
BILL WOULD PERMIT AND ARE AND TO
BE AVAILABLE VIA TELEHEALTH. TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY NURSING SKILLS
AND EXPERTISE DURING THE
DONATION PROCESS LIKE INTRODUCED
DOCTOR HERRON THE CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER AT THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS. AND DOCTOR HUGHES THE
SENIOR MEDICAL OFFICER AT
VIOLENCE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU SO-
DOCTOR AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO GIVE YOU TWO MINUTE WARNING
AND THEN- AND THEN TOTAL FORM IS
BETWEEN THE TWO SO YOU GO OVER
THE DOCTOR HUGHES HAS LESS TIME
SUCH AS- OKAY JERRY BEGAN IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- DR
RUSS HERE AND DIVISIONAL CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER FOR AMERICAN RED
CROSS BY MEDICAL SERVICES. ALSO
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS THEME OF
VIGILANCE PROGRAM. CAME OF AGE
IN ITS THEM. IN A VALUATION OF
BLOOD DONOR FIFTY IN PENN
TRANSFUSION RELATED PATIENT
SAFETY- THE AMERICAN RED CROSS
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. THE TOP
PRIORITY OF THE RED CROSS TO
SAFETY OF BLOOD DONORS AND
SAFETY TRANSFUSED PATIENTS.
WITHOUT READILY AVAILABLE BLOOD
PRODUCTS AS SEEN WITH THE
HISTORY MAKING NATIONAL BLOOD
CRISIS. PHYSICIANS MUST MAKE
DIFFICULT CRISIS STANDARDS OF
CARE DECISIONS IN PATIENT CARE
SUFFERS. DURING THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC EMERGENCY IN
THE NATIONAL BLOOD CRISIS
AVAILABLE BLOOD DONORS HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO DONATE BLOOD DUE TO
CANCEL BLOOD DRIVES AN INABILITY
TO SCHEDULE BLOOD DRIVES DUE TO
STAFF SHORTAGES. IN WITHOUT THE
USE OF EMERGING. TELL THIS.
WOULD HAVE BEEN EVEN WORSE.
UPDATED FIGURES FROM MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY TO MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THERE OVER SIXTEEN
HUNDRED RED CROSS BLOOD DRIVES
WOULD UTILIZE TELEHEALTH
REGISTERED NURSE COVERAGE. THAT
WAS ABOUT THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
BLOOD DONATIONS OF ALL BLOOD AND
ABOUT NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
DONATIONS OF PLATELETS. ARE AND
STAFF SHORTAGES IN CALIFORNIA
BUT A LONG TERM PROBLEM WE
CONTINUE TO BE SO. IN CALIFORNIA
THE RED CROSS HAS TWENTY THREE
ARE IN POSITIONS CURRENTLY OPEN.
THIRTEEN OF THOSE POSITIONS HAVE
BEEN OPEN FOR OVER ONE YEAR. IT
CROSSES EXPERIENCE YOUR ISSUES
AFFECT ACCESSING OUR ENDS WITH
TELEHEALTH OPTIONS. THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE MANY PRIOR
YEARS EXPERIENCE OF ACCESSING
RED CROSS DITIONS ROUTINELY BY
TELEPHONE AND OTHER VIRTUAL
MEANS. IN A RED CROSS- BUT
REGIONS THAT HAVE HAD A
DEDICATED PHYSICIAN STAFF
AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY. TO CONSULT ON ANY MEDICAL
CONCERNS RELATED TO ANY OF THE
PLEDGE DRIVES. BLOOD DONORS A
HEALTHY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
EXTENSIVELY SCREENED FOR DAR
ELIGIBILITY AND THE RED CROSS
MANAGES DONOR COMPLICATIONS
ACCORDING TO PROCEDURES THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED NATIONWIDE BY
RED CROSS MEDICAL IRECTORS-
REACTIONS ARE HANDLED BY THIS
ALL. IN THE SAME MANNER
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER REGISTERED
NURSE OR UNLICENSED STAFF
MEMBERS ASSISTING WITH THE
COMPLICATION. HAS MENTIONED
CALIFORNIA THE ONLY STATE THAT
MANDATES THAT A REGISTERED NURSE
BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT AT ALL
SITES WHENEVER BLOOD IS DONATED
TO MINUTES. DESPITE THIS
REQUIREMENT RED CROSS DONOR HIM
OF ITS AND STATUS- NO
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE RED
CROSS. REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER GREGIS NATIONWIDE- USING
REAL WORLD DATA FROM THE UP
BEFORE THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND ALSO DURING THAT
AND PANDEMIC EMERGENCY. WE'VE
SHOWN- THAT USING OUR INTEL
HEALTH CAN BE EFFECTIVE. FOR
SAFETY AND AVAILABILITY THE RED
CROSS STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE IT
PROMOTES BLOOD AVAILABILITY FOR
PATIENT CARE THAT'S PROMOTING
PATIENT SAFETY. AND RETAIN THE
HIGH STANDARDS OF DONOR SAFETY
THEY'VE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN CALIFORNIA. DURING
THE LAST TWO YEARS OF WAR AND
TELEHEALTH COVERAGE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND THE DOCTOR USUALLY BE
NEXT. OKAY DR. HUSING LEFT TWO
MINUTES TWENTY SECONDS. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR JONATHAN
HUGHES AND I'M THE SENIOR CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER FOR BY TALENT.
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF BLOOD
CENTERS OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
COALITION OF FIVE ELEVEN NOT FOR
PROFIT BLOOD CENTERS THAT ARE
LICENSED TO OPERATE WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE PROVIDE
OVER 90% OF THE BLOOD THAT IS
USED BY HOSPITALS WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. CERTAINLY
IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGING LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND WE FACED.
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES RELATED
TO INVENTORY AS WELL AS STAFFING
CHALLENGES. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ASSURE DONOR SAFETY THROUGH THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE
THAT IS ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
ROBUST DONOR SCREENING
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA WE HAVE
ROBUST POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
THAT ARE IN PLACE TO SUPPORT THE
CARE COLLECTION AND MANAGEMENT
OF DONORS. AGAIN THE SAME
PROPHECIES FOR BOTH LICENSED AS
WELL AS NON LICENSED STAFF. AS
WELL AS ROBUST TRAINING
COMPETENCY PROGRAMS. I'M STAFF
THAT HAVE MORE XCELERATED OR
SUPPORT FOR AVERY'S THIS
DONATION AGAIN THE SAME SORT OF
TRAINING IS PROVIDED FOR BOTH-
LICENSED AS WELL AS NON LICENSE
STAFF IN SUPPORT OF A FREEZE
THIS DONATION. WHICH HAS A
PROVEN SAFETY TRACK RECORD OVER
DECADES AS WELL AS OTHER STATES
WHICH LIKEWISE DO NOT REQUIRE AN
ONSITE PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF A
NURSE TO SUPPORT THESE. FREEZES
DONATIONS OR WHOLE BLOOD
DONATIONS. THROUGH THE DATA THAT
WE'VE COLLECTED AS WELL AS
THROUGH THE NEEDTO SUPPORT LIFE
CARE. LIFESAVING MISSION WITHIN
THE HOSPITALS WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THAT WOULD INCREASE ACCESS.
TO OUR DONORS. AS WELL AS
PROVIDING LIFESAVING PRODUCTS
FOR PATIENTS IN NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FIVE HUNDRED TIMES.
OKAY WE'LL TAKE A ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED AND. SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHRISTY WOODS REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS- AND LOOKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I SEE NO
ONE ELSE COMING UP THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE- NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THAT THE FOURTEENTH SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HE ONE MOMENT FOR
COMMENT HE.
FIVE FOUR FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. COMMENTED THAT THE
AMERICAN- HIM PART OF SB FORTY
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THAT'S WHAT THIS. EIGHT YOU LINE
THREE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR LADY OF LORDS
REPRESENTING LIKE SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA WE'RE JUST ON SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT TO SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON BEHALFOF BY
TALENT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF IT
THE FOURTEENTH SEVENTY FIVE
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS.
THANK YOU I FOR FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CARRILLO BY
TALENT SUPPORT THANK YOU THE
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- THAT'S NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- THAT WOULD GIVE
CURTIS LANE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION JAZZ
SUMMARILY FROM CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION- YET TWO MINUTES
APIECE WILL BEGIN WITH- CURTIS
LANE. YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ENCOURAGE LINE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND REGISTERED
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA. IF WE
OPPOSE AT THE FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH WOULD IT AND THE
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE BANKS HAVE
A REGISTERED NURSE FIFTY PRESENT
DURING BLOOD DRAWS AND OTHER
PROCEDURES. INSTEAD WOULD ALLOW
THE REGISTERED NURSES O MONITOR
THE PROCEDURES TO BE A
TELECONFERENCE NURSES ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT PATIENT SAFETY
WILL BE PUT AT RISK BY THIS
CHANGE. THAT IS AS IT HAS BECOME
A PAINFULLY CLEAR FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS THE CONFERENCE
SERVICES ARE FREE WE ON
RELIABLE. THIS RISK WOULD BE-
EVEN BE EXASPERATED AND RURAL
AREAS LESS RELIABLE INTERNET OR
PHONE SERVICE. AND THESE RURAL
AREAS ALSO LIKE THE INVOLVED
WATER TRAVEL TIME TO EMERGENCY
CARE CREATING ADDITIONAL RISKS
TO THOSE DONATING. HEALTHCARE
WORKERS SIMPLY CAN'T INTERPRET
SOMEONE'S PHYSICAL REACTION TO
BLOOD BANK PROCEDURES OVER THE
PHONE OR EVEN BY VIDEO
CONFERENCING AS WELL AS CAN BE
DONE AND- PERSON. THE COLLECTION
OF WHOLE BLOOD FROM HEALTHY
DONORS IS ONLY ONE PROCEDURE
PERFORMED IN BURBANK SETTING
OTHER PROCEDURES THAT INVOLVE A
POTENTIAL FOR GREATER RISK
INCLUDE AFTER REESE'S APRIL
RECESS. DURING WHICH A
PARTICULAR BLOOD COMPONENT IS
OBTAINED FROM A DONOR AND
SEPARATE OUT FOR COLLECTION AND
THE REMAINING BLOOD IS RETURNED
TO THE DONOR AT THE END OF THE
PROCEDURE. TO ENSURE SAFETY FOR
CALIFORNIANS NURSES- MUST BE ON
THE PREMISES FOR THIS AND OTHER
PROCEDURES. ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT TEENAGE BLOOD
DONORS. COMPRISED A LARGE AND-
BOB. A BLOW DON'T BLOOD DONORS
IN THE STATES. ALTHOUGH BLOOD
DONATION IS IF PROCEED. ADVERSE
REACTIONS IN INJURIES HAVE BEEN
REPORTED. A DISPROPORTIONATE
NUMBER OF SEVERE REACTIONS AND
INJURIES OCCUR AMONG TEENAGE
WHOLE BLOOD DONORS COMPARED TO
ADULT AREN'T DONORS ACROSS ALL
AGE GROUPS. I HAVE INDICATE THAT
THE PRACTICE OF TELEMEDICINE
BOARD FISHING IN FACEBOOK
COLLECTION ROB THE STATE IS SAFE
NECESSARY IMPRACTICAL HOWEVER
RESTRICTION DURING THE COPA
PANDEMIC RESULTING IN A 52%
DROP. IN COLLEGE AND HIGH SCHOOL
BLOOD DRIVE FROM THE PANDEMIC WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT WHEN THE
BLOOD DRIVE TO RESTART THIS
TEENAGE POPULATION WILL BE AT
RISK OF NURSES ARE NOT PRESENT
ON THE PRINCES. PROPONENTS OF
THIS MEASURE HAVE ALSO INDICATED
THAT BY REMOVING THE RESTRICTION
THAT NURSES SPECIFICALLY
PRESIDENT AT A BLOOD FOR ALL THE
LOVE TO MARRY THEIR INCREASES IN
BLOOD. DONATIONS IF THE SORT OF
BLOOD OR DONORS IN A IS A
NATIONWIDE PROBLEM LEAD TO BE
CAUSED BY MULTIPLE FACTORS. EVEN
STATE THAT DO NOT REQUIRE
ARMENIANS ARE ALSO SEEN DROPS IN
DONATIONS IS NOT RELATED TO
DIFFICULTY HIRING RN'S. LOUDLY
IT IS NOT UNIQUE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THE LOAN STATE
HOLDING UP SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
FOR ITS CITIZENS MANY STATES
ALLOW AYE FROM FOLKESTONE
MINISTER MEDICATION AND PERFORM
OTHER DUTIES THAT ARE PROBABLY
FOR LIFE AND- PERSONNEL BUT THE
DATA THAT DOES NOT MEAN. THAT IS
EITHER SAFE OR ACCEPTABLE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY. URGE YOUR NOBLE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ELSE
WE WANT TO CHECK A MAN. AND I
THINK YOU A MINUTE FIFTEEN.
RIGHT FROM ABOUT. GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
MALLEY THE LIST CAL LABOR
FEATHER OF AND RESPECTFUL TO FOR
WORKING FOR THE FIVE WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITE OFFICE
AND PROPONENTS OF THE MEASURE
FROM NEEDING THE STORAGE FOR THE
FED CARE BEFORE DEEPLY TROUBLED.
BY THE ELIMINATION OF THE
REQUIREMENT AND THERE SHOULD BE
PRESENT AT THE TIME OF. FLIGHT
DR- LABOR IS ALWAYS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND SUPPORT IN THE-
TO LOOK AT WAYS TO FIND. TO WHY
WORK FOR SHORTAGE. WORKFORCE
ISSUES. LAST YEAR WE HELPED
FIGHT FOR ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
INVESTING PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. WE WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR TO FOUR HUNDRED TRADE
PARTNERSHIP THAT AND- TO REJECT
THE NOTION NURSING SHORTAGE IN
THE STATE. WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON LEGISLATION TO FUND A
PROGRAM THAT WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING DOLLARS.
INCREASED. PAY FOR FEDERAL
QUALIFIED HEALTH. WE BELIEVE IT
CREDIT FOR BLOOD BAY INSURER HOW
QUALITY CARE AND PROVIDE LOW
RISK. PRODUCTS RELATED DISEASE
OR INFECTION. OF THE FIFTEEN
KIND OF HAD THE END WITH THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY- LARGE
ENTITIES FINANCED MAHLER
ENTITIES AND THEN TAKING COST
CUTTING MEASURES LIKE
ELIMINATING JOB. TO MAXIMIZE
PROFITS. I AND FOR THE REASONS
WE- URGE YOUR NOTIFICATION. THE
VERY MUCH WITHOUT A MOVE ONTO DO
SO WITNESSES OP TO SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED YES HI MY NAME IS SANDRA
E. FROM SAN I AM A REGISTERED
NURSE I AM ALSO ONE OF THE
PEOPLE REPRESENTING FORTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
TERRITORY OF CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS. BILL THANK YOU. SEE
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING A
MICROPHONE- MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK THE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END OF THE ROW I SAID FINE.
OVER TWENTY FOUR FORTY FOUR
PEOPLE HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS AT WAYLAND L. WILL
DEPUTY HERE- WE HAVE THE UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
YUNEEC YOU H. C. P. IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU BYE FOR FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHE MAIRE WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK
GOODNESS. THANK YOU I'M FOR
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS NOT ALLOWED TO
BE ON BEHALF OF NPA STATE
COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU. OKAY WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. AS OKAY S. AND RUBIO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- YOU KNOW I
WANNA JUST BE RESPECTFUL OF BOTH
SIDES HER DADDY'S THE COMMENTARY
NINETY NINERS DOWN YOU KNOW THIS
ISSUE IS AS PERSONAL FOR THE
NURSES AND I ACTUALLY SAT DOWN
I'M SORRY IT INTO TOWN I ZOOMED
WITH THEM- TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
ABOUT WHAT THE ISSUE IS AND- BOB
AND I KNOW I HEARD- THE CENTER
SAY THAT IN FORTY NINE STATES-
BUT THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE A
REGISTERED NURSE SO I WILL AGREE
WITH THE GENTLEMAN WHO SAID AND
I BELIEVE HE'S A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE NURSES WHO SAID THAT.
JUST BECAUSE OTHER STATES DON'T
REQUIRE INTEREST DOESN'T MEAN WE
HAVE TO SEARCH IF IT IF IT YOU
KNOW IF IT'S NOT SAFE FOR- FOR
PATIENTS BUT YOU KNOW I HAVE TO
SAY THOUGH I DID TRY TO FIND
INFORMATION ANY INFORMATION THAT
WOULD SAY THAT IT WAS DANGEROUS
YOU KNOW AND I DID INVITE THEM
TO SHARE ANY INFORMATION I WOULD
SAY AT ANY GIVEN TIME IF IT'S
DANGEROUS AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR THE SAYS
IT'S DANGEROUS I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT- WE ARE. GOING
THROUGH SOME CHALLENGES AND
CHANCES SHORTAGE THIS NOT ONLY
NURSES BUT ALSO BLOOD DRIVES AND
YOU KNOW I'M A DONOR SO YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR PATIENTS BUT AND I WANT TO
BE RESPECT FOR THE FACT THAT I
YOU KNOW GAVE IT EVERY EFFORT TO
FIND THAT INFORMATION THAT. THAT
SAID IT WAS DANGEROUS AND I
STILL DON'T HOUSE DOT- I DO WANT
TO- MAYBE SUCH US ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WAS BROUGHT UP WAS
THAT IN MAYBE RURAL AREAS IS
MORE DANGEROUS BECAUSE THERE'S A
LONGER WAIT TIMES IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING HAPPENS AT FOR AN
AMBULANCE TO GET THERE ARE TO
GET TO A HOSPITAL MAYBE IT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO HAVE
ABOUT. POSSIBLY BILLS EMOTE
AREAS THAT MAY BE MORE DANGEROUS
BUT NOT YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
KEEP AN OPEN MIND SO I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT- YOU KNOW I
HOPE. THAT THAT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A CENTER WE
- THANK YOU I MISS CHAIRMAN-
WHAT THEY THOUGHT FOR BRING US
FOR AND I DO SUPPORT- THIS BILL
- I COMPLY RESPECT. THE
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND- YOU
KNOW WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS
SAYING BUT WE TO YOURSELF I'M
NOT ALLOWED TO GIVE BLOOD
BECAUSE IT CAME OUT I AM BANNED
FROM GIVING BLOOD BUT I- I
FULLY- I DON'T WANT OTHER PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALLOWED TO GIVE BLOOD
BUT TO DO SO AND I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A PRETTY SEVERE. BLOOD
SHORTAGE IN THE CAR VERY BAD-
DURING THE PANDEMIC- AND YOU
KNOW I THINK WE NEED SOMETIMES
MOREFLEXIBILITY AND SO YOU KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE- WITH- WITH WITH-
STI TESTING A DOCTOR POSITION TO
SEE IT BUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
BE. PHYSICALLY THERE WALL STI
TESTING IS HAPPENING BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO EXPAND CAPACITY FOR
STI- TESTING ON WE DID A BILL TO
YOU KNOW EXPAND- ACCESS BY
ALLOWING ATVS COUNSELORS TO
ADMINISTER RAPID SYPHILIS TEST-
THE- OBG LANDS OPPOSED- THAT-
YOU WE MATT AND ULTIMATELY WE
PASSED AS PART OF BOTH THE CHAIR
KERRY. AND SO I YOU KNOW I THINK
EVERYONE WANTS PATIENT SAFETY
AND THAT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BUT I THINK WE CAN HAVE PATIENT
SAFETY WITH MORE FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT WE ARE- GETTING MORE BLOOD
DONATIONS- WE DO NEED A LOT MORE
NURSES AND THE NURSING
PROFESSION- WAS ALWAYS HARD AND
IT IS KIND OF BEEN REALLY HARD
HIT BY THIS PANDEMIC AND- AND-
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
NURSES WHO CHOSE. TO LEAVE THE
PROFESSION. BECAUSE OF THE-
DOUBLE STRESS AND TRAUMA F
THIS. AND WE NEED. TO READ TO
HAVE MORE NURSES- BUT NOT FOR
NOW- WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH AND-
AND WE NEED FOR BLOOD DONATIONS
SO- RESPECTFULLY TO THE
OPPOSITION I SUPPORT. CENTER
EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD I MEAN THE
ABILITY TO DONATE AND RECEIVE
BLOOD WHERE IT IS MOST NEEDED I
THINK IS CRITICAL NOPE AND
NOBODY ARGUES WITH THAT- I WOULD
OLD JUST ASK THIS BILL IS
PERMISSIVE RIGHT IT DOESN'T
MANDATE THAT THERE NOT BE AN R.
AND ON IT'S JUST PER MISSIVE
THAT IF NECESSARY ONE CAN BE
AVAILABLE. THROUGH THE TELLER
MOTORS ARE CORRECT THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY SO BECAUSE I'M
THINKING LIKE IT'S IN THE ISSUES
OF BEING OUT IN REMOTE AREAS
PERHAPS THAT CLINIC WOULD OPT TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS ALTHOUGH WE KNOW WHAT
TELEHEALTH. ARBOR MODE AREAS
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO BEAUTIFULLY
INCREASE PEOPLE'S ACCESS TO CARE
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO USE
TELEHEALTH- IN MORE WAYS- AND
JUST LIKE LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
EXTENDED. THE THE MEAN
PHYSICIANS. OVERSEE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. AND IT'S RIGHT
RIGHT AND NEVER VERY RARELY IN
PERSON. WE HAVE A LOT OF
EVIDENCE OF TO BE REQUIRING A
HIGHER LEVEL DEGREE BUT THAT
PERSON NOT BEING ON SITE BUT
THAT WORK IS GOING ON. NOBODY
SAID LIKE THAT LIKE GENERAL HERE
I WAS IN THE MILITARY AND I WAS
A- A MEDIC- BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT PRACTICE IN THE MILITARY-
IS QUITE DIFFERENT AND IT'S MORE
LIKE WHAT WHAT YOU CAN DO YOU
GET TO DO- SO. WE HAVE DONE FINE
IN THE ARMED FORCES BEING ABLE
TO CARRY OUT THE MISSION.
OFTENTIMES BEING ABLE TO MAKE DO
WITH WHAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE- SO
I WOULD YOU KNOW AT A DEEP
RESPECT FOR THE NURSES IN THE
PROFESSION. I THINK THIS IS
ANOTHER STEP WE CAN TAKE FORWARD
TO INCREASE ACCESS. AND I WOULD
MOVED ABILITY PROTECT. OKAY
BILLS AND MOVE AYE SIR EGGMAN.
CHIRLA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING BILL FORWARD I WOULD
ASK. THAT HE REDOUBLED HIS
EFFORTS AND OF HAVE ANOTHER
CONVERSATION OR TO WITH THOSE
WHO STATED SOME OPPOSITION BASED
ON THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE DONOR
SAFETY- AT LEAST IN SOME PARTS
OF THE STATE PERHAPS THE ROLLER
IS IT'S BEEN MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUES. I AM HEARTENED BY
THE FACT THAT I. IF I HEARD MY
YORK HER FRIENDS CIVILIAN LABOR
TODAY INDICATE THAT THERE IS A
SHORTAGE OF NURSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THEY'RE
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO FIX THAT
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY THOSE OF
US IN. ANOTHER COMMITTEE HERE IN
THE SENATE HAVE HEARD TO THE
CONTRARY THAT BY SOME IN THE
PROFESSION AND SOME IN LABOR
THAT THERE IS NO WORK TWENTY
FOUR SHORTAGE. AND NO SHORTAGE
OF NURSES IN THE STATE CURRENTLY
IN IN FACT- TO HAVE UTILIZE THAT
CERTAINLY IN THE PAST TO LIMIT
THE PRODUCTION OF NURSES IN OUR
NURSING SCHOOL SO. PERHAPS WE'VE
NOW UNIFIED OUTSIDE THIS
BUILDING. ON THE THOUGHT THAT
THERE IS A SHORTAGE AND WE WILL
START CURING THAT. SHORTAGE BY
THE PRODUCTION OF. VALUABLE
NURSES TO WORK TO SERVE THE
POPULATION OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WHEN THAT
SHORTAGE OF BATES- WE CAN
PERHAPS REVISIT THIS ISSUE. OF
HAVING ARE IN THIS- ED TO BLOOD
DONATION SITES. BUT FOR NOW I
SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK THE
OTHER FOR BRING IT FORWARD. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY FIFTEEN A SEVEN GLAZER- TO
APPRECIATE- YOU BRING THIS BILL
FOR A FULL DISCLOSURE OF BEFORE
I WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE DID
SERVE ON A BOARD OF A BLOOD
BANK- AND- POSITION AND OF
COURSE THOSE FAMILIAR WITH THE-
SAFETY. PROTOCOLS THAT WERE
INVOLVED. IN AND ALSO YOU KNOW
FOR AGAIN MY FRIENDS AND- THE
LABOR COMMUNITY I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED- BUT ULTIMATELY
OF COURSE THOSE CONCERNS NEED TO
BE BACKED UP BY DATA. AND SO I
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO BE LIKE EVERY OTHER
STATE- THAT- WERE. WE CAN BE
UNIQUE- BUT THAT EXPERIENCE AND
ALL THOSE OTHER STATES CAN HELP
INFORM. WHETHER WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE OR NOT.
AND I THINK AT LEAST AND I
APPRECIATE THAT RUBIO'S COMMENTS
LIKE I I'VE BEEN CHALLENGE IN
FINDING THE DATA. SHOWS THAT
DOING THIS IS. RAISES A
SIGNIFICANT SAFETY CONCERN OR
EVEN A MINOR SAY CONCERN IN
ADDITION THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
THIS ACTUALLY UNDER COVERT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC OF BUT- AND WE HAVE NOT
SEEN IT NOT ONLY OF COURSE AND
DRESS THE COUNTRY BUT ALSO
STEVEN HERE IN OUR STATE. I DO
ACKNOWLEDGE AGAIN TESTIMONY OF.
NURSES ASSOCIATION APPRECIATING
THAT- NO IT'S NOT QUITE THE SAME
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR FEWER PATIENTS
SAID CETERA SO MAYBE IT'S LESS
LIKELY WILL PICK SOMETHING UP
BUT WE STILL HAVEN'T SEEN THE
SAFETY SIGNAL COMING UP SANDERS
A- PERSON OF CONSENT TO CONCERN.
I THINK THAT'S I THINK THAT'S
THE CHALLENGE FOR- THE
OPPOSITION IS THAT IF YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY IF THERE IS. A SIGN OF
A SAFETY CONCERN THEN CERTAINLY
WE WANT TO ADDRESS THAT AND WE
WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE MITIGATE
THAT AND WE WILL BE DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER STATES IF THAT'S
WHAT'S NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
PROTECT HIS ADDRESS AT SAFETY.
BUT THIS POINT HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGED IN TERMS OF FINDING
THAT CONCERN. AND SO WITH THAT-
WILL BE SUPPORTING- THIS BILL
TODAY AND- SENATE GLAZER WHICH
I'D LIKE TO CLOSE THE TICKET AT
CHAIR PAN AND MEMBERS FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION. I AM
THAT I AM ALSO A DONOR- MANY
MANY MANY TIMES. I THINK
PATIENTS TO SAFETY REALLY IS THE
DRIVER FOR THIS AND ALL OF OUR
HEALTH POLICY. AND IF THERE WAS
SAID DATA PROVIDED THAT SHOWS
THERE WAS ANY ENHANCE RISK I
THINK WE WOULD ALL TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY. BUT THERE IS NO DATA
THAT SHOWS THAT THERE IS A
CONCERN- I WOULD NOTE THAT- IN
THE STAFF ANALYSIS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE STAFF FOR DOING AN
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS ON PAGE TWO.
THE TALKS ABOUT THE CRITERIA FOR
DONATIONS AND ONE OF THEM DEALS
WITH IF THERE WAS TO BE AN
ADVERSE REACTION THIS REPLY TO A
RURAL AREA. THAT- THERE TO HELP
THE NEED TO BE FILLED NO MORE
THAN FIFTEEN MINUTES AWAY. SO
THAT STANDARD IS APPLIED
APPLICABLES WHEREVER IT THAT
DOES DONATIONS- ARE HAPPENING.
AND I THINK THAT THAT SHOULD GO
DOWN A LONG WAYS TO MAKING
PEOPLE COMFORTABLE THAT- THAT
THAT THE STANDARD WOULD BE IN
PLACE. THAT SAFETY STAND WOULD
BE IN PLACE- THE THESE FOLKS
THAT ARE DOING BLOOD DONOR THE
RED AND I THERE THEY'RE NOT
PROFIT MAY GROUPS HERE THERE
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THE FOR THE
COMMUNITY FOR PATIENT SAFETY
AND- I APPRECIATE THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND AS WE ALL DO-
THIS BILL REALLY IS BEST IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE CAN HAVE
LIFESAVING CARE THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE AND WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT VOTE. COULD THANK YOU-
SO ACTUALLY IT'S ON SECOND THE
BILL THING THIS. THE MOVE OF
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER OFTEN
OKAY SO THE MOTIONS TO PASS ITS
AMENDED- TAKEN BY CENTRE RAFI-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. PAN HI CAN I AM MELINDA'S
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ GROVE
RICARDO HURTADO AYE LEYVA. LEAVE
A NOTE LEÓN. ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
OKAY THE BILL CERTAINLY- SIX ONE
AND- WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU IF YOU
AND I SEE CENTER VECTORS HERE-
SO LET'S MOVE NOW ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB FOURTEEN NINETEEN
BY CENTER FACTORS. THANK YOU A
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- PERSONALLY
SIX AT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
LIST ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE
COMMITTEE. ANALYSIS ONE OF THE
MOST SACROSANCT RELATIONSHIPS IN
OUR SOCIETIES BETWEEN A PATIENT
AND A PHYSICIAN. IN SUCH A
RELATIONSHIP PATIENTS CAN
CONSULT WITH A PHYSICIAN ON
PRIVATE MATTERS ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH AND RECEIVE A FREE FLOW
OF INFORMATION AND HIGH QUALITY
CARE. TAILORED TO THEIR NEEDS.
OVER THE SHARING OF PATIENT
HEALTH INFORMATION WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT PHYSICIAN
CONSULTATION AND PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS CAN HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT. THIS CAN
HAPPEN BECAUSE FEDERAL
INFORMATION BLOCKING RULES
REQUIRE PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS TO RELEASE PATIENT
DATA AS SOON AS IT'S AVAILABLE.
THANK FOR THE FEDERAL RULE
DIFFERS TO STATE LAW HELLO
CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO BALANCE THE GOAL PROVIDING
PATIENT ACCESS INFORMATION WHAT
PARTICULAR PRIVACY IN A HEARING
TO THEIR WISHES. THIS BILL AS A
NEW PATIENT PROTECTIONS IN A
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT WILSHIRE
PATIENTS RECEIVE CHALLENGING
HEALTH INFORMATION. IN THE TIME
AND MATTER THAT WORKS BEST FOR
THEM. THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND RECEIVE NO RICHARD
OPPOSITION. I THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY. VIRGIN I VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU CENTER VECTOR- WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES- WENT IN
PERSON AND ONE ON THE PHONE- I
DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE YOU WANT TO
TAKE FIRST SERVICE GOT MCDONALD
HERE IN PERSON OKAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO ITS FIRST BEGAN WITH US
SCOTT MCDONNELL- WELCOME AND
THEN YOU HAVE. TWO MINUTES AND
THEN- TOTAL FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN
THE TWO SO YOU RUN OVER THE TWO
MINUTE WARNING YOU'RE TAKING
TIME AWAY FROM THE OTHER
WITNESSES SO WELCOME STATUS
WELCOME BACK TO THE FINALS WILL
TRY T BE RESPECTFUL THANK YOU.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SCOTT MCCONNELL TIME- GENERAL
INTERNIST AND CLINICAL
INFORMATICS IS ONE OF THE NEWEST
MEDICAL SPECIALTIES. AND I WORK
AT UC DAVIS IS THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OF ELECTRONIC. HEALTH
RECORDS. TO TESTIFYING TO OF
THIS BILL TODAY NINE. AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN I DON'T
REPRESENT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS CASE- I'VE
BEEN ADVOCATE FOR SHARING
PATIENT MEDICAL RECORDS WITH
PATIENTS FOR MANY YEARS- AND SO
I KNOW HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
ONE TWO THREE FIVE ONE FOUR
EIGHT VERY WELL- AS I'VE BEEN.
HELPING IMPLEMENT IN OUR
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM
FOR MANY YEARS- THE LAST TWO
YEARS HAVE BEEN THE MOST COMPLEX
OF THE WHOLE TIME AS WE'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING THE FEDERAL
INFORMATION BLOCKING REGULATIONS
AND TRYING TO MARRY THOSE
AGAINST THE CALIFORNIA STATE
REGULATIONS IN THIS. HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE- IT'S INTERESTING
THAT THE PAST YEARS THAT CODE
WAS SORT OF A BARRIER TO WHAT WE
COULD A RELEASE TO PATIENTS WHEN
WE WANTED TO SHARE INFORMATION
INCREASINGLY CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATIONS ARE LOOKING TO
CALIFORNIA STATE LINE TO HELP US
CAV X. EXCEPTIONS TO NOT SHARE
PATIENT DATA IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
OF THE FEDERAL INFORMATION
BLOCKING RULE AND THAT RULE IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE STRICT
LATER THIS YEAR WE'RE HAVING TO
SHARE EVEN MORE INFORMATION WITH
PATIENTS IMMEDIATELY. FOR THREE
DIFFERENT ROUTES AS WELL. SO I
REALLY DO STRONGLY FEEL THAT
PATIENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO THIS
DATA BUT AS PHYSICIANS ALSO HAVE
A DUTY THE SACROSANCT DUTY TO
PROVIDE THEM CONTEXT MEANING IN
SUPPORT- ALONG WITH THAT
INFORMATION CERTAINLY WHEN IT'S
INFORMATION THAT'S REALLY LIFE
ALTERING TO PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE CURRENT LAW
ADDRESSES CASES OF CANCER THAT
TURN UP ON ISSUES ROUTINELY
PROCESSED BY THE BIOPSIES AND
PAP SMEARS IN THE LAKE. IT
DOESN'T REALLY ADDRESS- CANCERS
THAT MAY APPEAR ON AN IMAGING
SCAN- IT ALSO DOESN'T REALLY
ADDRESS GENETIC INFORMATION THAT
CAN LEAD TO- THAT IT CAN ALSO BE
LIFE CHANGING FOR FAMILIES-
CARRILLO WAS INITIALLY WRITTEN
BACK WHEN WE HAD DIAL UP
INTERNET. COMPUTERS WERE BIG
BEIGE BOXES. AND NOW MOST
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SUPER
COMPUTERS IN THEIR POCKETS AND
ALWAYS INTERNET CONNECT LIVE
CONNECTIONS AND THEIR-
CONNECTIONS TO THE WORLD. IN
THIS TRANSFORMATION AND HEALTH
RECORDS BEEN NO LESS DRAMATIC
WORRIES HAVE WALLS OF PAPER
CHARTS- NOW WE HAVE REAL TIME
ACCESS TO OUR OWN INFORMATION
ACROSS THE INTERNET. AND ABLE TO
HAVE- INTERACTIONS WITH OUR
PROVIDERS AND RETAIN. DIRECTLY
CLOSE TO REAL TIME SOMETIMES-
ALSO ELECTRONIC SECURITY AND
PRIVACY IS LIGHT YEARS AHEAD OF
WHERE IT WAS BACK IN THE
NINETIES WHEN THIS BILL WAS
INITIALLY WRITTEN. SO I THINK
IT'S TIME TO THOROUGHLY MEET THE
NEEDS OF PATIENTS PROVIDERS AND
HEALTH SYSTEMS BY A CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA LAW TO PERMIT
FLEXIBILITY FOR COMMITTEE
HORATIAN IN OUR SYSTEMS. MARCIN
MISUNDERSTAND WE CAN COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL REGULATIONS WHILE
ENSURING LIFE ALTERING
INFORMATION RELEASES HAPPEN IN A
TIMELY FASHION BUT STILL WITH
THE GUIDANCE AND THE SUPPORT OF
THEIR DOCTORS. OKAY THANK YOU-
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR OTHER
WITNESS ON THE PHONE- DR SHANNON
WHO A CONSTANT I THINK YOU GOT A
LITTLE OVER A MINUTE. ME THERE'S
A CHANCE YOU'RE A CONFLICT AT
THIS TIME BUT WILL TO QUICKLY
SEE IF SHE'S THERE. OKAY
MODERATOR YEAH CAN YOU SEE IF
DOCTOR SHANNON IT A CONSTANT IS
AVAILABLE. I CURRENTLY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THEM. OKAY YEAH WE
GOT WERE THERE MIGHT WITH THIS
SPECIFIC TIME THERE MIGHT BE
HAVE BEEN ISSUE SO OKAY SO OPENS
THE DOORS- THEN MOVE ON AND
THEN- SO WILL TAKE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT TODAY HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. GEORGE
SOURIS OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS A PROUD SPONSOR
OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING MICROPHONE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHICH TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FOURTEEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOURTEEN NINETEEN WE HAVE NO
FORMAL REGISTERED OPPOSITION FOR
TESTIMONY IS THERE ANY ANY
WITNESSES HEARING ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED THAT WE SHOULD THAT'S
FINE OPPOSITION. FIVE THREE P.
MY NAME YES A CENTURY FROM SAN
AYE OPPOSED- THIS BILL OKAY
THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING MICROPHONES-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANY WITNESSES WHO TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO STAY IN OPPOSITION TO ASK THE
FOURTEENTH NINETEEN. FIFTY FOUR
ONE ZERO AT THE FIVE. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WELL IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SERRA. OKAY SERVICE
SCENE NO ONE- CENTER VECTOR YOU
BRING THIS BILL FORD WITH IN
TERMS OF THE SPECIALLY IN TERMS
OF ARE IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS
ARE ONLY FUNDED HEALTH THE STATE
EXCHANGES AND INFORMATION- WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
HER STRICTLY ASTRONOMICAL OKAY
THANK YOU- SO- IT'S BEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY IT'S BEEN SECONDED BY
SENATOR ROB- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN I CAN I AM
MELINDA. EGGMAN EGGMAN ARKANSAS
. GROVE HER TADO FURTADO I LEYVA. RUBIO AYE WIENER OKAY A BILL
CURRENTLYHAS FIVE VOTES SIX
FIVE ZERO OR HOLD THE ROLE OF
CONTRAST NUMBERS THANKS OKAY I
GUESS WE'RE WAITING FOR FINAL
AUTHOR SILICON LARGER THAN THE
MEANTIME I DO KNOW WE HAVE SOME
MEMBERS HERE WHO PERHAPS CAN
BENEFIT FROM LIFTING THE CALL SO
I'M JUST GOING TO GO THROUGH
LIFT BECAUSE- BILL SO WE'LL-
FOLLOW ORDER SO BEGIN WITH THAT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO THREE NINE TWO
THREE BY CENTER WIENER
CONSULTANTS- PLEASE- THE THAT
PLEASE COP AFTER MEMBERS. YES SB
NINETY THREE SB NINETY THREE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO
HI OKAY THAT BILL CURRENTLY HAS
NINE ZERO WILL PUT THE BILL BACK
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B.
TEN THIRTY FIVE BY CENTER EGGMAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE- CAUGHT THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ
MELINDA'S HI GONZALEZ GROVE HER
TADO HER TOTAL FIVE RUBIO RUBIO
AYE WIENER. OKAY THAT BILLS
CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO FOR THE
BILL BACK ON CALL LET'S DO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SP ONE. TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
THE FILM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
HI GONZALEZ GROVE HER TADO. HI
HER TITLE BY RUBIO HI RUBIO HI.
OKAY- SO THAT'S CURRENTLY NINE
ZERO WILL PUT THE BILL BACK ON
CALL. LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO
BY SIR CAPPIELLO AND SKINNER-
CONSULT PLEASE CALL OUT THE ROLE
OF ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ
GROVE HER TADO. LIMON. OKAY SO
THAT BILL STILL IS CURRENTLY SIX
ONE AND- WILL PUT THE BELT BACK
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- WILL
STILL WAITING FOR CENTER
COMMODITY PAYER ITEM NUMBER
NINE. I'M SORRY THE NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE OKAY- ACTUALLY
PLENTY OF AND WE'LL COME BACK
WELL IS THERE. AND LET'S MOVE ON
TO ITEM THE TEN AS BEFORE NINETY
BY SO BACK. I CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT. MELENDEZ
MELINDA'S KNOW GONZALEZ. LIMON
WE RIGHT WIENER AYE OKAY LET
BILLS FOR- SEVEN ONE AND THE
BILL BACK ON CALL. THEM MOVE THE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN FOUR SEP FIVE
PLACE AND WILL. CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELINDA'S MELINDA I CONCERN.
GROVE LIMÓN. OKAY THAT BILLS SO
ONE PUT THE BILL BACK ON. WINDS
FOR SOME. ASSEMBLY. TEN THIRTY
FIVE. OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW
TO GO BACK TO ITEM THE SIX
THAT'S TEN THIRTY FIVE I CENTER
EGGMAN- LIVE THE CALL AGAIN ON I
AM SIX SB TEN THIRTY FIVE
EASTERN- CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THAT'S MEMBERS GONZALEZ
GROVE WINNER WINNER BY OKAY THAT
BILLS CURRENTLY NINE WILL THE
BILL. ON COST ALL RIGHT SO- THIS
POINT WE'RE WAITING FOR CENTER
WATER- I KNOW IS ALSO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SELL- YES HELLO SO YES
WE DO HAVE THE CAL SORRY- DID
YOU ARE YOU OKAY SO LET'S LOOK
AT ON THE CAN CALENDAR DICK
CENTER. ON ONE I KNOW ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS B. TEN THREE. I
CONSULT PLEASE CALL OUT THE OF
APPS MEMBERS FOR CONSENT
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I CAN SEE
GREW FURTADO FURTADO BY RUBIO.
RUBIO HI OKAY THAT SAID
CURRENTLY NINE IS COULD THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR ON CALL
HOUSE MEMBERS. OKAY. I SHE'S
HERE. YEAH SERICA MARKER WELCOME
SO WE ON ITEM NUMBER NINE S. B.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WELCOME-
APOLOGIES. MEMBERS CAN MISTER
CHAIR. AND I AM HAPPY TO BE HERE
. THE TONIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I AM HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT. SB TWELVE FORTY FIVE
THE L. A. COUNTY ABORTION ACCESS
SAFE HAVEN PILOT PROGRAM. SENATE
BILL TWELVE FORTY FIVE WILL
SUPPORT OF FUNDED PILOT PROGRAM
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO BUILD
ON THESTATEWIDE EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE CALIFORNIA'S A
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE. THE
PROGRAM WILL HOUSE INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES AND PATIENT CENTERED
COLLABORATIONS TO SAFEGUARD
ACCESS TO ABORTION FOR PATIENTS
COMING TO LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE PATIENT
RESIDES. THIS YEAR THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT IS
REVIEWING A DIRECT CHALLENGE TO
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
ABORTION ESTABLISHED IN ROE V.
WADE. SHOULD THE COURT UPHOLD
MISSISSIPPI'S BAN THEREBY
OVERTURNING ROE THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN PEOPLE IN OVER
HALF OF THE STATES IN THE
COUNTRY OVER THIRTY SIX MILLION
WOMEN AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO MAY
BECOME PREGNANT WILL LOSE ACCESS
TO ABORTION CARE. IT IS ALREADY
HAPPENING PEOPLE IN TEXAS HAVE
BEEN DENIED PROTECTIONS UNDER
ROW SINCE THE STATE'S EXTREME
ABORTION BAN WENT INTO EFFECT
LAST YEAR. ACCORDING TO A REPORT
RELEASED BY THE GOT MARKER
INSTITUTE THE NUMBER OF OUT OF
STATE PATIENTS WHO WOULD FIND
THEIR NEAREST ABORTION PROVIDER
IN CALIFORNIA FROM FORTY SIX
THOUSAND TO ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION AN INCREASE OF NEARLY
THREE THOUSAND PERCENT. L. A.
COUNTY ACCOUNTS FOR OVER A THIRD
OF ALL ABORTIONS THAT TAKE PLACE
IN CALIFORNIA THE PREVALENCE OF
ABORTION IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IN PARTICULAR LIKELY REFRESH
REFLECTS BETTER ACCESS IN THE
CITY IN OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN OTHER STATES
IN THE NATION. THIS PREVALENCE
COUPLED WITH THE COUNTY IS ROLE
AS A MAJOR. MY TROP METROPOLIS
TRANSPORTATION HUB WITH MULTIPLE
AIRPORTS MAKES IT HIGHLY LIKELY
THAT NON RESIDENTS WILL COME THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR THE
ABORTION CARE THAT THEY WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO ACCESS IN THEIR HOME
STATE OR KIND OF COUNTY.
CURRENTLY L. A. COUNTY HAS
ALREADY MADE EVIDENT COMMITMENTS
TO HEALTH EQUITY. THE COUNTY HAS
A RECORD OF SUCCESSFUL
INNOVATIONS IN CARE COORDINATION
THROUGH PROGRAMS SUCH AS MY
MENTAL HEALTH. L. A. ECON SOLD
SYSTEMS LANES HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE AND THE WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOT PROGRAMS. WHICH ARE
NOW INFORMING CAL AIMS STATEWIDE
EFFORTS. BUILDING UPON THE L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
RESOLUTION OF BUILDING A COUNTY
WIDE RESPONSE TO THE POTENTIAL
OVERTURN OF ROE V. WADE. SB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WOULD FUND AND
SUPPORT A PILOT PROGRAM APPROACH
TO CARE THAT IS RESPONSIVE. TO
THE IMPENDING NEEDS OF PEOPLE
SEEKING ABORTION CARE. HE
FUNDING AREAS FOR THE PILOT
PROGRAM WILL INCLUDE SERVICES
THAT PRIORITIZE EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE AND IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES. COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES
STREAMLINED AND SECURE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO COORDINATE
CARE AND OTHER PATIENTS SUPPORT
SERVICES. PATIENT ACCESS TOOLS
TO EMPOWER PATIENTS TO OVERCOME
BARRIERS TO CARE. MEDICALLY
ACCURATE. EDUCATION AND TRAINING
TOOLS SPECIFIC TO COMMUNITY
NEEDS WITH IN THE COUNTING. AND
PATIENT COMMUNITY OUT REACH TO
ASSESS COUNTY SERVICES. WITH
ABORTION RIGHTS ALREADY A
ROADING IN NUMEROUS STATES. IN
THE FUTURE OF ROE V. WADE
HANGING IN THE BALANCE NOW IS
THE TIME TO PUT FORWARD
INNOVATIVE INVESTMENTS IN
ABORTION ACCESS. WITH ME HERE IN
SUPPORT IS SELINA VAZQUEZ CHIEF
EXTERNAL OFFICER FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES AND
ONYEMA OVIE KIA. POLICY ANALYST
FROM BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS
ACTION PROJECT AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
US ERICOM LAGER- AND I BELIEVE
BOTH ARE GOING TO BE JOINING US
BY PHONE SO MODERATOR- PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE CELINDA VAST
QUIZ FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS
ANGELES AND- YEAH- BECAUSE- OF
THE BLACK. WELLNESS BUT WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS ACTION- BECAUSE
WILL BEGIN WITH CELINDA VAST
QUEST YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES-
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER O.
THAT'S BECAUSE IF YOU GO OVER
THAT'S GOING TO BE TIME AWAY
FROM THE SECOND WITNESS. SHASTA
CYLINDER THAT'S BECAUSE PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU HAVE AG GOOD
ACTORS SEEMS MOST. ACTIVE
MEMBERS- IF YOU CAME IN THAT
PACKAGE AND TO KEEP IT. THEIR
PLATFORMS ACCOLADE. AND WE- OF
LOS ANGELES RED AND OVER HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND THAT THAT A YEAR
I THINK YOU'RE A LOAN WE SEEN
HUNDRED ABORTION REACHED. IN
FIFTIES AND FORTY EIGHT THREE A
BAN AT BEING. ENACTED IN ARIZONA
IDAHO AND WYOMING- UNITED LIKE
MISSOURI LAWMAKERS ARE TAKING AN
EVEN MORE ATTRACTIVE APPROACH
ATTEMPTING TO BAN RESIDENTS-
GIVE ME- THE BALLOT RESIDENTS
FROM LEAVING THE STATE PAYMENTS
UNDER PORTION. I EDITED
ESTIMATED THAT IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS OVER THIRTY SIX MILLION
PEOPLE VOTE IN OVER HALF OF
STATE IN OUR COUNTRY PEOPLE LOSE
ACCESS TO ABORTION IN THEIR
HOMES EIGHT. LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS HOME TO ALMOST THIRTY PER OF
THE STATE. THE NEXT FOR A THIRD
OF ALL. OF THE AFFORD THAT YOU
TAKE IN CALIFORNIA AND- FIFTY.
HOLD WITH THE COUNTY WILL THE
MAJOR METROPOLITAN AS SENATORS
EIGHT IT. CONFRONTATION WITH MY
VOEPEL. MAKE IT HIGHLY THAT. NON
RESIDENTS WILL COME FLOCKING
ANGELES COUNTY FOR PORTION
SERVICES. THAT THE COMPLETE
CANNOT AND HOME. AFTER WHO
WATCHES EACH. AN INCREASE IN OF
PATIENTS TRAVEL TO FANATIC STATE
IN PARTICULAR AFTER THAT. ACTIVE
HE CAN. IN FACT- ONE HAS
TRAVELLED- USING A BY WAY OF
BURKE. HI IF IT DIFFICULT HI FOR
PATIENTS- IT IS DIFFICULT TIME.
FOR A PORTION ACCESS AND WE ARE
PREPARING FOR THE OF PATIENTS
COMING TO OUR STATE- CALIFORNIA
AND KNOCKED DOWN. BUILDING YOU
SEE GAVE WILL ENSURE THAT WATER.
COUNTY AND PREPARED IF THIRTY
TWO- EVEN FURTHER DELAY I THINK
THEY'RE COMMITTED- FURTHER
FORECLOSURE AND IN JANUARY TWO
MINUTES OUT PRODUCTIVE.
HEALTHCARE HATE THEM. MY OVER
TEN IT'S A SOME YES YOUR TO THE
NEXT WITNESS. I WILL I WILL
RESPECTFUL AND ALLOW MY CALL AT
IT MIGHT MIGHT MY COLLEAGUE I
THINK OF THE FACT URGE IN HIGH
FLOW FROM THAT CRITICAL BILL
HADN'T. ARE YOU TIRED TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU LET'S NOT
MOVE ON TO A YELLOW WEEK OF FROM
THE WOMAN THE SPECS PROJECT YOU
HAVE A MINUTE FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARES COMMITTEE THANK
YOU DEFENDING THAT I. AM LOOKING
YEAH I WAS LUCKY WOMAN WHERE
BECAUSE OF NEW REGULATIONS AND
IT COULD BE YOUR PROBLEM THAT IT
WILL BE IN A BLACK WOMEN AND
GIRLS. WE HAVE OFFICES IN LA IN
BOSTON AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG CONFESSION CALLED
THIRTY FIVE WHICH BILL WILL.
MARK A SIGNIFICANT REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM IS AN EFFORT TO PROTECT. EQUITABLE AT. TO FULL SPECTRUM
OF THE COULD TO BE SEXUAL HEALTH
CARE. A FOUR. FORTY LARGER
COUNTY WITH. FOR THAT THE TWO.
THANK. WE'VE HEARD WILL PUT YOUR
THIRTY DRAMATIC ROLLED BCK
EXACTLY RIGHT COUNTRY AND- HELP
. HOW DID. AND A HALF AND CALL
OF THE RESIDUAL SUGAR BY THE
REALITY IS THAT MANY OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY BLACK. BEAUTY BLACK
FEDERAL TAX THE WRESTLING
REPRODUCTIVE ACTUAL HOPE FOR
SERVICE DELIVERY. YES TO MAKE
DECISIONS HELP. FOR
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTUAL
HEALTHCARE INCLUDING ABORTION
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
WORKING PEOPLE SHOULD NOT ONLY
BE ABLE TO DECIDE. WHETHER OR
NOT CONTINUE. ALL WHO ENJOY OUR
TO CARE REFORM. QUARTER MMHM A
ROW ABOUT INNOVATIVE APPROACH
AND TO ADDRESS WILL NEXT BE WITH
THE ACTUAL HELP OUTCOMES THE
FACT. WHAT FOR APPROACH IS TO
PREPARE THE INCREASED CARE
NEEDED FOR THE COMING PLACE WRAP
UP INCREASING THE LANDSCAPE
MUSIC WITH THE DJ AT THE BASE
INCLUDE COLLABORATIONS WITH
THANK WITH FOLDER PLEASE COME
VISION. I THANK YOU. OKAY THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR YOUR OVERTIME APOLOGY BUT
YOU OVERTIME THANK YOU SIR MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WILL AT TAKE
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL TO. FROM
PEOPLE ARE AT IN ROOM TWELVE
NAME WORKSTATION POSITION. ST OY
APPROACHING THE MIKE- WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO TELL IF FIND MY-
PLEASE OPEN LINES WITNESSES WHO
TEST. IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
FORTY FIVE NAME OR- A POSITION.
THAK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN CALIFORNIA AT THAT BEFORE WE
BEGIN THERE IS ONE PERSON'S
APPROACH THAT HEARING ROOM
TWELVE HUNDREDS. SORRY MY ROPES
AND PLANNED FOR IT HAD A FLEET
OF CALIFORNIA WERE CO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. I APOLOGIZE
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO TELEPHONIC LINE SO LEASE
DON'T HANG IN THERE- YET
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE- NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
APOLOGIZE MODERATOR BUT PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO THIS WAS
TESTIFYING SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR FORTY FIVE THE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO ONE FIVE. FIND FIFTEEN
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY
MEMBERS AARON EVAN BOND WE HAVE
THE WRONG APPROACH WAY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO FIGHT FOR DR THIS
IS SUPPORT THANK. YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. YOU'RE RIGHT FORTY
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
HELLO- WITH HEALTH FULLY FOR
FUND. AND FORMER DEFENSE HE
WANTS TO FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NICK WITNESS. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER THANK YOU. OKAY
THANKS VERY A WELL KNOWN MOVE ON
WITNESS AND OP. TO TWELVE FORTY
FIVE WE HAVE- TWO WITNESSES
REGISTERED. HER TESTIMONY- SUSAN
R. NELSON RIGHT TO LIFE PLEASE
COME BACK AND THEN ALSO
GEORGIANA BUT AS FOR THE
ARCHDIOCESE OF LOS ANGELES. SO
AGAIN YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES IF
YOU GO OVER IT TAKES AWAY TIME
FROM THE SECOND WITNESS TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES- WELCOME. MY NAME
IS SUSAN AREN'T ALL AS I'VE TOLD
YOU BEFORE I'M A CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY I'M WITH THE RIGHT TO
LIFE LEAGUE WE ARE BASED IN LOS
ANGELES. SB TWELVE FORTY FIVE
ALTHOUGH FACIALLY NEUTRAL WILL
DISPARATE LEE IMPACT MINORITIES
AS THE BILL ITSELF STATES IT IS
HOME 228% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION. BUT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALREADY ACCOUNTS FOR MORE
THAN ONE THIRD OF ALL ABORTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA. MOST ABORTION
FACILITIES IN L. A. COUNTY ARE
LOW INCOME HI MY NORTE AREAS.
AND GUTMACHER INSTITUTE
STATISTICS SHOW THAT BLACKS AND
HISPANICS ARE FAR MORE LIKELY
THAN ANY OTHER RACE OR ETHNICITY
TO HAVE AN ABORTION. WE AS A
NATION CAN NOT AND SHOULD NOT
IGNORE RACISM IN OUR HISTORY.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S FOUNDER
MARGARET SANGER WAS AN ADMITTED
QUITE SUPREMACIST. HER STATED
PURPOSE WAS TO PROMOTE BIRTH
CONTROL AND ABORTION FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR. SAYING A
REFERRED TO BLACK AMERICANS
IMMIGRANTS AND INDIGENOUS
AMERICANS AND I QUOTE. AS HUMAN
BEINGS WHO NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN BORN. I AM NOT SAYING AND I
DO NOT INTENDED TO IMPLY THAT
THE AUTHORS OF PRO ABORT BILLS
TRAVELING THROUGH OUR
LEGISLATURE ARE RACIST OR
INTENTIONALLY PROMOTING A RACIST
AGENDA HOWEVER. BY PLACING MORE
ABORTION FACILITIES IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE UNDENIABLY FOLLOWS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD'S EUGENIC ROOTS
MARGARET SANGER WOULD BE
THRILLED. MOREOVER JUST LIKE SB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO. S. B. TWELVE
FORTY FIVE IS ONE SIDED IN ITS
FUNDING AND IT'S FUNNY CALL
FINANCIAL SUPPORT OF ABORTION
OVER CHILDBIRTH IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PURSUANT TO THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE CASE
COMMITTEE TO DEFEND REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS VERSUS MYERS. THANK YOU
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
GEORGINA VITIS FROM THE
ARCHDIOCESE'S ACCOUNT OF LOS
ANGELES ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATE PLEASE BRING RON AND-
THREE BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN COUNCIL MEMBERS OF THE
HELP COMMITTEE I MEAN. I'M A
RESIDENT OF HOMES WILL BE A
MOTHER OF A ONE YEAR OLD. FIFTY
FOUR FORTY FIVE NOT FOR MY
COMMUNITY. WOMEN IN MY COMMUNITY
ONCE THE MOM YES ANOTHER THING I
NEED A LITTLE EXTRA HELP IF YOU
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU FOR A
BETTER FUTURE FUNDING. IN OUR
THINKING WISHING OF COURSE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. I THINK THAT
WOULD HELP. BUT WE NEEDED A
PORTABLE HOUSING IN A FIFTY
HEALTHCARE GOT MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE COUNTY HAD
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND PREGNANT
WOMEN FREAKING HOME THE FULL
THIRTY THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE. THOUSANDS OF
STRUGGLING FAMILIES THAT'S WHAT
WE HELP WITH. CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO WOMEN IN MY COMMUNITY.
TELL ME WHEN WE DON'T WANT THESE
PEOPLE I'M PAYING YOU ARE OFF
THE YEAR BEFORE. OTHER THAN
ABORTION. NATURISM OFFENSES THAT
PORTION. THAT'S NOT OFFERED.
SOLUTION WHEN GET A BUCKET ALL
HAVE TO I THANK YOU FOR HIS
RETURN THE STATE YOU CAN FOR
LIVING THE STREETS DIRECTOR THE
THING BECAUSE BILL MAKING IT
PROPERTY AND THAT'S NOT. IT FAIR
TO OFFER A BOY IS THE ONLY
SOLUTION FOR. WOMEN I WANT A
FORTY OF. I'M NOT TO WORK.
MOTHERS DON'T WANT WANTED WHAT
THE **** THAT SHE AND HER IN
RIGHT GATHER. ARE YOU HALF A
QUESTION FOR OF A- MY FOR FREE
FROM THE PROVIDERS AND YET HELLO
HOW. WE DON'T NEED OF COURSE OF
WHAT WE NEEDED HELP WITH THAT
TECHNIQUE BOB VERIFY AND BRIGHT
. WE WILL INCOME WOMEN WOMEN OF
DESERVE AND HOW YOU NORMALLY.
THE PROBLEM WE FACE FOR THE WEEK
YES AND NO A SB FIVE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
THIS MURDER SPELL THANK YOU.
MALAYSIAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JENNIFER MILBORNE WITH ABORTION
SURVIVORS NETWORK I SURVIVED MAY
BIRTH MOM'S ABORTION ATTEMPT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
RIVER THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. BUSKERS OR IN A FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
IT OPPOSES BONE UPTAKE USING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MANY
INNOCENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. CHEYENNE KENNY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LAUREN THE BU I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ELIZABETH KENNY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JONATHAN KELLER WITH CALIFORNIA
FAMILY ALLIANCE IN THE
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN BAPTIST
CONVENTION OPPOSING THE BILL
THANK YOU CENOVUS SAID THE
MICROPHONE HERE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED- MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE THESE PRESS ONE. ZERO AT
THE TIME. WHY FOR SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES NAY MORE VISION
POSITION OF. YES MY NAME IS
SANDRA MARQUEZ I AM A ****
COUNTY RESIDENT AND MEMBER OF
THE COUNTY FREEDOM COALITION AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS SYSTEM
THANK YOU'RE RIGHT TO NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS HOGAN I CAN MOTHER TO
REPORTED COUNTY. AND IT IS
MURDER I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT.
TWELVE FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU
KNOW WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M AT
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIVE.
EIGHT FIVE. BY TWO THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME
. YES NAY MOTIVATION PASILLO.
PLEASE ENTER YESTERDAY MARINO
ALAMEDA COUNTY. AN AREA CODES.
THIS YOU GUYS THROW AWAY I THINK
SO THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU RYAN FOR FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR FIVE SEVEN.
ME F. REQUIRED. BOBBY HIDDLESTON
BAKER CITY- FORTY FIVE THAT
OFFICE THREE KIDS I DON'T KNOW
THANK YOU THANKS WITNESS. BRIAN
FOR HIS SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS NOEL MILBORNE
FATHER AND HUSBAND A MEMBER OF
THE CARING FOR MOTHERS AND
UNBORN BABY'S MOVEMENT- STRONGLY
OPPOSED THIS THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LINE THIRTY THIRTY ONE
BEFORE I HAVE. FIVE THREE THREE
ONE YES THIS IS. AND SOMEONE WHO
WOULD LIKE MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN THIS WORLD I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU BYE THREE EIGHTY THREE FOR
HER. FIVE THREE EIGHT ZERO.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
STARTED AND GET A NUMBER MY NAME
IS ROBERT TAPERED I'M A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF THE SENATEDISTRICT
ELEVEN LOCATOR WIENER AND I AM
AN ACTIVIST THAT FOR LIFE SEVEN
CISCO AND PROJECT THIS BILL NO
ON SB. TWELVE FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU BYE
FOR SIXTY SIX PEOPLE HAVE. TONY
HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN AT
TWO THIRTY TWO PEOPLE HAVE. FIVE
TWO THREE TWO. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SESSION THE COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIRTY
GROWTH. AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. M. FIRST I DO AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS OF THE FIRST OF
INDIVIDUAL IN OPPOSITION THAT
YOU KNOW MARKET SINGER IF WE'VE
LEARNED YEARS FOR YEARS THAT SHE
WAS A WHITE SUPREMACIST AND SHE
DID IT SHE DID FIFTIES ABORTION
CLINICS IN BLACK AND BROWN
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A STATEMENT I KNOW YOU
GUYS GOING TO PASS THIS BILL UP
WITH FLYING COLORS- BUT THERE'S
NO LACK OF ACCESS FOR ABORTIONS
IN LOS ANGELES NOR IS THEIR LACK
OF ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
STATE ALREADY FUNDS ABORTIONS
THROUGH TAX DOLLARS THERE'S OVER
FOUR HUNDRED FACILITIES
PERFORMING ABORTIONS. ABORTIONS
ARE OFFERED BY NURSE
PRACTITIONERS NURSE MIDWIVES
FUSES PHYSICIANS' ASSISTANTS VIA
TELEHEALTH ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
AND THROUGH DOZENS OF SOURCES BY
MAIL. AND TO DO A PILOT PROGRAM
LIKE THIS TO USE ADDITIONAL
TAXPAYER DOLLARS FOR A STATE
RESIDENTS IS- I WOULD SAY A SLAP
IN THE FACE TO CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS- TAXPAYERS
THAT. ARE OBVIOUSLY OVERTAXED AS
IT IS BECAUSE OF THE ABUNDANT
AMOUNT OF SURPLUS THAT WE HAVE.
AND I THINK IT'S AN INEFFICIENT
USE OF OUR RESOURCES NOT ONLY
FOR- THE- FISCAL PEACE BUT THE
MORAL GROUND PLEASE SET THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR TARO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO-
I KNOW THAT THE CONVERSATION
HERE TODAY AROUND THIS BILL IS
LARGELY FOCUSED ON THE PORTION
COMPONENT WHICH YOU KNOW I THINK
. NO ONE SHOULD HAVE ANY SAY
OVER A WOMAN'S OVER A WOMAN'S
BODY. THAT THE WOMAN SHOULD HAVE
A SAY OVER HER OWN BODY. AND
SECOND- THE OTHER. COMPONENTS OF
THE BILL THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE IS- THE INCREASE.
APPROVING ACCESS TO THE FULL
SPECTRUM OF SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH I MEAN LOOK WHAT WE'RE
COMING OUT OF IT PANDEMIC
CRYSTAL IN ONE RIGHT AND WE KNOW
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE. ENGAGE IN
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NOW LET ME
WE HAVE AN INCREASE IN GONORRHEA
AN INCREASE IN SYPHILIS WE HAVE-
JUST A NEED FOR. IMPROVING
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE CARE AS
WELL AND SO. I KNOW THE FOCUS
HAS BEEN ON THE ABORTION PIECE
BUT WE GOT A LOOK AT IT AS A
WHOLE AND I THINK THIS BILL.
WILL HELP WITH SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT WILL BE CONTINUING
TO FACE SO. I SUPPORT THE BILL
AND A LITTLE BIT AT THE
PROPONENT VETERAN MOVER CENTER
TILE AND OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER EGGMAN- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CENTER CALLING FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- AND AT.
IF TO ME ON THIS ON THIS DIET
HAS TRIED ACCESS TO AN ABORTION
IN A- IN THE MOST RECENT HISTORY
THEN I GUESS THEY COULDN'T
BEGIN. WITH VERACITY CLAIM THAT
THERE IS NO PROBLEM WITH ACCESS
EARLIER BILL TODAY WE HEARD A
VERY CLEAR PROBLEM WITH ACCESS
THAT SOMEBODY HAD IN LOS
ANGELES- SO MUCH LET'S JUST SAY
THAT. AND I APPRECIATE A LOT OF
WHAT PEOPLE I MEAN AS WE SAID
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF CHOICE AND
ACCESS AND FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
OPPOSING TO OPPOSE. ON TAKING
AWAY SOMEBODY ELSE'S CHOICE
SEEMS TO BE THAN IMPOSING THEIR
FEELINGS ON TO OTHER PEOPLE
WHICH IS AGAINST- MOST THE
THINGS. PEOPLE STAND UP FOR
RIGHT FRIEDMAN CHOICE SELF
DETERMINATION THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS WHICH THIS BILL IS TRYING
TO PROVIDE FOR PEOPLE YOU CAN'T
HAVE A SELF DETERMINATION IF
THERE. IS NO ACCESS. THAT'S LIKE
SAYING THAT NOBODY'S HUNGRY IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE GROW ALL
THIS FOOD WE KNOW THAT'S NOT
TRUE. WE KNOW EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
A RICH AGRICULTURAL STATE WE
STILL HAVE PEOPLE WHO SUFFER
FROM FOOD INSECURITY- SO I WOULD
HAVE MOVED THE BILL IF IT
WASN'T- ALREADY AND I JUST I
ALWAYS HEAR IN MY IN MY MIND-
THE WORDS OF. FLOORS WHERE TO
WHO SAID WHO SAYSJUST BECAUSE I
HAD ELEVEN KIDS DOESN'T MEAN I
THINK EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO I
WAS MY CHOICE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A SIMILAR THIS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- SO. YOUR BILL. SAYS
FUNDS MAY BE USED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF IMPLEMENTING
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED
TO AND THEN IT LISTS AT SIX
DIFFERENT THINGS HERE SO IT'S
THE NOT LIMITED TO PART- THAT
CONCERNS ME BECAUSE THAT'S
BASICALLY OPEN ENDED THAT MEANS
THIS MONEY CAN BE SPENT ON
ANYTHING THAT THE L. A. COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS DECIDES IS
APPROPRIATE THAT PERHAPS TO
TAXPAYERS MIGHT NOT SO FOR
INSTANCE WHEN YOU TALK HERE IN
YOUR BILL ABOUT BUILDING SECURE
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN YOU DEFINE
WHAT YOU MEAN BY THAT. WELL SURE
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE- ATTACKS
MADE AGAINST PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
CLINICS AND FACILITIES WHERE
ABORTIONS ARE ACCESSIBLE. AND
PART OF IT IS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT PATIENTS AND CLINICIANS ARE
SAFE WHEN THEY ARE GOING TO SEEK
CARE IT COULD BE A PORTION CARE
IT COULD BE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE ON THE SPECTRUM. SO WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING THERE IS
BUILDING A FACILITY- THAT IS
SECURE MUCH LIKE THE ONE YOU'RE
IN RIGHT NOW. IS THAT CORRECT.
SO THAT WOULD BE OPEN TO YOUR
POINT THAT THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND A PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS
ANGELES AND THE COMMUNITY WHERE
THE PILOT PROGRAM IS GOING TO
RESOLVE. OKAY COUNTERING
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS- WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN WHAT
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT OR WELL WE KNOW I
HISTORICALLY THERE ARE- THERE'S
PROPAGANDA AGAINST- CLINICS THAT
OFFER ABORTION CARE OR ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE DOCTORS- OF THAT
PROPAGANDA OR IS IT A DIFFERENT
POINT OF VIEW WELL IT'S
MISINFORMATION IF YOU SAY THAT
X. OR Y. COULD HAPPEN IF YOU GO
INTO THAT CLINIC THAT IS
MISINFORMATION. OKAY WELL THAT'S
OPEN TO INTERPRETATION-
PROVIDING MEDICALLY ACCURATE
INFORMATION TO HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS.
PROVIDING MEDICALLY ACCURATE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TOOLS TO
THE COMMUNITY- WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE TO YOU PROVIDING
MEDICALLY ACCURATE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TOOLS TO THE COMMUNITY
IT LOOKS LIKE IN A CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE AND SENSITIVE WAY
MAKING SURE THAT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVE ACCESS TO ACCURATE
INFORMATION RELATIVE TO HOW THEY
LIVE HOW THEY LOVE HOW THEY HAVE
SEX HOW THEY TAKE CARE OF THEIR
BODIES HOW THEY ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE HEALTHY. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THAT ALREADY. IN SOME INSTANCES
WE DON'T SOME COMMUNITIES MAY
HAVE AN OVER ABUNDANCE OF THOSE
RESOURCES OTHERS COMMUNITIES MAY
NOT OR IT MAY NOT BE CONSISTENT
FOR EXAMPLE. WE DO NOT HAVE
CONSISTENT ACCESS TO CARE ON OUR
SCHOOL CAMPUSES FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS SOME COMMUNITIES
THAT MIGHT EIGHT HAVE. AN
ABUNDANCE OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE
HIGHLY RESOURCE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MIGHT HAVE ACCESS TO CERTAIN
CARE OTHER DISTRICTS MAY NOT. SO
YOUR BILL THEN WOULD ALLOW
FUNDING TO BE FUNNELED INTO THE
SCHOOLS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PROVIDING ADEQUATE EDUCATION ON
ATTAINING AN ABORTION I WAS
USING AN EXAMPLE. ABOUT
INCONSISTENCY AS IT RELATES TO
ACCESS THIS IS ABOUT A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR- ABORTION ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE NOT ON
A SCHOOL CAMPUS WELL BUT I GUESS
IT GOES BACK TO MY ORIGINAL
QUESTION BECAUSE- IN THE BILL
IT'S AS BUT NOT LIMITED TO. SO
THE FUNDS COULD BE USED TO-
SEND- EITHER MATERIALS OR
PERSONNEL ORDERED YOU KNOW
TRAINING VIDEOS OR WE KNOW
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE INTO
THE SCHOOLS IN ORDER TO EDUCATE.
KIDS ABOUT- ABORTION OR HOW TO
GET IT OR WHAT'S MEDICALLY. I
MEAN RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S AS BUT
NOT LIMITED TO. WELL I MEAN I'M
NOT LIMITED TO COULD INCLUDE A
WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS LIKE
CREATING MATERIALS TO TELL YOU
HOW YOU CAN GO TO MARS- BUT I
WOULD POSIT THAT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
IT COULD INCLUDE YES A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. TO LET'S GO WITH
YOUR EXAMPLE TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO MATERIALS THAT TALK ABOUT
STDS GONORRHEA SYPHILIS WHICH IS
ON THE RAIMES I CAN ALSO TALK
ABOUT DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
ALSO ON THE RISE YOU KNOW THAT
YOUR BILL DOESN'T TALK ABOUT
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY OR
SYPHILIS IT TALKS ABOUT
ABORTION. IT SAYS BRING IN THE
VERY FIRST PARAGRAPH OF YOUR
BILL IT TALKS ABOUT- INCLUDING
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CHOOSE
TO BEAR TRIED OR TO CHOOSE TO
OBTAIN AN ABORTION SO THIS BILL
ISN'T ABOUT. STDS OR ANYTHING
ELSE THIS IT WAS SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT ABORTION WHIPS ABOUT
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INCLUDING ABORTION I JUST A
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THESE. THE
FIVE OR SIX POINTS EXCUSE ME
THAT YOU HAVE ENUMERATED IN YOUR
BILL YOU KNOW WHAT EXACTLY THEY
MEAN I THINK YOU PROVIDE ME SOME
GREAT INSIGHT TODAY AS TO WHAT
YOU ENVISION THAT LOOK LIKE I
JUST WANTED CLARITY. ON THAT
WELL THE CALL AND I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR AND YOUR YOUR CANDOR
AND YOUR MINISTRY. SO IT WILL
INCLUDE ACCESS TO SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND SERVICES INCLUDING ABORTION
I'M NOT GOING TO SHY AWAY FROM
THE FACT- THAT- THIS IS ALSO
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WOMEN. IF
THEY CHOOSE HAVE ACCESS TO
ABORTION SERVICES THANK YOU. L.
COMMENTS ARE QUESTIONS TWENTY
MEMBERS. OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY
ALL RIGHT- SO- SORRY FROM OTHER
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I THINK- YOU TO OTHERS
IN NEED TO SURE AND YEAR AND
ACTUALLY IN. THE CITY THAT YOU
LEAST REPRESENT FOR YOUR IN YOUR
DISTRICT- THE RESOURCES TO SHOW
WE HAVE EQUAL ACCESS SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT IN MY
CLOTHES RESPOND TO A COUPLE OF
THINGS YES AND IN FACT THERE
WASN'T- OPINION PIECE IN THE NEW
YORK TIMES I BELIEVE IT WAS-
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WRITTEN BY ALEXIS MCGILL WHO IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHO TALKED
ABOUT. MARGARET SANGER IN- DOES
NOT EXCUSE THE HISTORY- OF HER
AND IN FACT SHE WAS NT AGAINST-
BLACK PEOPLE AND BROWN PEOPLE
SHE WAS ALSO AGAINST OTHER
IMMIGRANTS POLISH AND IRISH- AND
I ALSO I'M NOT EXCUSING HER I
THINK SHE WAS A PRODUCT OF HER
TIME. I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT ALL WOMEN
OF ALL COLORS AND ETHNICITIES
AND RACES ARE HAVING ABORTION.
ARE GETTING ABORTIONS. EACH AND
EVERY DAY. WOMEN HAVE A RIGHT TO
CHOOSE WHAT THEY WANT TO DO WITH
THEIR BODIES AND THIS IS A BILL
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WOMEN
HAVE A RIGHT TO ACCESS THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED BASED
ON THE CHOICES THAT THEY MAKE
WHEN WE HAD COBIT. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SAID WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE GETTING TESTING AND
VACCINATIONS TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED-
FROM HAVING UNDER RESOURCE
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND THEN WE SAW
NUMBERS OF ARTICLES AND TV
REPORTS OF WHITE PEOPLE. IN
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES IN
LINE GETTING THOSE TESTS AND
GETTING THOSE VACCINATION SHOTS
I WOULD SAYING THAT BECAUSE
REGARDLESS OF WHERE SOMETHING IS
LOCATED PEOPLE WHO NEED THE
RESOURCE WILL MAKE THEIR WAY TO
THAT FACILITY. I ALSO WANT TO
ADD THAT ALTERNATELY AT THE END
OF THE DAY. IT'S NOT SO MUCH
IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO CARE. AND IT IS
ALSO BEING VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY
WOMEN FROM OTHER COUNTRIES AND
FROM STATES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
ARE MAKING THEIR WAY TO
CALIFORNIA. TO FIND ACCESS TO
CARE THAT IS BEING DENIED IN
THEIR STATE. AFGHAN REFUGEES
ASSAULTED AND RAPED BY THE
TALIBAN WHO FIND THEIR WAY TO
TEXAS PREGNANT WANTING AN
ABORTION. ARE MAKING THEIR WAY
TO CALIFORNIA. LATINA IMMIGRANTS
LIVING ON THE BORDER IN TEXAS
NOT ABLE TO ACCESS ABORTION CARE
BECAUSE THERE IS A LACK OF
CLINICS AND PHYSICIANS AND SAFE
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO ABORTION
CARE ARE MAKING THEIR WAY TO
CALIFORNIA TO RECEIVE RESOURCES
IF WE ARE GOING TO UPHOLD. THE
DECLARATION OF THE GOVERNOR THAT
SAYS THIS WILL BE A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN OWN UP TO THAT DECLARATION
BY MAKING SURE THAT FOLKS WITH
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CARE THAT THEY DESERVE AND WANT
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE NOT
THROWING THEM ARE MARGINALIZING
THEM BECAUSE WE ARE ALSO WORKING
VERY HARD TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THOUSANDS OF WOMEN EACH AND
EVERY DAY WHO ARE DESPERATELY
FINDING THEIR WAY. HERE AT THE
END OF THE DAY. REGARDLESS OF IF
YOU PASS THIS BILL OR NOT PEOPLE
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE SEX. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO GET PREGNANT
PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT IS RIGHT
FOR THEIR BODY AND PEOPLE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE ABORTIONS. WE
CAN CREATE A SCENARIO WHERE
FOLKS ARE HAVING ILLEGAL UNSAFE
DEADLY FATAL ABORTIONS OR WE CAN
CREATE A SPACE WHERE WOMEN DO
NOT HAVE TO DIE. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
. THANK YOU SIR COME LONGER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY IT'S BEEN SECONDED BY
CENTER HER TADO CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI HAN
HI MELINDA MELINDA IS NO EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ GROVE GROVE
NO FURTADO HIGH FOR TOTAL AYE
LEYVA. LEYVA AYE LEÓN LIMON I'VE
ROTH ROTH HI RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE
WIENER WIENER HI OKAY THAT STILL
IS EIGHT TWO- THAT STILL IS A
PATH. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO BACK AND LOOK LOOK
AT THE CALLS. TWENTY FIVE THAT'S
JUST TO GO BACK THROUGH THE
FOLLOWERS- ACTUALLY NEED I'LL
JUST START OFF WITH A COUNTER
TOP FORGET IT- SO FIRST WE CAN
BEGIN WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THE ONLY I'M BECAUSE A
COLLEGE AND NUMBER FIVE S. B.
TEN TWENTY THREE BY SERVER TODD
OF A CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS WITH EXACT
CALENDAR. GONZALEZ GROVE HI
GROUP BY K. SETTLERS OUT TEN
ZERO RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. NINE
TWENTY THREE BY CENTER WIENER
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS GONZALEZ GROVE
GROVE NO. THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT
TWO. SIX ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB NINE FIFTY EIGHT BY
CEREMONY CANCELED PLEASE CALL
OUT THE ROLE OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ. GONZALEZ GROVE. OKAY
THAT BILL IS ABOUT EIGHT ZERO.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
TEN NINETEEN BY SARAH GONZALEZ
CONTROL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS GONZALEZ GROVE. I
GROUP BY THAT BILLS OUT TEN
ZERO. EXCITED ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
TEN THIRTY FIVE BY CENTER EGGMAN
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS AND SALAS GROVE.
GROVE I THAT BILLS OUT TEN ZERO
SIX ITEMS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S.
B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN BY CENTER
EGGMAN- CONTROLLED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS GONZALEZ
GROVE GROUP I THAT BILLS OUT TEN
ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO BY
SARAH CAPPIELLO CONTROL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ GROW GROVE NO HER TADO.
LIMÓN HI LIMÓN I THE BILL'S
HELPED SEVEN TO NEXT. ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB FOURTEEN
NINETEEN BY CENTER BACKERS
TACKLED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ GROVE
GROVE NO LIMÓN HI LIMÓN I THAT
BILLS ABOUT EIGHT TWO. AND THEN-
NEXT FILE ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR GLAZERS CONCERN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS GONZALEZ GROW HI GROUP
BY. KILEY MON. OKAY THAT BILL
FELT. EIGHT ONE THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR WAS PULLED.
AT THIRTEEN THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE
PERSON OF COLOR WAS. OKAY YEAH
THERE'S NO SB. THIRTY SIXTY ONE.
THERE I DON'T KNOW I DON'T HAVE
ONE EITHER OKAY. OKAY RIGHT WITH
THAT WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
OF THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND I THINK
ALL THE INDIVIDUAL TO PROTECT
THIS PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY- OR IF YOU
WISH TO SEND IT TO A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE COMMENTS UP PLEASE
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH- OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US WHO WANT TO LOSE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAFF ELEVATE SERGEANTS AS WELL-
AND- THE TECHNICAL STAFF AS
WELL- FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE IN
MAKING A SMOOTH RUNNING BACK
HEARING WE'VE CONCLUDED THIS
AGENDA OF THIS- HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE HEALTH- THIS.
THIS HEARING IS NOW ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.